pour le tata style salut à vous tous
salut Mathieu c'est Mathieu cornette qui
m'accompagne aujourd'hui bonjour bonjour
est-ce que ce que j'arrive à voir ton
live pour l'instant j'ai une pub je peux
pas d'accord bah en tout cas je sais
qu'on est en live Mathieu ça a marché
donc on verra bien mais ça nous fait
plaisir de vous retrouver et moi ça me
fait plaisir de retrouver Mathieu cornet
je voulais dire quand on était jeune on
jouait dans la même catégorie au
championnat de France 5 aussi non 85
tous les deux Mathieu et du coup on sait
jamais jouer pendant les championnats de
France jeunes alors que Mathieu gagnait
quasiment tout le temps qu'en été en
deuxième année
voir tout le temps voir tout le temps
enfin les les cinq éditions que j'ai pu
faire je crois que tu as gagné Mathieu
trois fois en tout cas
ouais tu gagnes un an sur deux c'était
en première année j'ai fait deuxième et
troisième
tu étais quand même bien présent tout le
temps du coup bah ça ça veut dire que au
France et quand junior où j'aurais pu
t'affronter et puis je tombais à côté
voilà
mais en tout cas ça prouvait que je
faisais pas des super championnats de
France alors que Mathieu était très
régulier donc ça compte exactement et du
coup on a quand même eu l'occasion de
faire les Mondiaux quand même en moins
de 18 mois de 20 ans quand j'ai à peu
près réussi mes cheveux à la France j'ai
eu le droit de rejoindre Mathieu au
cheval du monde et c'était des très bons
moments
c'était c'était hyper rigolo
- 18 et moins de 20 ans on a eu du bol
de de faire ça
Turquie et Grèce je dis pas de bêtises
alors moi je vais essayer de vous
retrouver un chat à peu près à peu près
cohérent donc ronde 13 Mathieu qu'est-ce
que tu as envie de nous dire sur ce
tournoi donc peut-être Léon on peut les
rappeler
d'aller voir mon résumé tous les jours
parce que tous les gens je fais une
vidéo sur les stream voilà vous le savez
Mathieu il nous a fait ses petites pubs
et souvent vous relayez que les vidéos
de Mathieu bah sont très sympas donc ça
marche bien en tout cas tes vidéos j'ai
l'impression Mathieu
c'est quand j'analyse des parties
d'ordinateur et complètement absurde
mais des fois c'est assez drôle je
reçois des messages sympas genre d'année
en date j'ai reçu un message de Moussard
à 2h du matin disant que ma vidéo était
vachement bien d'accord
sinon les tournois mais j'ai trouvé
intéressant après c'est toujours
intéressant de faire des tournois où il
y a les très forts qui sont habitués à
jouer et un peu les autres Siders entre
guillemets des jeunes au dents longues
n'ont pas peur de jouer et ouais c'est
toujours un plaisir on attend de voir ce
qu'ils allaient donner à ce niveau là on
voit qu'abdo il confirme une folie en
fait et on voit aussi par exemple qu'un
Erika ici que j'adore ben enfin comme un
pas assez bien mais par contre là ce
matin j'ai fait la vidéo de sa partie
d'hier où il perd qu'on parle mais en
fait c'est un fou furieux il joue pour
le gain tout le temps en fait
mais je pense que ça va sur le long
terme être payant en fait d'avoir cette
attitude là ça me paraît plutôt une
bonne chose donc bon je trouve que c'est
tout à son honneur entre entre
guillemets mais c'est vrai que là ça
passe pas quoi et moi pour dire la
vérité je suis un peu déçu de certains
joueurs bon mais il y a le joueur que
j'aime le moins maintenant du circuit
c'est wesleo je comprends ça quand il
est arrivé il était fantastique et juste
hier il joue pour la nul avec les Blancs
oui c'est terrible c'est ce qu'on a
relayé ça pendant pendant le stream avec
Fatou hier on était nous aussi déçus
puisqu'elle m'a annoncé ah bah tiens il
échange les dames ils auraient pas pour
la nul avec les Blancs et je lui dis non
non il doit avoir peut-être une idée des
fois c'est pas si simple c'est position
et en fait
c'était pas terrible j'étais un peu déçu
de avoir dit ça tu vois Mathieu du coup
j'avais pas bien senti le coup j'avais
pas bien senti le coup mais en vrai que
j'adore franchement là il est en mode
tapis qui fait un tournoi
il essaie s'il a rien dans l'ouverture
il fait nuit avec les Blancs aussi ah
c'est vrai que c'est pas terrible ce
côté-là j'adore mais l'autre jour
l'annulera rapidement un peu énervé mais
bon hier il a gagné avec les Blancs
qu'on dit Ding décevant mais décevant
avant le championnat du monde j'ai envie
de te dire bah il faut se régler vaut
mieux qu'il fasse ses conneries là il
joue déjà c'est ce qu'on leur demande et
joue
[Musique]
il fait froid chez toi non mais alors
j'ai la veste officielle c'est un peu la
tenue de costume-chasse.com parce que
souvent en fait les gens ils confondent
la veste zippée avec un manteau et du
coup je l'ai remis tu vois ils aiment
bien entre guillemets tu dis tu as pas
un truc doudoune derrière ici c'est pas
mal j'ai un petit une petite fourrure
ouais qui trompe un peu son monde j'ai
l'impression
j'ai l'impression que ça t'a plu ce
petit pull je peux dire qu'il fait
fureur
c'est vraiment donc j'étais obligé de le
remettre aujourd'hui pour la dernière il
y en a undertale à des viewers qui est
vraiment là tout le temps il m'a dit
Kevin tu remettras pour la dernière
ronde ta veste doudoune s'il te plaît du
coup je me suis exécuté il faut faire
plaisir à Mathieu tu sais bien
[Musique]
pour la première place bien sûr donc il
faudrait un nul à 12h39 bon ce qui est
possible avec les pièces blanches il
veut aussi gagner sans doute ça te RAF
mais en fait ou une défaite mais bon
pour l'instant il est pas trop il mange
pas trop de ce pain là dans le tournoi
le cas classique je dirais c'est
victoire d'Aniche guéri contre Richard
rapporte et nulle d'abus à torov et là
on est en match de partage voilà bon
après il y a d'autres cas évidemment au
niveau exactement au niveau du
classement juste pour resituer les
choses je dois pouvoir je dois pouvoir
le mettre si je suis pas trop trop
mauvais on va voir ma réactivité
aujourd'hui sur sur ce sujet là et du
coup c'est très très loin hop allez je
vous mets je vous mets ça à l'écran le
classement avant cette dernière ronde on
voit Abdou sa torov qui est en tête avec
8 points talonnés par année je guéri un
demi point mais un demi point à ce
niveau là c'est énorme et wesh les sauts
et Magnus quinzaine en embuscade il faut
que Abdou Sator Rohff perdent caniche
guéri ne gagne pas et que Wesley se
gagne alors qu'il fait qui joue vraiment
très tranquillement comme disait Matt
en théorie on pourrait faire un
départage A4 voilà mais c'est une
théorie quand même très très lointaine
franchement
donc les matchs du jour vous savez
aboussa torov allez blanche compte de
Forest guéri aller blanc contre rapporte
Carlson donc ce sera même pas facile de
battre et regalizi sauf que regaizy va
jouer contre Carcen vraisemblablement
ouais c'est ça aura les Noirs contre
Prague on le voit pas tout envoyer hier
il jouait contre douce à torov et
Matthieu était très déçu nous le disait
de voir qu'il avait même pas essayé en
fait donc bon bah c'est il a peut-être
plus de chance de gagner c'est son
anniversaire je pour le gars exactement
exactement pourquoi pas par contre la
partie qui m'a le plus énervé de sauce
et quand il joue contre parram avec les
Noirs la ninjo il est mieux tout de
suite avec le noir et ici il est même
dit en interview ouais j'ai pas compris
à ce point-là que j'étais mieux j'aurais
peut-être du jeu pour rien mais ouais
mais tu joues jamais pour le lien donc
qu'est-ce qui te surprend en fait
c'est un petit peu c'est un petit peu
décevant et on l'a relayé hier dans
l'ensemble on a eu le droit à des
grosses parties alors des fois c'était
technique et pas fantasque mais
objectivement ça a quand même plutôt pas
mal joué mais il y a quelques joueurs
c'est toujours pareil dans ces tournois
là alors est-ce qu'ils sont en forme
ce qui est dommage c'est que les sauts
comme tu le disais il est plutôt en
forme il joue plutôt bien il a pas de
raison de jouer comme un pelote comme tu
le dis hein c'est c'est ça qui est un
petit peu bizarre il a dit dans
l'interview qui voulait redevenir numéro
2 mondial bon le mec là il a pas
l'ambition d'un numéro ça on peut à la
limite pourquoi pas ça bizarre mais oui
non les vannes les veines aussi décevant
mais bon je l'envoie un peu moins je
sais pas pourquoi parce qu'il a pas les
punitions aussi oui et puis
il est mieux je pense qu'il va je pour
lui c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça la grosse
différence
mais juste pour revenir à une question
dans le chat oui on vous rassure si un
départage a trois ou quatre on connaît
pas le règlement
je regarder mais alors moi je dis
obnubilé par l'aspect technique que ça
marche et pour vous dire c'est plutôt
pas trop mal mais il y a eu quand même
des petites des petites blagues je
disais Mathieu ce matin ce matin c'était
horrible tu dis je le dis c'est parti on
commence ok bon ben
exactement exactement mais ça m'a fait
ça y est donc je vais mettre à jour la
page et je suis le pro du refresh
Mathieu maintenant
et du coup
j'ai toujours
d'accord tu as eu le même problème au
début mais c'est venu très vite mais pas
sur tous les échiquiers il y avait que
l'échiquier de Magnus j'ai annoncé qu'il
était en retard j'avais pas la cam et je
pouvais pas mettre la cam si tu veux
j'étais pas la régie hier alors que là
je le serai et d'ailleurs faudra que je
note les cames je note les
camescom ça marche pas sur le chaise
comme d'accord ok bah cool cool cool
les infos dans le chat merci BJ et salut
à tous ceux qui arrivent
donc il a pas joué une super tort
pourquoi donc si elle est bizarre par
contre on voit que en fait mes scènes
sont revenues normales du coup ben mon
mon petit mixait tout ce que j'ai fait
juste avant de te voir il y a un petit
une petite blague ou alors c'est moi qui
ai pas fait cet échec là c'est pas grave
en direct je vais vous faire un petit
petite manip petite manip en direct je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé
non c'est bien cadré là ça a l'air pas
mal
voilà voilà
mais en fait j'ai l'impression qu'ils se
sont fait un petit kif James comme au
lieu de se mettre 15 minutes de retard
et sans son mi-20 d'accord
voilà le temps que je fasse mes petits
réglages alors moi je dois absolument
noter à Mathieu je vais te laisser
broder et je vais noter quelles sont les
came qui correspondent
Stéphane il avait même pas les cames qui
marchaient l'autre jour ouais bah les
cames vont bien marcher hein franchement
alors la cam1 je sais pas il est pas
installé ça marche pas pour l'instant
elle a quand même deux bah super ils
sont pas installés alors
deux photographes super bon bah du coup
je fais le tour des câbles vous voyez on
vérifie que ça marche aujourd'hui cam4
je sais pas non plus Mathieu c'est la
cagoule en fait on est trop en avance
aujourd'hui Matt c'est vrai que merde
ouais on raconte notre vie j'ai vu tout
salut à toi tous salut à tous évidemment
mais franchement ça ça nous fait bien
rigoler si on est en avance bien
mais les parties moi j'ai les cours en
fait ailleurs
ouais alors du coup tu as les couilles
c'est bizarre c'est bizarre c'est
bizarre et ouais Léo bon c'était tu t'es
fait supprimer ton message il y en a qui
sont bons à la technique parce que c'est
vrai que comme je suis à la technique je
serai mais
[Musique]
des fois il faut des trucs bizarres mais
c'est pas les pires faut pas non plus
oui et en ce moment vous l'avez vu alors
il y a quand même une certaine
saturation des serveurs parce que
justement ça marche très bien voilà donc
du coup on va on va être un indulgent et
vous inquiétez pas bon c'est pas
il est dur Léo il est dur on dirait les
débuts de Microsoft voilà bon après ça
veut pas plaire à tout le monde les
robots dans l'ensemble à titre perso
comme je joue beaucoup sur chetcom je me
suis vraiment habitué après c'est
peut-être ça aussi après il y en a qui
préfèrent d'autres sites vous avez le
droit
non mais je veux sur les chaises on peut
dire non c'est bien mais qu'est-ce comme
il y a quand même pas mal de contenu il
y a plein de trucs gratuits et des trucs
payants il y a des tournois c'est pas
mal en rapport si je lignes de la Roser
douteuse mais intéressante donc ils ont
décidé de faire une demi-heure non je
sais pas je suis pas au courant Mathieu
je ne peux pas te dire malheureusement
j'étais tellement content d'avoir réussi
à passer les embûches techniques Mathieu
oh là d'un coup tu as vu
les coups sont arrivés vite hein waouh
donc alors je vais me remettre sur le
match qui nous intéresse le plus puisque
abusa torov est en tête il joue le
Jordan van forest
Matthieu pas grand chose à dire pour
l'instant sur cette taille manov bon
c'est c'est du classique trois c'est le
coup principal ok ici il y a plein de
coins hyper intéressant il y a un 3 qui
est à la mode qui était un coup qui a
été
montrer au niveau par Carlson il est
parti très récent des Damas 3 qui est
l'ancienne grande ligne oui en fait ça
grenier c'est plutôt F3
d'ailleurs oui il y a une période de
petits coups à la mode qui est français
ici est hyper intéressant d'accord
il a montré qu'il est très très bien
préparé hier encore il a gêné en tout
cas dans le début
bien sûr
il avait joué 50 Magnus à vague qui a
quelques années il avait rejet cette
année en top 2 ce qu'on ne m'obsession
dans le match contre chat Chalon
classique ouais tu peux nous expliquer
l'idée
la cage G4 parce qu'en gros les blancs
soit l'idée de faire un G4 G5 soit juste
dames G3
reprendre de H et de mettre la pression
sur le pionchette et de te dire ton
problème avec ton roi c'est que tu sais
pas où le mettre grand rock il y a quand
même des trous sur les cases noires et
petit rock aura une faiblesse en
Hachette les blancs vont pouvoir pas me
doubler sur la tu peux montrer une ligne
par exemple à la place 5
et en fait souvent le défaut de cette
position pour les Noirs c'est ce pion
achète et les blancs vont jouer au grand
Rogue F3 G4 améliorer leur position et
tu peux avoir un problème sur ce pion un
petit plus sans risque on peut même
décès la case des 6 il y a pas trop de
cible côté blanc donc les Noirs les
Noirs galères dans cette position c'est
un petit plus cette potion à deux
résultats sans doute on souffre
longtemps avec baignoire pour apprendre
à stouf oui à 10 balles à jouer mais en
fait grenier j'ai parlé avec lui de
cette ligne il a dit j'ai inventé la
ligne il considère qu'il avait peut-être
pas joué en premier dans la base mais il
avait déjà avant en fait c'est dans ce
sens là
c'est celui qui me l'a dit donc à chaque
fois plus ambitieux de la part de Jordan
mes analyses faudrait comprendre
qu'est-ce qu'il veut sur ce qui est
Francis et qu'est-ce qu'il veut sur dame
je crois justement c'est la question que
je vais te poser
ce qui est
ici avec Dame G7 x 5 est-ce que c'est
jouable
ça marche et donc ça doit être ça son
idée non parce qu'en fait normalement le
coup normal c'est genre cavalier F6
et là sur dame J3 tu peux pas jouer D6
parce que tu as est-ce que ça peut être
ça son idée juste
parce que là j'ai vraiment fait ça en
l'air Fouday six ne marcherait plus
c'est pas le seul coup on peut jouer
juste derrière dame je crois que c'est
pas très terrible ici parce que je peux
prendre avec un G4 non là il y a plus
foueuse 50 vous voyez la différence on
joue au jeu des différences avec Mathieu
ils sont plutôt au grand rock le coup
parce que
[Musique]
parce que sur dame G3 il y a prise et
que j'ai 4 d'accord dans mon seigneur je
croyais que c'était cavalier au 5G 3
j'ai peut-être vu une partie mais après
il est deux en fait grand rock j'ai joué
cette position genre fou béca tu es pas
bon parce qu'on prend en C6 c'est fou
des 4
d'accord
parce que je reprends de quoi ici avec
les noirs
et là Mathieu nous a expliqué E5 dames
G3 du classique voilà on peut parce que
sinon E5 c'était vraiment très gênant on
faisait sauté un petit peu le fou et il
y avait des idées de fou français 3 pour
éclater le roi ou le petit
veut sur grand rock
qui comme le coup logique peut-être
cavalier E5 dame G3 H4
ce que je pense
moi ok mon intuition j'aurais joué qui
est processus
pour éviter que du coup
parce que je sais que précise précise
d'Afro a du sens
donc prise d'abord me paraît logique
normalement tu reprends B plutôt après
dame mais
pour essayer d'avoir un gros centre
et là on a une grosse avance de
développement la colonne B on devrait
pouvoir contrôler peuvent même peut-être
mettre le roi à un moment à leur pièce
c'est une vraie question contre la
poussée E5 c'est important aussi parce
que sinon ça pourrait être vite très
difficile ce genre de chez moi dans la
silienne
non ok à chaque intéressant ok ce qui
est cool c'est qu'on a un fight Abdou
est pas dans sa prépa pour une fois vent
de forêt joue une petite ligne mais
comme il est bien préparé il a toujours
des idées il a fait des franchement
c'est un récital toute la semaine compte
que ça pétrole contre Kawana ça hier ça
ligne sur la regodie c'est la folie la
nouveauté qui ne veut contreding sur la
mer en c'est incroyable
ok guérir on peut faire guérir un pense
comme donc le numéro 2 du tournoi qui
joue contre rapporte qui mine de rien
c'est pas du tout de bruit dans cet
endroit on a l'impression qu'il passe en
mode fantôme il a fait un mauvais début
de tournoi puis après il a trois
victoires
et donc c'est une roseur G6 qui est
censé être un peu douteux c'est plus une
ouverture de rapide bien sûr donc là
pour te dire Mathieu cette position j'ai
fait jouer cette ligne à ma femme en
en Championnat d'Europe féminin elle
avait perdu contre moi il s'appelle
cosin seva je pense
et en fait c'est hyper dynamique
récemment il y a des parties je pense de
reggae ici il y a dû le jouer
quand il réfléchit si tu arrives à jour
et l'idée c'est qu'après prise
précepti c'est quand même le seul coup
qui peut réfuter quand je reprends de
eux en fait j'ai un avantage de
développement et en fait je vais sans
doute perdre des six on va dire on s'en
fout on idée c'est de jouer cette F5 et
de jeux pour la avec la paire de fou
contre qui t'a perdu on perd le pion des
6 mais on a les cases noires Mathieu et
du coup on joue à de la paire de fou
comme ça se fait dans le monde moderne
on voit beaucoup de parties de très haut
niveau sur ce sujet là quoi donc là je
sais qu'il y a plusieurs écoles donc fou
B5 qui a été joué c'est un des grands
coups l'autre option c'est de jouer
juste que le Jardin des Deux qui ait des
seins qui est grand rock pas forcément
pour manger le pion direct
mais je sais que les deux existent là
j'avoue que j'ai pas analysé ça depuis
longtemps
je suis en train de Matthieu c'est pour
ça que je te réponds pas trop je regarde
juste les caméras je suis un petit tour
des came pour voir qui est placé ou
parce que c'est toujours un peu la
surprise
donc
c'est un peu une énigme c'est quelqu'un
que je connais bien dans le sens où je
l'ai joué deux fois et j'ai déjà passé
trois quatre heures à parler avec lui
dans une soirée plusieurs fois je
m'entends bien avec lui mais c'est un
mélancolique tu vois qu'il est triste de
bosser les échecs il aime bien jouer
mais bosser ça le fait chier moi je
trouve qu'il me fait de la peine en ces
interviews
c'est dommage parce que c'est comme un
joueur fantastique fantasque
je suis en train de faire
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette chiotte
donc ok est-ce que tu veux que je te
mette un autre échiquier avec la partie
de Carl Seine
comme tu veux donc là c'est que le début
faut baisser 5 ou 17 elle est blanc
essaie de se rappeler de la théorie moi
je me rappelle pas non plus oui c'est ça
les joueurs ils doivent à chaque fois
c'est monstrueux d'ailleurs je trouve
qu'ils arrivent à se farcir et j'aime
très bien
petite question
Mathieu tu en es où toi Mathieu est-ce
que tu arrives à encore avoir assez de
temps de jeu je sais que maintenant tu
es dans l'entraînement particulièrement
l'entraînement de haut niveau
tarif toujours à jouer très
régulièrement j'avais pas regardé ta
fiche feed Mathieu
j'ai en 2016 j'ai décidé de me bouger le
cul j'ai retravaillé pour moi ce qui
m'était pas arrivé depuis des années et
j'ai devenu chemin de France je suis
passé en 2017
2600 jusqu'à 2120 après j'ai eu une très
mauvaise période 2018 après il y a eu la
ma fille arrivée en 2019 donc c'est une
période un peu particulière donc j'ai un
peu mis de côté et cet été j'avais une
mauvaise période et
je me suis remotivé ce que j'ai été
sélectionné en équipe de France en fait
parce qu'il y a eu pas mal de
désistement devant du coup j'ai bien
bossé j'ai fait un très bon choix de
France où j'ai perdu un demi finale
contre Jules Moussa qui a gagné le
tournoi mais en juin des bonnes parties
donc ça m'a remotivé les Olympiades j'ai
plutôt bien joué et donc j'ai les
périodes genre là par contre je j'ai pas
joué je devais jouer en décembre
finalement j'ai pas joué je rejoue que
fin mars d'accord oui oui c'est ça fait
quand même des grosses périodes
d'interaction j'ai encore envie de jouer
j'ai encore cette j'aime jouer encore
mais j'ai l'avantage qui est aussi un
inconvénient c'est qu'en fait si je
gagne ou que je joue pas très bien c'est
pas si grave parce que c'est plus ma
source de revenus principal je comprends
ça change d'un côté je peux je veux plus
tranquille mais d'un côté je me mets
moins de pression et du coup tu joues
pas forcément mieux toi donc il y a des
inconvénients des avantages mais prendre
soin du plaisir à jouer c'était j'ai
vraiment pris du plaisir à jouer mes
deux tournois
je crois que ça dure je comprends je
comprends c'est super bah c'est super de
pas avoir de pression
financières dans le fait de jouer
ensemble
pour les honoraires je me suis mis une
pression parce que je voulais pas être
ridicule ah oui oui c'est autre chose
ouais c'est autre chose je comprends je
comprends c'est pas facile ce genre de
compète surtout que pour le coup là
c'est des compètes de très très haut
niveau et voilà j'étais assez content
juste un anecdote hier guéri il a dit il
savait que la nouveauté de Van Forest a
existait il a dit ok j'ai pas pensé ce
genre de truc c'est difficile de retenir
parce que l'ordi dit avantage noir et
quand tu te prépares avec les Noirs
c'est dur d'avoir en priorité à se
rappeler une ligne ou tu es censé être
mieux je regarde toujours celle où tu es
en danger ou tégalise c'est compliqué
vachement aimé sans explication qui est
ils disent pour lui c'était une ligne
trop difficile à retenir parce que c'est
une ligne que l'ordi un pas moi je
comprends
bien sûr mais il dit il y a des mecs
comme vent de Forest ou double qui
peuvent rentrer exprès dans des lignes
là parce que ils se disent typiquement
que les gens vont pas la regarder on va
pas s'en rappeler et il a eu raison
d'ailleurs
rigolo bonne anecdote donc on prend pas
de dire à se faire défoncer c'est pour
ça que quand je fais un tournoi j'essaie
de le faire bien ouais c'est normal
aussi on fait un petit tour yes ou tu as
pas fini de noter c'est un peu galère
mais sauf m'a rappelé la petite mise à
jour des cames c'est un truc un petit
peu bizarre voilà et du coup pour
l'instant j'en ai quatre je sais que la
cam1 c'est guérir la porte ensuite il y
a Kemer gokeh et il faut que je fasse
des refresh j'ai commenté deux fois avec
lui il a pas eu une cam
[Musique]
ce que je fais la petite je fais la
petite manip mais ça ça marche pas
forcément si cela j'ai réussi à la
remettre par exemple mais ça peut ça
peut faire des petites blagues voilà
il est très jeune il est très sympa je
l'avais rencontré cette année
d'ailleurs je crois que les gens
simultané je me rends compte moi j'avais
gagné quand même mais non mais c'est un
gros espoir mais il est tout petit donc
c'est dur de de se prononcer encore
comme dit Mathieu voilà maintenant le
chat est-ce que quelqu'un se rappelle
d'Adrien Leroy et oui bah oui bah en
tout cas moi je m'en rappelle Mathieu je
vois très bien où tu veux arriver mais
effectivement des gens vont pas
connaître et bien sûr
il est coiffé champion du monde 10 oui
oui c'est ça il a été attendu comme
meilleur COBAL pro éventuellement et
après il a arrêté
mais même nous notre génération
Fred marquez se rappelle et bien sûr
Édouard Bonnaire l'âge peut-être
erreur Bonneuil il était plus jeune que
nous en tout cas dans Mathieu je pense
et du coup
[Musique]
Stéphane qui dit qu'après ça marchait
nickel et est-ce que tu avais les
problèmes de mettre à jour la page ou
pas expliqué comment mettre à jour mais
bon la manip est juste un petit peu bête
mais
[Musique]
bien sûr
donc on a eu un début Réty sorte de
système un peu West indien c'est ce que
je joue avec les noirs on a vu cette
partie aux candidats c'était mvl avec
les blancs avec ce schéma qui avait été
joué par nepom semble-t-il Mathieu
double fiancetto contre
petit rock
et oui donc des 5 bah c'est assez
classique même dans les schémas avec
aussi de toute façon il y a le même
schéma pour pour museler le fouet
j'ai une partie dans la base en project
League où j'avais joué ça contre
Vendeville avec le noir donc là il y a
plusieurs coups jouer à 50 automatique
moi je joue moi je joue à 5
il y a un coup qui était assez
surprenant qui avait été joué par
Houilles fan
c'était un dames 8 est-ce que c'est ici
je dirais non
non à 5 c'est le coup
à 5 c'est le coup ok vas-y joue à 5
et quand je me rappelle ma partie j'ai
montré ça il y a plein de parties de
marquants par la base
mon cavalier avec avec B4 et l'idée
c'est que si tu fais le cadre pour
prendre le centre j'ai le 5
il faudra bien que je réagisse par
rapport à ça et D6 c'est hyper moche
dans cette config avec la grosse classe
C6 qui serait laissée donc 4 Mathieu
nous dit hop on fait E5 on empêche E5
des blancs parce que sinon ils ont tout
le centre et ils nous dégagent nos
cavaliers c'est beaucoup quand même
et du coup sur cahier des quatre à cinq
le coup principal attend 2 secondes
qu'il y a 4K du sens
mais il me manque un truc
comme ça ça n'existe pas ces choses là
faut être plus concret
je pense à Dame CE2 mesdames tu peux pas
prendre en dessin
effectivement envoyer un vis-à-vis
contre le 5 c'est assez logique en fait
plus pragmatique peut-être
ah oui prends des 5 c'est ça attends
c'est que ouais E5 faut prendre
et prends des 5
faut prendre le 7 qui apprend cette
ronde
voyez cavalier prend ses trois je
comptais faire B prend ses mais le fou
besa tu es protégé donc du coup il y a
pas de souci et Mathieu il a affaibli à
structure donc F4 E5 c'est pénible
pourquoi j'arrive pas à me rappeler quel
est le coup principal
dans mon genre de pas me rappeler il y a
un truc avec kb3 est-ce que c'est ici
plein de fois
tu as vu je touche je te fais un gros
progrès technique j'ai juste pas la
carte pour l'instant je sais pas où il
est les cames sont bizarres mais je l'ai
un deux trois quatre donc j'ai quatre
cames sur 6 déjà au fur et à mesure du
stream souffle mais en tout cas j'ai
laissé le mode studio je savais pas
qu'il fallait laisser le mode studio
tout le temps pour pour faire la mise à
jour des cames
oui c'est vrai mais en fait c'est pas si
grave par exemple je sais qu'il y a une
partie il y a une partie la case B5 il y
a une partie là j'ai compris donc faut
bien faire quelque chose aussi c'est
aussi par exemple genre B3
B3 qui est un coup normal ok là tu peux
commencer par un torroïde mais tu peux
faire le 5 disons et quand il me fait
kb5 je peux jouer aussi pour le plan
cavalieux 8 d'accord avec ça il y a une
partie de marquant comme ça
c'était la première année contre
contre l'Islande et si la journée c'est
une manœuvre assez connue d'ailleurs je
me demande dans cette fameuse partie que
je t'ai cité là le entre mvl et
une époque il y avait aussi cette
manœuvre me semble-t-il si je dis pas de
bêtises
qui était pourtant le coup principal
c'est assez surprenant alors est-ce que
c'est là où tu es pas obligé de jouer en
fait si tu fais E5 il va juste pour
expliquer si tu veux 5 kb3 est censé
donner un petit avantage d'après la
théorie
légère pour enlever le cavalier c'est 5
pièces et le coup un peu plus moderne
parce que le grand coup c'est E5 et B3
quand tu prends en B3 il y a une partie
de virer que je me rappelle c'est agrise
pas complètement et du coup si je fais
la même idée avec un valet B3
je prends
et je peux peut-être bouger mon cavalier
E6 peut-être après au C6 s'il te plaît
en plus j'ai même pas vu mais je me
menace du coup des petits des petits C5
intéressantes
petite pression
que je suis en train de réfléchir
ici est-ce que je me lasse pas grand
chose en fait
est-ce que je peux jouer
oui prendre ici c'est peut-être pas si
bon par contre je peux jouer fou aux
trois peut-être à Mathieu pour prendre
dans de meilleures conditions enfin
essayer de te faire prendre justement là
on regarde les structures de pions avec
Mathieu on essaie de comprendre est-ce
que les blancs peuvent prendre ici ça
mettrait peut-être une pression
peut-être sur les dames avec B2 qui
deviendrait faible
déjà
transposerait jouable avec l'idée de
revenir avec un cahier dans des six mais
est-ce que je peux pas jouer de 6 il me
semble que c'est pas un truc malin ici
du coup j'ai l'heur de quoi inverse
peut-être non ça marche pas ce que tu as
dit ici je sais pas
oui il va falloir que tu fasses un truc
une bizarre rire avec je sais pas tu vas
reprendre le 6 et sur quel est prononcé
5 tu vas peut-être faire fouger d'eux
mais ça doit être bizarre quand même
donc là c'est intéressant
voilà on essaie d'activer nos pièces
dans les deux camps les blancs plus
d'espace donc c'est plus difficile pour
Magnus un petit peu il a les pièces
noires c'est du grand classique
Mathieu alors je vais quand même
vérifier que tu veux pas non tu vas pas
te donner je vais jouer X3
pour te faire prendre
ouais et après je vais mettre un je vais
faire ouais ouais non mais c'est
toujours mieux pour les blancs
c'est parce que tu joues pour le gain tu
gardes toutes les pièces adjokovic a
gagné d'ailleurs merci Mathieu merci
Mathieu pour le
il a gagné en 3 7
parenthèses vous savez qu'on aime les
petites parenthèses
je me rappelle pas c'est ce que je a 5
il a 5 direct OK
sur internet mais c'est jamais très
probant qui est bizarre je me rappelle
pas et B3 il y a kb5 aussi qui existe
mais moi je sais que je faisais A5 avant
avant je préférais
donc on aura cavalier B3 ça a du sens
comme ça on garde notre espace au centre
avec les Blancs on va pas prendre en
passant on perdrait
si je ne peux plus en profiter
non et mon idée c'est quand tu prends en
ce 5 tu voudrais reprendre dedans
moi j'ai plus trop envie de prendre
maintenant est-ce que je peux pas jouer
le 4
FDC
poussez vite et je pourrais être 5
il faut faire des fois tu peux avoir des
fois
non mais là
c'est pas si simple de jouer
j'ai réussi à enterrer le fou B7 mais tu
m'as dit je peux le ressortir pas six
maintenant que tu as que j'ai fait
cavalier B3 à 5 et surtout tu vas manger
le fou en faisant cahier des 300 doute
et je m'attaquais ça
mais c'est pas si facile
ok non
je pense que tu dois prendre mais
du coup ça c'est intéressant donc
peut-être à trois ici
bien sûr donc à 5 peut-être mais est-ce
que tu vas me donner à grosse casse B5
c'est pas sûr il y a un des 6
pourquoi pas et là à 5 je commence à
regarder des trucs un peu un peu Gamble
comme des 6 ça serait beau mais c'est
pas sûr que ça marche évidemment
pour les cases mais des sites
[Musique]
tu dis ça mais tu ne le ferais pas je
regarderai je regarderai Mathieu
évidemment mais je le ferai sans doute
pas effectivement je regardais cavalier
B5 Mathieu va me poser le problème avec
cavalier 8 et il a dit je veux le béton
armé à Cadd 6 et là ça commencera à être
dur parce qu'il pourra à terme balancer
les pions à la loi il aura un cavalier
tu dois essayer de préparer BK
[Musique]
on va voir allez on va voir
c'est une Espagnole ça fait partie des
comment dire des cames que je ne trouve
pas
un petit un petit refresh
4 encore
en ligne de darkangles donc là cette
ligne avec tous ces zincenglet c'est pas
forcément le bon nom quand on écoute
Vlad parler de cette ligne
ça devrait pas s'appeler comme ça mais
bon
[Musique]
tu vois la cam 5 regarde Mathieu ce que
tu la vois cette belle cam 5 là que je
Tamise
le mode et si je fais une transition tu
vas voir ce que je vois
ça va vous faire marrer voilà le genre
de Cam que j'ai
est-ce que
tu vois et c'est le genre de CAM qui me
fait tilter parce que je cherche les
cames depuis tout à l'heure et voilà
voilà ce qu'on me propose parfois et du
coup ça c'est un peu énervant bon allez
c'est pas grave
OK et donc du coup c'est une ligne
à la mode
ok j'ai fait mon petit truc mais j'ai
toujours pas trouvé cette punaise de cam
hello à tous ceux qui arrivent du coup
voilà arcangles alors elle devrait
s'appeler comment cette arkangle je sais
pas écouté Mathieu excuse-moi
d'avoir joué après il y a godena mais
godenas c'est plus
en fait c'est sur A4 quand tu joues
plutôt foot B7 que tu as B8 mais du coup
là les Blancs n'ont pas joué à caca ton
jeu pour cette 3D 4 alors qui est assez
la mode je me rappelle Sophie mie avec
complètement dominé morized dans le
fermer de Grand Maître où il est devenu
grand maître j'étais sur place quand je
l'ai entraînais et
[Musique]
mais bon ça c'est Cabana connaît très
bien et Ding pas du tout
alors c'est un peu à la mode ce fouet
trois cadd2 sans aller chercher des
refuses à base de la 4
et là les enjeux de la question c'est
est-ce qu'on peut jouer des 5 à chaque
fois c'est la question qu'il faut se
poser à tous les coups
les Noirs menacent présents sur
j'étais en train de chercher
de nos têtes Matthieu c'était un grand
moment c'est un grand moment il n'y a
pas une fin de Moller aussi avec fusée 5
mais c'est fou c'est 5 très tôt je crois
que ça existe ou pas Mathieu
donc mais c'est vrai que tout le monde
parle de larkangle honnêtement ton
histoire de yourtaef c'était pas arrivé
jusqu'en Bretagne je peux te dire
Mathieu très honnêtement
c'est dur d'être partout
c'est les plus saines presque pour les
normes mais c'est pas si simple ouais
donc là les enjeux de la position c'est
si tu fais cavalier F1 je pense que tu
as un prénom 4 direct
tu veux pas jouer un coup
là il y a déjà puis on prend des quatre
il y a un prénom à 4
et donc du coup faut que c'est pas beau
si tu fais un coup neutre
[Musique]
après Mathieu c'est ça
si je reprends une pièce c'est pas
l'idée je voulais garder mon centre donc
du coup on prend et là tu me saoules à
double menace après même ça c'est pas
c'est pas fini parce que sur le coup
j'aime pas me mettre en face d'une tour
c'est con
je suis pas content de me mettre en face
de toi
de le coup principal ou A3 je sais pas
un dessin que c'est toujours le coup à
quelques donc là il y a deux options
soit il faut prendre 3 soit puis en
français 6
non soit
là et en fait pourquoi il revient de
quoi vendre c'est Camille hyper
intéressant
reviens on revient encore un peu
Touring là
de tout manger c'est ça Mathieu que tu
vas nous dire si tu veux le montrer si
tu veux prendre
et puis en français
et vous voyez qu'à la fin de notre
supermarché on a fait mange mange mange
mange mange mange mange mange et ben on
se fait banane parce que notre tour est
attaqué
il est hyper utile c'est un coup très
fin dans mes souvenirs c'était pas fou
ces deux ici mais ça doit l'être mais il
faut juste pour montrer aussi à la place
de tomber 8 il pouvait pas prendre en D4
de l'espagnol dès qu'on vend 4 avec un
cavalier faut pas se faire avoir avec
vos dessins mais tour B8 on peut dire
que c'est quand même un coup de
l'ouverture arkangal c'est quand même
Mathieu qui est qui est classique
du coup tous ces deux
tourbé donc maintenant faut baisser donc
là l'idée c'est que des 5 on peut se
permettre de prendre 3 bien sûr le
supermarché fonctionne parce qu'au bout
du supermarché maintenant regardez la
différence ok on fait le supermarché et
prise B7 n'attaque rien donc là ce
serait la catastrophe voilà donc faut
prendre 3D français 6 c'est la
catastrophe on perd du matériel donc
surtout prends le 3 on n'a pas le choix
on va reprendre 3 bon de la tour et 7 et
vont jouer pour C6 et
on a le mauvais fou contre un fou qui va
s'ouvrir avec la rupture proposée par
Mathieu c'est 6 je pense que vous
comprenez ça facilement
on nous demande pourquoi l'arc anglais
c'est bien réputé pour jeux pour le gain
non c'est une ouverture saine en fait
c'est surtout ça
après plus pour le gain qu'une autre pas
forcément mais je sais pas si vous
rappelez du candidat
pas le dernier celui d'avant quand
caronage ou ça deux fois avec le noir
contre un VL il avait des idées et c'est
des positions très compliquées du coup
c'est bien pour jouer pour le gain
un statue constitue quand même pas mal
pour perdre
en fait c'est juste c'est moins correct
là winammer darkanga c'est censé être ok
[Musique]
il y a quand même pas tant que ça de
d'alternative aussi pour jouer avec les
Noirs garder les pièces et pas souffrir
sur l'espagnol c'est c'est juste que
c'est une ouverture qui est excellente
avec les Blancs qui garantit un petit
plus et du coup bah au niveau arkanga
c'est une des une des alternatives parce
qu'on va pas jouer enfin bon il y en a
plein qui aiment pas la berlinoise etc
voilà c'est des choix quoi si on veut
jouer pour quelque chose voilà
j'avais regardé ça il y a pas longtemps
moi j'avais A3 ici donc j'avais bien
raison on a l'impression de la partie je
pense que le coup que j'avais c'était à
3 je viens de vérifier
non je préviens quand je regarde sur ma
base ce que j'ai j'ai à trois ici bon
c'est logique parce que tu nous as dit
tu nous as tout dit avec la menace en
fait noire donc à trois fesses mais
c'est plus la question la presse
voilà bon les Noirs ils font on imagine
qu'il faut rien Mathieu pour juste que
tu nous montre comment jouer avec avec
les Blancs ici est-ce qu'on ferait B4 B4
qui coûte on améliore qu'on améliore
juste ouais on va mettre le feu en B1
peut-être déjà comme ça tu arrêteras
peut-être
des cinq C4 aussi voilà les ruptures on
va trouver une rupture à l'aile d'arme
mais on prépare
et avec les noirs et je sais pas quel
est le mien même ça direct peut-être
[Musique]
dû à mon emprise centrale et donc à
l'espace central
le prince
bon c'est normal en même temps ça fait
vraiment
ok de mettre lequel en G6 donc j'ai joué
ça un peu avec les Noirs j'en ai jamais
joué mais j'ai travaillé pour mes élèves
quand je disais marquant jouer ça
c'était pas un hasard mais est-ce que on
commence par cavalier 7 on fait ed qui a
eu 7 comment tu expliques Mathieu bon
digne il a pris 20 minutes autant c'est
pas non plus une folie mais
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qui a été un
petit peu différent voilà je pense qu'il
est il a pas l'habitude du coup il
connaît tout il va trouver mais tu dis
pas
le plan principal sur cette ligne
par exemple tu peux mettre le foot en 17
au lieu de tomber une foule ça tu peux
le mettre en un coup en dessert
parce qu'en fait des fois faut juste
expliquer aussi c'est quand tu fais des
cinq cavaliers 7 dans l'absolu je parle
des petites flèches alors
ça peut être complètement jouable pour
les Noirs aussi ça dépend des fois mais
pas quand c'est moins bon qu'avec un
fond d'essai parce que là il t'apprenne
l'idée de prendre avec le pion C c'est
plus quand le Fou est sur l'autre
diagonale je comprends voilà ça
donnerait pas trop envie quand même mais
bon
ça donne quoi
avec l'idée dès que tu fais le 5 je mets
quelque chose en dessin
qui est assez thématique d'ailleurs ce
genre de choses dans pas mal d'ailleurs
de variantes espagnoles avec des fois
des C5 alors là ce qui est un peu
différent c'est que le fond n'est pas
fuites
même des C4 et tu continues à avancer je
pense que j'essaie d'abord sur ton grand
classique et d'ailleurs Mathieu tu ne te
trompes pas parce que c'est joué
sur la winver d'ailleurs j'ai pas j'ai
pas saisi
ça me surprend qu'on parle pas de la
winver pour le mateur jeu pour le gain
mais je dis ouais mais c'est moins bien
ça c'est mieux pour les blancs
OK
on va dire que c'est presque la seule
idée noire sinon subissait le jeu
d'amélioration que tu évoqué donc là on
joue dynamique avec les noirs on change
la structure et on a une idée comme tu
l'as donné c'est 5 à vallée G6 alors que
sans cela la position était dure
E5 j'ai l'impression que ça passe pas du
tout non cinq tactique mais les pièces
sont pas l'air si bien passé pour
s'engager là-dedans on n'a pas de
batterie Dame des trois peut-être des
cinq
avec l'idée de prise prise mais tu me
joue ces 6 probablement
bien
ce que Mathieu propose kg 6 qui a du
sens pour améliorer le cavalier des 4 et
là il y a un petit problème sur le pion
c'est de voir un gros problème sur le
long terme il y aura du Tour c'est un
comme on l'a évoqué et on va travailler
sur la casse faible et sur le pion C7
donc ça ne serait pas une bonne idée
structurelle
donc qui avait lieu 7 décembre prise C6
voilà on est jaloux de du centre adverse
de la fixation sur notre pion C7 c'est
un pion mou hein j'en ai parlé hier et
puis arriéré sur colonne semi-ouverte
donc on va le taper voilà puis
on dur ils sont protégés avec les pions
et les pions mouilles ils sont protégés
avec les pièces et les pièces sont pas
contentes de protéger les pions c'est la
galère
il y a un équilibre dynamique
dans l'espagnol quand même le jeu de
pièces je prends je pense que je
reviendrai avec le cavalier d'ailleurs
dans cette position et on le cavalier
peut venir Volter un petit peu partout
le pion décide donne la case E5 et en
plus il peut y avoir des dessins à
certains moments surtout si je jouais
cavalier 5 faut pas se prendre un gros
E5 bien gras et se retrouver mal quoi
ça va être intéressant mais je m'attends
pas
donc du coup on va on va continuer
peut-être un petit tour des stades
qui émerge la partie des jeunes les deux
font une bonne fin de tendance ok ça
c'est quelque chose que je connais
du coup c'est
trois fous de 2
tu peux revenir c'est intéressant les
blancs de coin les Noirs vont jouer un
ordre de coin intéressant on a vu jouer
bah en fait c'est
dans une inzo c'est gookage d'ailleurs
qui c'est mal débrouillé sur une
situation assez similaire en début de
tournoi Mathieu
je me suis pris un coup par contre
Prague en 2022 j'ai inversé de ligne
c'est ballot B6 donc c'est le coup c'est
prendre des c'est le grand coup faut des
trois et là il a joué qu'un coin un peu
la mode
dans le tournoi mal joué ce type de
position c'est pas ça mais il a perdu tu
te rappelles de cette partie Mathieu
dans le tournoi et ça a été vraiment
très triste il s'est développé non mais
c'était pas pareil non c'était c'était
une ragondine il y avait un damaka qui
est ici
et du coup il avait donné son coup de
case noire et c'est pris une raclée sur
15 mois dans la partie
et en fait ok donc Toro 8 c'est quoi ce
malin parce qu'en fait tu te gardes du
foie à 6 donc retarde au développement
noir et on joue pour E4 si je comprends
bien dans cette position Mathieu c'est
le seul moyen de faire parler l'avantage
de développement
pas toujours mais petit rock c'est pas
le coup évident normalement pour CE1 est
plus joué
donc tours
[Musique]
en fait c'est un truc bête mais c'est ça
c'est pas évident à comprendre quand tu
joues ces cinq c'est mieux de le faire
avec le foot derrière la chaîne de pion
que devant bah sinon tu vas le faire
carotter ou embêter en fait ok il y a
des lignes où ça va d'ailleurs mais moi
il m'avait jeu dame c'est de Prague
à la place de torsion rock
moi j'avais je foutais
dans la partie moi j'ai déjà vu une
photo 8 l'idée c'est que des fois on
peut sortir le foot C8 ailleurs quand
ben c'est ce qui paraît bizarre c'est ce
qui s'est passé dans la partie donc rock
il faut des six
parce que tu veux jouer C5 et le fou il
est mieux placé en D6 quand F8 et l'idée
que sur faux D6 c'est que je contrôle la
classe de 5 donc il y a plus le plan
habituel des cavaliers E5 F4 que toi tu
connais bien je pense donc tu aimes bien
et du coup faut laisser si kb5 en fait
tu t'en fous tu pourras partir en F8 et
tu vas jouer C5 en un coup et qui a eu
des cinq sert à rien donc faut des si si
avantage de l'ordre de coups et j'ai une
question que juste voilà qui me tente
donc je te parlais de A3 B4 j'ai dû le
voir dans des positions similaires
comment ça se comment ça joue si les
blancs arrivent à faire à 3 B4
est-ce que tu vas quand même jouer pour
C5 au niveau de la structure entre un
exemple
ici je vais partir moi
sur internet en tout cas c'est une bonne
gueule
et tu joues cette position pion pendant
soit tu fais ce que moi j'avais joué
j'avais joué en mode je m'en fous
j'avais le jeu pourtant 8 cavalier 4 et
je veux pour l'attaque et j'avais maté
d'ailleurs d'accord tu tu joues tu
bloques le centre avec ton cavalier 4 et
ensuite tu transfert tes pièces à la tu
joues pour l'attaque quoi donc pour
revenir à ta question donc dans la dans
l'ordre de coup de la partie
[Musique]
pour éviter les C5 justement
moi mais c'est possible que c'est ça qui
a gagné
c'est pas sûr et peut-être qu'on peut
jouer donc
c'est rare il a joué on va regarder moi
perso je ne connaissais pas il joue pour
un cadre je pense que tu as raison donc
la vraie question c'est qu'est-ce qu'il
y avait sur foues 7 pour moi
probablement pour continuer
C5 justement Mathieu sur leur logique
mais là tu préfères pendant
qu'ils sont pas toujours
simples à jouer
bien sûr structure classique aux échecs
on a parlé beaucoup dans les streams du
pion isolé là on a les pions pendant on
a parlé hier de toute façon mais c'est
assez dangereux à jouer et donc du coup
dans la partie là je vais fougère
vraiment mais bon les blancs vont se
prémunir de ce genre de menace peut-être
un képé 5
d'abordaires kb5 nous propose mature
objectivement je sais même pas ce que je
ferais
bon du coup c'est compliqué ces
positions là ce sont des positions très
très jouées une structure qu'on obtient
régulièrement aux échecs
et les noirs doivent jouer dynamique
parce que sur le long terme on peut dire
Mathieu exceptions peuvent être faibles
plus moins les pièces sont présentes sur
l'échiquier un peu comme un pion isolé
en fait dans un certain sens
ouais complètement bah souvent ça va te
perdre puis pendant et puis désolé
ça peut aller être perdu mon homme
alors
j'ai joué une fois cette idée de pas
sortir le fouceau B7 donc H3 x 5 il a
joué le 4
c'est marrant on dirait qu'il a pas joué
contre contre l'idée blanche il a joué
vraiment très très dynamique avec les
noirs
bien sûr on voit ça dans le pion isolé
d'ailleurs avec la poussée de dessin qui
se fait vraiment sur le coup B6 c'est le
même logique et du coup des cavalier
prend eux il y a vraiment les casse
faibles comme nous le signal Mathieu
avec du coup éventuellement ma cavalier
4 des schémas comme ça cavalier BD7 du
coup là ça marche plus
et fougères 5 et on a un pion isolé
passe standard parce que
là il est obligé de jouer au sept non
tu vas être moins bien je prends F6 je
prends un 8 je prends un F6 bien sûr
vous voyez la petite petite trique
tactique de Mathieu pour profiter du
clouage et dégommer la structure de pion
regardez cavalier donc je vais jouer un
coup neutre voilà 5 pas terrible
cavalier
c'est vrai c'était juste pour montrer
voilà voilà cette structure Hashi
s'aggraver le cas sans doute tu as bien
aimé à 5 j'ai l'impression
c'était le coup pour rien c'était le
coup pour rien
j'avais pas le contrôle zéro de chasbase
voilà donc vous voyez la petite menace
structurelle de dégommer
[Musique]
donc et en plus bon il y a la pression
sur des six donc faut 7 et là
faut réfléchir déjà
là on doit être quasiment dans le dans
le dur on va essayer de réfléchir
moi ça reste pas
pas si visuel
[Musique]
non il y a des
qui doit
je vois des idées à base de cavaliers 5
ou j'ai l'impression que je vais être
vachement mieux du coup
mais de rien dire je suis à plus de ça
ne saute pas aux yeux
à moins qu'il y a un truc direct
est-ce qu'on peut jouer j'enlève mon
cavalier je fais fouter 5 parce que la
casse c'est 6 en fait tu peux plus
rentrer
mais c'est juste vraiment super chiant
c'est assez incroyable d'ailleurs comme
chez moi mais
il est sous pression vous cache
qu'est-ce que tu penses de Vincent Kemer
d'ailleurs
non je pense c'est un bon joueur après
il a un défaut qui est assez étonnant
c'est qu'il a déjà un style de papier à
18 ans
comme NiAl par exemple dans les jeunes
qu'on a on ne voit pas mais
en fait son problème c'est qu'il n'est
pas le feu sur les chiffres et quand à
18 ans tu mets déjà pas le feu sentez
par exemple son entraîneur c'est l'Echo
mais les cours nous dit c'est un super
joueur d'attaque John
il jouait que des variantes hyper
pointus et lui il joue déjà des quatres
avec un site de papier et là dans le
tournoi on voit qu'il a été très très
bon dans les positions techniques où il
a retourné des 27 à partir de position
gay je pense contre bonne forêt contre à
dominé des positions égales contre les
mecs déjà la 27 bien sûr il calcule bien
aussi mais il est moins tactique et
ouais avoir un style de vieux à son âge
c'est un peu bizarre
ouais dans key G3 c'était mon chat on le
dit que j'ai trois ok j'ai trois
cavalier F5 ouais c'est pas bête pour
aller chercher un fou pour avoir les
deux fous
ça a l'air déjà dur en fait la pose
noire
fou G6 et soit fou B5 soit qui avait F5
et j'ai trois fou G6 et il faut baisser
que ça a l'air je sais même pas ce qu'on
joue Mathieu je suis hyper inquiète j'ai
envie de le voir parce que je vois pas
du tout ce qu'on joue
ah tu me laisses cavalier
[Musique]
bon je sais pas j'ai pas trop calculé
mais
c'est un peu la loose l'histoire ça
intuitivement
F6 enfin on est on est au bord du groupe
donc ça
sur 8 et dans ma carte direct c'est
hyper fort à Mathieu tiens
content de mon tour 8
[Musique]
on peut le faire dans les deux sens mais
ça avait l'air ça a l'air quand même pas
mal ok ça y est ça gagne direct
ivement que c'était pas jouable du tout
pour moi non ça c'est un super joueur et
tu sens qu'il aime les échecs il est à
fond juste moi ce qui me manque une
partie de référence tactique
dernière ronde et c'est pas passé grand
chose Mathieu on va remettre Kerwan a
dit c'est bien j'avais pas la caméra
donc c'est bien il savait peut-être il
savait
on est payé à l'heure ah d'accord
donc du coup
l'annuler rapidement
des fois est-ce que tu es content que la
matière du repas
la question
ouais ouais je peux comprendre
mais juste par exemple les gens oublient
que carpov était un super joueur
d'attaque aussi du coup Mathieu un bon
commerçant ce que tu devrais proposer
c'est un forfait à l'heure avec une
assurance avec une assurance Mathieu
voilà je te donne l'idée je te donne
l'idée pour la prochaine négo
ok bon
c'est parce que ce qu'on me propose
c'est déjà bon vu ton CV Mathieu voilà
c'est pour ça tu as pas besoin de
négocier
au contraire
c'est bien Mathieu tu fais monter les
enchères
je vais t'appelais le Giroud bordelais
Mathieu avec avec cette petite technique
là du coup on a pu partir encore non à
rognonx allez on y va
on a dit avantage caméra
il doit travailler
faut pas oublier que c'est le tournoi le
plus long de l'année à part les
championnats du monde c'est très bon
c'est n'importe quoi et en plus
si tu as joué à 13h le championnat du
monde junior qu'on a fait tous les deux
c'était 13 secondes
je suis quasiment certain j'ai perdu les
deux dernières
j'en avais trop marre je te laisse
vérifier
dans ma tête c'était 13 secondes mais tu
vois c'était 11 mais j'ai l'impression
que c'était c'est peut-être un 11
secondes du coup faudrait que je vérifie
six fois donc si quelqu'un dans le chat
veut vérifier si en 2005 qu'on a joué le
cheval du monde avec Mathieu en Turquie
à Istanbul voilà donc du coup vous
pouvez aller voir
alors à rognon on va aller voir à rognon
et la cam d'aronia je l'ai pas non plus
mais c'est pas grave et si
hier
dans sa partie contre Prague c'est fait
un peu dominé dans l'ouverture mais
après quand ça devient le bordel il est
très bon c'était avant-hier pendant
je pensais qu'il allait se faire
vraiment bouger dans ce tournoi et en
fait pas tant que ça il fait parmi les
outsiders c'est lui qui réalise un des
meilleurs tournois si on exclut à Boussa
encore enfin deuxième partie de tournoi
fêter outsider qu'on se comprenne bien
c'est juste que il fait partie des plus
jeunes quoi il fait pas encore partie de
des cadres mais ils veulent devenir vu
ce genre de tournoi mais mazout lou très
bonne surprise à ce niveau là du coup on
montre rapidement il a une en fait juste
si quelqu'un
il est très dynamique et c'est un
facteur de ouf ouais il attend il aime
bien la façon
quand c'est un jeu de manœuvre
normalement il est quand même dans le
dur donc c'est pas son point fort
à l'ancienne mais que ça revient à la
mode parce que
[Musique]
souvent visser sur ce genre de ligne
bien sûr mais par contre un moment ils
vont placer une tactique et te retourner
oui c'est très chaud ce genre de
position on aimerait jouer des cinq un
jour
bien sûr votre adversaire vous visse et
vous travaillez l'option D6 il a déjà
travaillé l'aile voilà on se fait
des fois
ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est un très
bon choix qu'on parle parce que dans le
jeu de manœuvre il est vraiment pas très
long d'ailleurs Mathieu est-ce que tu
peux m'expliquer cavalier 8 je suis pas
spécialiste d'un genre je fais quand
j'étais petit mais cavaliers 8 ça me
rappelle rien donc dis-moi Mathieu
sa seule idée c'est que c'est pas cool
de parram j'aimerais bien moi prendre
des choses c'est pas apparemment ça ça a
pas tes faveur ce coup Mathieu
de quoi après
revenu je me suis dit tiens Mathieu va
me donner un petit tuyau sur ce truc là
qui me paraît vraiment bizarre
ah ouais vous voyez comme les mecs sont
plus 2007
a tellement de boulot à faire dans la
compréhension des positions les plans
par contre après abattre il doit être
horrible il te met une pression de ouf
il calcule hyper bien
il t'a fait mentir quand même il a un
sacré jeu de manœuvre regarde ce qu'il a
fait cavalier 8 et cavalier ef6 c'est
assez créatif en terme de manœuvre tu
vois
c'est vrai que c'est la première fois
parce que ça a l'air vraiment tout à
fait normal ce que je voulais blanc hein
dame 1 pourra laisser passer les pièces
en D2 et du coup avec arrivé noir c'est
un peu plus bizarre pour l'instant le
jeu de pièces c'est vrai qu'il a il a
pas si bien commencé
et du coup cavalier des deux est-ce
qu'on va aller chercher une case F5
peut-être
les gens en train de me dire le mec a
tellement mal joué est-ce que tu peux
pas jouer cahier des 5
fois
c'est logique et des 5 donc tu vas
laisser ces deux qu'est-ce que tu as vu
du coup
en du pion et je sais que et du coup si
je bouffe ces deux un ange j'ai mal vu
d'accord ça m'arrive aussi avec le
stream vous savez que des fois bon on a
des petites alu et je me suis Mathieu il
a dû prévoir quelque chose j'ai vu de la
jauge merdé aussi donc je me suis dit il
a peut-être quand même oublié l'histoire
des un torrent d'accord ok ok donc
oui on précise qu'on n'a pas leur dire
oui oui bah ça on l'a suffisamment
précis déjà la jauge franchement bah
c'est une commande shetcom l'histoire
qui vient pas de nous j'aimerais bien
vous l'enlever mais apparemment il y en
a certains qui aiment la jauge il y a un
certain qui aiment l'ordi mais pour
apprendre normalement enfin aux échecs
on n'a pas la jauge c'est à Nantes qui
disait qu'il gagnerait quasiment toutes
ces parties si on lui donnait la jauge
justement une vraie jauge
et que ses adversaires ne l'avez pas
pour expliquer que c'est très important
de connaître les valeurs j'avais oublié
de français
oui j'aime bien cette histoire c'est
encore mieux je pense on a le temps en
fait voilà on a fixé
tellement bien joué de ça ok mais alors
Mathieu est-ce que toi qui est vraiment
un spécialiste quand même de théorie tu
peux nous dire avec les Noirs comment on
aurait dû jouer
honnêtement je comprends rien trop
compliqué pour vous moi c'est les seules
positions que j'ai pas trop étudié là
j'ai regardé récemment tous les lignes
de nageddorf autre il y a déjà du boulot
et là on est dans la ligne tradies je
les ai pas trop regardé je dois les
regarder d'ailleurs
pas t'es censé mettre un truc rapidement
en C4 peut-être je sais pas moi donc
peut-être cavalier B6 dans le champion
en tout cas ça donne pour la vie
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est sûr qu'il faut pas
mettre de caillou en cessisme moi je
suis même pas sûr oui bien sûr
normalement je vois dans les nages
d'offres que mais là il a été malin dès
qu'il y a A4 les joueurs spécialistes de
nageurs ils jouent quasiment kssys
système pour la case cependant il a
attendu cavalier BD7 moi je pense que
c'est peut-être une connerie bah oui
parce que normalement ce que j'explique
aux amateurs c'est qu'on laisse la
souplesse du cavalier parce que rock on
est sur de le faire donc c'est un peu
étonnant
si je veux un coup d'attente tu as
peut-être des cinq en plus et on
recroise un dessin et je pense c'était
il y a une partie des ventouses partie
avec les blancs mais objectivement ça
doit pas être grand-chose
mais au moins laisser l'aspect du
cavalier c'est normal aussi pour moi
Mathieu enfin ça a l'air ça a l'air plus
logique quoi
bon bref on voit pas trop l'intérêt de
ce hyper rapide en tout cas et puis il a
pas vraiment pro prouvé mais en fait
pour C8 je pensais qu'il avait des idées
même de claquer Mathieu bon voilà c'est
quel R3 ici probablement
tu as pas le temps non je pense et j'ai
pas de dessin là comme un
pourquoi parfois
j'étais pas sûr de la ligne pour tout
dire
c'est
une bonne gueule
ok mais je ramène je ramène mon cheval
je ramène mon cheval
si ça marche c'est plus fort tu as
raison
tu as raison c'est le coup que j'ai dit
aussi
à moi qui est fou F5 tu as raison bah
c'est compliqué mais oui moi je
m'attendais
tour C8 je sais ça devait être pour
prendre dans ces trois mais comme il a
fait à 5 petits rock et quand voilà le
truc de daube ça a donné parce que ça
vous voyez c'est une position où bah
j'ai les pions fixés et j'ai pas trop
d'idées Mathieu nous demandait des fois
où tu joues pourquoi tu joues pour
qu'elle échange pour qu'elle structure
ben pour que dalle on joue pour subir et
regardez c'est en train de le cas c'est
catastrophique OK et il y a une ration
de partie à voir Prague sont
ok je retire il ajoute
la nouvelle ligne avec cette prendrait
c'est que des ordinateurs ils acceptent
de jouer avec un pion de moi et ça c'est
assez dynamique c'est incroyable
d'ailleurs
je m'en suis pris une il y en a
plusieurs il y a plusieurs façons
d'arriver dans ce style de position même
une avec l'échange de dames Matthieu
mais je sais plus comment on est arrivé
ouais mais ça là non celle-là c'est une
la plus à la main
il connaissait en fait regarde c'est pas
une connaissez de rendre le pion c'est
chiant contre carrossen ça ou ouais je
suis champion
en fait il y a eu un
là une vidéo série qui parle de ça
il me semble mais c'est intéressant et
en fait il a joué assez vite il a rendu
le pion en disant je vais rentrer dans
une finale je vais être un peu mieux ok
ça me prend
c'est si tu le fais pas je faisais à
trois
et donc là l'idée c'est qu'il
y a la case des 6 qui peut menacer des
e33
on a peut-être un meilleur jeu de pièces
la dame est bizarre ok
parce que si je prends en D7
j'ai failli avoir une belle alu j'ai
failli faire fout aussi Dame des cinq et
sauter par dessus ton cavalier mais
c'est on rappelle que c'est interdit
alors
j'étais en train de me dire qui me l'as
assez fou des 7 3 mais si tu bouges ta
dame loin je peux maintenant j'ai pas
trop envie d'aller au loin
je vais aller voir le temps quand a été
utilisé par les joueurs c'est souvent
c'est comme une indication pour
l'ouverture à quel point ils connaissent
tu peux l'avoir mais là tu l'as pas ok
KIC il avait réfléchi 0 faut si ça a été
jeté un pot ça sert à rien qu'on regarde
d'accord
minutes jusque là et l'autre toujours
tempo E4 premier coup il a réfléchi et
c'est pour tourner endertale que j'ai
mis que j'ai mis la doudoune j'ai
expliqué ça Mathieu il m'a demandé il
m'a dit mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ta
veste c'est une veste zippée je rappelle
que c'est plutôt un pull même s'il y a
une petite moumoute derrière je rappelle
ça tout le monde c'est important à
Mathieu de faire une petite transition
là-dessus donc en vente non c'est pas en
vente mais elle est très bien cette
doudoune je vous invite à choisir la
maison des vestes zippées c'est top mais
vas-y P voilà ou alors sinon vous avez
un petit pull avec un col comment
s'appelle ton pull Mathieu
ce que tu connais le nom de ton call
c'est un nom mais je sais pas quoi il y
a col mao Colm machin comme je sais pas
quoi on apprécie on a apprécié ton pull
aussi Mathieu ne soit pas jaloux de ma
veste zippée voilà je pense que
Néandertal fera une petite remarque qui
trouvera bien quelque chose à dire
là-dessus
non c'est faux ok tu as été joué
c'est la douceur
c'est tout à fait ça
j'avais pas compris ok mais du coup il y
a eu des échanges et bonne prépa de
merde
des blancs c'est pourquoi tu es mieux
regarde la position finale
petit tour à trois j'avais les deux
connaissent en fait je sors la dame ok
chacun croit que son pion mais là ouais
c'est une prepa pour l'instant donc du
coup et une prépa qui n'a pas abouti à
grand chose puisque là on voit que
l'égalité est en train de se mettre en
place avec peu de défauts structurels le
roi du coup il fait j'ai 6-3 G7 ok ça va
faire nul voilà on va se laisser sauts
dans dans sa stratégie de départ mais en
même temps là il a pas pu faire
honnêtement c'est pas de sa faute il a
joué une ligne assez charpe d'ailleurs
pour finir le tournoi tranquillement et
revenir l'année prochaine peut-être
du coup qui tu veux aller voir Mathieu
maintenant qu'on a fait le tour des
stades on a oublié personne
on n'a pas vu depuis le 5ème cool donc
on va aller voir
Abdouh B5
je vais regarder le temps
B5 je veux un pot grand rock après 10
minutes
et dame
prise
on n'a pas le temps de faire G4 à mon
avis ce qui veut jouer la finale sans se
prendre f3g4 que j'avais on avait
annoncé mais on va voir c'est pas si
simple parce qu'après faut c'est ça qui
s'est pris le 4 en fait j'avais pas vu
la suite de quoi je me demandais
qu'est-ce qui va se passer sur des trucs
comme ça et après si tu me fais ça j'ai
5 donc c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est
bien parce que c'est la question
sélectionnez les joueurs pour moi c'est
par invitation en fait sont sélectionnés
il y a pas de sélection il y a juste un
joueur qui monte du tournoi B
et tous les autres c'est sur Invite du
coup je laisse le pion ah oui j'ai en
fait ce qui est marrant c'est qu'il
tient tout seul
c'est marrant parce que tu fais cavalier
FC
faire cavalier fis après mais bon c'est
la même idée en fait si vous voulez
c'est rigolo on fait G4 pour gagner le
pion on peut le gagner mais on va le
repaire avec cavalier F6 alors comme il
y a des hachis on prendra peut-être
un peu le sport regardez poussez 5 il
ajoute un pot G4 il a un fichier 6
minutes
on s'en fout et on dit que le pion il
est ok
[Musique]
G5
on va regarder
je vais te montrer
on va voir
toi tu voulais faire cavalier
juste f32 sur cavalier E5 et je viens de
gratter le pion je veux G5 et manger le
pion aussi ah oui oui
ouais j'ai pas envie de voir ton
cavalier arrive en G4 je me suis dit que
tu allais m'embrouiller
ok elle a plein de Mathieu
je fais fou B7
ça change quoi je vais croquer tout
reprendre
H4
dans la partie pourquoi il fait pas ton
prochain
à la place de F3 d'accord je prends
prends
je prends prends
c'est comme ça que je voyais les choses
il faut au dos que j'avais oublié ah oui
donc il y a ça aussi alors c'est bizarre
tu reprends à 5 normalement était E5
finale mais je suis obligé de prendre
ou B4 cavalier quelque chose comme ça
j'intercale un petit bac à Mathieu
peut-être
et là je prends tout ah non bah j'ai mon
pion B4 en l'air donc c'est pas bon tant
pour moi bah du coup je pensais que
c'était cavalier 6 il doit y avoir une
idée on voit que la jauge de s'affole
pas mais on n'a pas encore compris
comment on allait récupérer le pion
je pensais que c'était cavalier fait fou
aux deux bravo Mathilde protège le pion
d'un coup que j'avais oublié
dans tous les cas je pense que c'est kf6
et après il faut sinon c'est un peu
décevant alors il y aurait peut-être
droit à des touches fuites mais bon
maintenant il y a G4 en plus
[Musique]
des cartes c'est un peu ce qu'on a
proposé tout à l'heure et le 5 et la E5
ça fait
je vais jouer à 4 mais Mathieu il essaie
de m'embêter bon bah je suis quand même
mieux avec les Blancs à 4
ah pas sûr à 4 à 5 mais
c'est pas sûr
j'ai un peu
ok mais c'est quand même forcément
ouais mais du coup après
du coup là je crois il a pas pris le
pion mais c'est bizarre j'ai tendance à
me dire que c'était le plus critique et
dans cette position qu'est-ce que je
peux jouer parce que ah
je tente 3 peut-être ou là tour B3 un
peu bizarre mon histoire mais mon tour
B3 allez tomber 4 fois c'est 6 tours
je regardais parce que je me doutais
qu'il y avait quelque chose donc tu
disais E5 tour des trois même idée
je veux jouer de ton jeu 3
la différence c'est qu'ici je te laisse
peut-être la voiture B4
et des 5
ok non il
a joué F3
ouais
tour des 6 au lieu de tour des trois
j'ai 6 à peu près 13 minutes
c'était possible avec ton BC mais tendez
trois j'aime bien l'idée d'aller dans le
3 où en jatron donc j'ai 6 joué cavalier
F5 c'est
assez obscur pour moi c'est parti
[Rires]
c'est dur après
Peugeot
ok mais ça paraît pas non plus être un
avantage colossal pour les blancs petits
plus mais
je sais pas j'ai 5
est-ce que je peux
le dash 4
si on prend un 5 cavalier 6
non j'ai quatre
là ce serait plus très agréable
ça commence à être un peu moins bien
d'autant plus que je menace à schisme
maintenant peut-être je sais pas s'il y
a peut-être G5
j'ai envie de te faire B4 mais je suis
pas sûr
les H5
ça a l'air un peu plus dur quand même le
jeu de pièces noir tu comptes passer par
où la voiture avec ton cavalier F6
c'est bizarre
moi je sais pas trop justement je
commence à dubitatif sur
la position noire qui s'est un petit peu
un peu délitée j'ai l'impression avec
ce que oui là c'est dû au roi E7 j'ai
pris un 5
alors est-ce que c'est mieux
non mais du coup je vois pourquoi il est
rentré dans ça avec les Blancs c'est que
ça a pas l'air si simple de ça
et pourquoi tu voulais pas jouer
cavalier F6 tout de suite Mathieu il y a
G5 c'est ça
pour éviter de d'avoir donc G5 peut-être
c'est le coup critique pour essayer de
faire quelque chose
c'est un peu bizarre mais bon
ça faisait peur donc j'ai 5
c'est chiant quand même histoire
dans cette position
mais je suis un peu trop court tu vas
faire kg
maintenant mais non et du coup c'est
peut-être con parce que je m'enlève
cette case pour le carré
il faut être précis mais là tu as réussi
à
en même temps ça fait sens de jouer
grand rock et on garde les deux options
kf6 KE7 plus de souplesse pour la pièce
aujourd'hui
un peu plus galère quand même à mettre
en place
ça s'énerve salut à tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent petit à petit
bonjour bonjour
sans aucun problème parce qu'on a passé
pas mal de temps sur cette position et
il y a réflexion pour pour vendre forest
exactement de quoi vous voulez aller
voir Carlson
bon voilà bah ça a suivi un petit peu ce
dont on avait parlé
en fait ce qu'il faut c'est que tu
appuies sur rafraîchir en fait j'ai pas
fait gaffe
B3 exactement le plan que j'ai annoncé
et aussi peut-être un arbitre qui nous
cache la vue
il est blanc
fou c'est 8 donc il veut passer par F5
Mathieu nous en parler de ce plan-là on
se retrouve dans une nest indienne ouais
tout à fait j'ai trois et on a fait
donc là il va entamer mais il est hyper
de loin F5 F3
position plus facile à jouer Mathieu
avec
surtout quand tu dois gagner avec les
Noirs là tu es au paradis après tu peux
ne pas gagner mais
aucun problème
non mais il y a aucun problème surtout
littéralement toutes les pièces et tous
les pions
et attaque sur le roi
c'est le paradis toi
5h à la casse par off ou H5 connecté
non mais tu as tout à fait raison
connecté à 5 bah attention on casse pas
c'est indienne connaissait un petit peu
les idées on va dire ça comme ça
ok je pense Magnus va gagner on peut
retourner à guéri que du coup là c'est
la partie numéro 3 à la partie numéro 2
donc on était on s'était quitté là donc
c'était début de la terre donc Fodé
cette fusée 4 et ça c'était Matic ce
petit jeu de jambes
donc on a bien Mathieu nous a expliqué
il y a le fou des sept peut être mal
placé des fois c'est un peu minimaliste
[Musique]
on va travailler arrêter
sans doute à F5 enfin l'empêcher c'est
un grand mot mais
essayer de l'éviter et la jouer Dame des
trois
oui on peut pas être mais bon il va être
un peu mieux mais ça peut être ça peut
finir en fou de couleur opposé
côté
Aniche guéri forcément il est blanc
c'est plus facile même sur une idée de
l'adversaire
F5 est-ce qu'on peut faire cavalier E3
pour passer le fond en dessin
et peut-être qu'il y a eu trois fois
schisme
[Musique]
c'est vraiment plus facile à jouer pour
les blancs alors est-ce que ce sera
suffisant
en tout cas c'est plus on est vraiment
bien plus content de jouer à
cette pause et maintenant comment je
fais ce que je fais à 4 à 5 pour prendre
de l'espace est-ce que tu menaces
vraiment quelque chose Mathieu ici avec
la noire F5
c'est pas cool ça du coup A4 A4 j'ai des
pubs sur chaise comme quand je suis pas
abonné
[Rires]
du coup A4
c'est ça mon idée je sais pas c'est bien
mais en tout cas
même là F5
dames des cinq et tu me tu me fais
tourcer 5 tu peux te demander
en tout cas bon c'est quand même un
petit pressing l'histoire au cavaliers 3
fautes cavaliers
on tape des 6 en plus on passe le fond
des 5 c'est quand même normal
du coup
on a fait un peu mieux mais rien de
spécial
on refait un tour en fait on refait un
tour et après on fera une petite pause
voilà donc
vous avez vu à la technique aujourd'hui
quand même vous avez vu sous vous parlez
de problème de caméra en fait maintenant
aucun problème en fait il est quand même
passé dans le chat de me dire comment
faire comment il avait fait parce qu'au
début il a eu des soucis de caméra et en
fait il y a une réactualisation à faire
voilà j'ai même pas besoin d'en faire
tout tout se passe bien tout se passe
bien juste pour la caméra dab d'où ça
t'auras
la structure dans la gueule mais on
n'avait pas trouvé de coup véritablement
mature on était embêté avec tout ce
qu'on avait expliqué là normalement
c'est faux
dur dur donc il a accepté
de donner toutes sa structure le roi pas
terrible il y a les dames sur
l'échiquier on a le foot casse blanche
qui tape un fou qui peut devenir un F4
ou F8 il faut bétonner faut que la tour
B8 il a bricolé avec fuj6
donc l'idée c'est de jouer sur la case
blanche et non pas de ça peut être de
prendre en G6 mais genre de sacrifier
pour mater soit c'est juste de mettre un
truc en F5
donc H4 a été joué c'est logique de
toute façon je regardais aussi des cinq
mais il y avait F5 c'était super ça
aurait été le super coup malin parce que
pour
rester pour enlever le C5 après gagner
la partie tranquille mais qu'à H4 c'est
beaucoup plus logique pour la case
[Musique]
je pense que ça va faire quand même
le retour Mathieu ça va te plaire de A5
ici dans cette position tu les aimes
bien ces petits coups et on va regarder
on vous laisse tu dis pardon tu es sûr
que tu es plus que la nul je veux déjà
prendre les trois pions vous voyez math
il dit ouais mais passe une tour et
après on verra essayer il va peut-être
raison on voit que la chose je sais pas
faut aller bon on va faire quoi j'ai 8
il y a peut-être aussi mais bon et il
faudrait que je passe une tour voilà G4
mais par contre on peut travailler quand
même cette position avec cavalier F5
ouais mais c'est pas encore
c'est vraiment ce qu'on avait envie de
faire de F3 pour moi
c'est très joli ce que nous propose
Matthieu il y a il y a la case F5 mais
il y a aussi la colonne les pièces
noires sont pas bien mises quand vous
devez jouer sur case blanche vous avez
deux façons soit un bon cavalier comme
mauvais fou sauf de couleur à poser
F5 et sinon il y a l'option de tout
sacrifier donc en G6 pour l'instant ne
marche pas non mais ça doit être mieux
pour les blancs mais la joie j'appelle
l'air de s'affoler non mais c'est dur
belle décision quand même de
goût cache avec ce dame C8
faut le jouer quand même avec accepter
cette position elle fait peur
visuellement pas de souci et dégueulasse
trois fois en partie longue je le
connais bien
ben là j'ai envie d'être pour Kemer je
trouve qu'il mérite de ouais il mérite
beaucoup mieux
que ce qu'il a eu on avait choisi des
chouchous avec stouffe pour se tournoi
stouf il a choisi à d'où ça torov j'ai
choisi après la première ronde
évidemment
et du coup j'ai choisi quelle mer en me
disant après c'est super Blitz c'est
rapide du monde et ben non pas du tout
en fait mais il a fait des bonnes
parties comme tu le disais en plus c'est
décevant par rapport à ce qu'il a montré
ils ont marqué des points négatifs après
ils vont être invités c'est ton premier
tournoi tu vas pas forcément défoncer
tout tu vas arjones j'ai envie de lui
laisser sa chance
malheureusement qui qui est très fort
mais il a joué avec un train on va dire
de sénateur quoi il a pas essayé de tout
balancer à rognon est-ce qu'il va
aujourd'hui essayer de jouer pour le
lien
je pense vu la position il peut pousser
son risque dans Matthieu qu'est-ce que
tu en penses ouais mais quand il y a
toutes les pièces sur le ticket
5 qui te dit c'est de l'eau
cache 4 bien
x 2 bon il y a toujours pas des 50 quand
même hein
non je regardais il faut prendre juste
H3 mais ça marche pas bien
des motifs vous voyez maths il a l’œil
qui traîne quand même là dessus mais il
y a dans mes fins heureusement parce que
ça empêche aussi motif ksg-4 qui pour
arriver aussi à terme donc tout est
contrôlé non il y a aussi des quais
bon ça doit être juste roi prend G2 faut
prendre H3 et on tient pour l'instant il
y a pas assez de pièces qui arrivent ok
est-ce que je peux jouer ton prince
cette fois on y revient
dessin
ça c'est vraiment dans l'esprit
c'est joli elles sont que les noirs sont
mieux en tout cas ça fait peur
maintenant parlant je peux peut-être
manger tu manges du Fou Mathieu ah ouais
pour bouffer
deux pièces qui s'activent parce que fou
des 5 fois ça tenait pas trop mal je
pense de récupérer le foot casse noir
comme tu as dit en E3 et DAC une autre
fou en C5 un jour l'idée de Mathieu
cavalier prend des 5 il veut bouffer le
four 3 comme ça il aura un fou vivant et
pourra venir faire suer
1h27 à la pendule ah mais qui se fasse
défoncer toi ça il m'énerve il m'énerve
là
tout le temps
qu'est-ce qu'on a loupé en fait puis on
prend
un dessin qu'il est pas obligé de
prendre il doit pas prendre je pense
même
c'est la cata
ça fait très très peur et c'est bien
aussi de McDo et descend F5 non mais moi
je suis pour qu'il gagne avec les Noirs
déjà quand on la cité tout à l'heure il
pouvait le faire
si tu reprends ces trois quêtes
intéressants mais là c'est plus
intéressant encore ce qui est bizarre
c'est que quand on regarde les coups
jouer tout à l'heure mais il a fait
petit aussi à rognon il a pas prouvé
grand chose enfin un plan catin
il s'est fait contrôler
attendez deux il veut contrôle la
cassette
donc pas ça bien sûr info 2 et
maintenant 300 C3 c'était Matic en plus
mature
je suis désolé jouer d'ailleurs
pour moi c'est une insulte aux échecs de
jeux comme ça avec les Blancs tu joues
vite sans réfléchir tu mérites d'être
puni et c'est casserve qui disait ton
français 3 c'est la chose la plus
naturelle dans une piscine tout à fait
en plus là tu tapes les deux
il a pris que 13 minutes pour cette
position qui fait pas rêver en pratique
mais moi qui te fasse défoncer moi quand
t'insulte le jeu sans
réfléchirons d'avoir cette merde c'est
des jours que j'adore en fait non alors
j'adore mais là franchement pas et en
plus moi ce qui m'énervait c'est qu'on
intervie dit ouais je suis ma stratégie
de faire nulle facile
donc si je comprends bien ok
il y a très peu de prix oui c'est vrai
par rapport à d'autres tournois du même
acabit ils ont des gros filles qui
négocient chacun en privé vous voyez des
enveloppes vous voyez l'idée quoi
et en gros ils ont dit cette année que
s'il y avait des ultra rapides il
pourrait être amener de plus réinviter
les gens ils l'ont dit il veut spectacle
dans le trou noir ça on peut on peut le
voir mais on peut bloquer sans faire de
nulle rapide quoi mais si tu là
franchement tu vois clairement qui tu ne
dois pas réinviter
à mon avis ils seront réinvité mais
d'ailleurs ce qui digne et Fabiano ils
ont joué tout le temps en fait
non non pour moi il joue oui c'est ça
c'est que c'est pas de bol aujourd'hui
c'est eux qui ont fait nul rapide mais
là sur une 13e ronde il y a presque le
droit si vous jouez 12 secondes à fond
ça va un matin c'est un état d'esprit
exactement
et c'est un tournoi pour au championnat
du monde tu veux de faire tenir rapide
je comprends on peut rien dire
là je suis désolé c'était payé pour
jouer pour faire un show pas de toute
façon ça l'organisateur d'en prendre
conscience et je pense que quand on voit
le plateau avec les jeunes pépites il en
a déjà conscience je pense qu'il
s'entoure d'ailleurs d'un board qui
choisit de qui invitait et ils ont
réussi à d'ailleurs trouver Max zülo qui
au dernier moment qui a remplacé Yann
Christophe Douda est super pioche aussi
donc c'est c'est plutôt pas mal le
plateau qui est proposé c'est même très
intéressant
au premier plan effectivement Magicus
on pense qu'il peut la gagner avec les
Noirs ça serait beau 3 victoires de
suite pour finir ça sera incroyable
[Musique]
je lui en veux pas du tout il a joué
comme tout le temps moi bien sûr bien
sûr donc on avance juste pour vous dire
là ça c'est Galice très très fortement
t'aurais fait
même les finales
on reviendra sans doute pas dessus ok
j'ai vu des coudes à partir de Magnus
donc il a fait le plan que tu avais
annoncé d'ailleurs c'est complètement ce
qu'on avait annoncé F4 on l'a dit à 3
c'était le plan pour jouer B4
normalement mais jamais le cavalier en
fiancé quand il le fait bah il trouve un
argument cette contrôler la seule
poussée classique des blancs pour
enflammer la dame parce que c'est leur
côté un les blancs on rappelle on
attaque à côté du sommet de sa chaîne de
pions voilà le pion en dessin qu'on va
attaquer là sommet de la chaîne de pion
noir ici en F4 on va attaquer là on
profite de l'avantage d'espace en
réalité pour mettre les pièces derrière
[Musique]
chacun son truc
bouge ton G7 soit ton rêve 6 tour G6 le
câble 8 pour revenir en F6 le fou D7 il
tient la dame et des fois il attaque à
droite donc c'est quand même agréable à
jouer pour la norme mais par contre ce
qui est ça doit pas être foutu du tout
pour les blancs c'est un vrai combat là
razf moi j'entends très bien Mathieu
mais dites-nous dans notre chat c'est
moi ou des fois le micro de maths coupe
j'ai pas l'impression moi mais après des
fois vous savez entre sur le stream et
ce que vous vous entendez et ce que
j'entends il y a une différence
j'utilise ce micro pour toutes mes
vidéos j'ai pas de problème normalement
non mais des fois c'est bizarre des fois
et en plus des fois c'est pas nous c'est
les viewers voilà moi c'est good ok ici
de H gadget là j'ai fait le proposer
mais tu en aller un peu vite quand tu as
joué le coup sur A3 il disait A4 était
intéressant pour les Noirs je voulais le
mentionner oui pour laquelle comme on
voit des fois mais vas-y à 4 d'accord
ce qui est plus chaud c'est qu'un
cavalier en B5 pour bouffer le cavalier
ah oui mais je pique le fousser fout B2
ouais en fait je voulais montrer une
ligne qui marche pas bien mais je la
montre ou pas
tu voulais enfermer le cheval métadonné
ton foot 150
mais même des fois tu peux donner la
qualité mais des fois il y a des trucs
avec prise en fait il y a une partie de
frais signé comme ça qui est connu avec
le noir où il avait joué ça il avait
joué un cavalier à deux prises tu
reprends à 3 et après tu reprends F3
mais là ça marche pas bien mais du coup
après il a peut-être préféré juste ce
qu'il a joué deux
avec la mamie
le spectacle
j'espérais faire qu'à prendre des quatre
et gagner ton pion des 4 donc c'est
n'importe quoi
regarde
quoi c'est logique de l'analyser alors
c'est pourquoi la jauge dit qu'on a
qu'on a complètement déconné
malheureusement sinon je comptais
ouais mais bon ça paraissait tu vois je
comprends pas le plus un de leur dit
pour les Noirs ça a l'air dégueu G3
c'est vraiment embêtant en fait je pense
que c'est
ah oui dame en plus j'ai pas vu
il y a une tactique en pratique on n'a
pas le temps de mettre en place donc A4
c'était bien à Magnus a raté pour une
fois une petite parce qu'il a confiance
peut-être aussi dans cette position
pour une fois hier il a raté
en direct
on a discuté en direct et on a trouvé un
semi truc mais ça paraissait ça
paraissait mais il y a eu deux choses
deux choix vraiment un petit peu bizarre
pareil
quand il a fait son choix pour prendre
le pion en B6 il avait deux façons de le
faire
je préfère les Noirs largement à chaque
jouet
d'accord
tu vas lui faire
[Musique]
moi j'aurais peur pas il a cliqué au
hasard c'est génial c'est marrant c'est
vraiment marrant et Mathieu m'a dit que
en fait c'est ton micro il coupe quand
je te quand je te coupe la parole
globalement si je parle sur toi je prime
apparemment c'est ça le truc je vais
essayer de pas le faire
c'est normal
ok du coup un H14
et sacrifiant
ramener du monde à la fête et on dégomme
on essaie de dégommer l'ossature
l'ossature blanche voilà et on va faire
une petite pause maintenant si ça te va
on se prend 10 minutes petite pause
je vais aller manger pour te dire à
Mathieu et du coup
après on est là dans donc dans 10
minutes je vous mets un petit
un petit film un petit film vous allez
être bien avec le film vous êtes hyper
bien allez tout de suite à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour pas du tout je
suis de retour tout seul Mathieu j'étais
snobé je savais pas fait trop de bêtises
techniques et là je vous montre que
c'est tout à fait possible et voilà on
est vraiment de retour avec Mathieu
aussi voilà je suis laissé déconcentrer
à la pause j'ai mangé un petit un petit
quelque chose et voilà
j'étais plus gros voilà
les salut à tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent on est reparti avec Mathieu
alors Mathieu Tunisie tu me disais qu'on
a dit une grosse bêtise sur une partie
ou une petite bêtise peut-être je sais
pas trop
il y a un problème de son
je crois pas je crois pas je peux
peut-être quand j'ai mis la cam ça fait
un quelque chose bizarre mais je vais
vérifier vous inquiétez pas je me suis
dit on a dit une bêtise sur la partie
Kemer
ok alors parce qu'en fait on est arrêté
à quel H4
qu'on a loupé qui est hyper fort c'est
limite avantage noir
enfilade
ça avait l'air d'être avantage on a pris
la case on vous c'est le coup qu'on
voulait faire qui a joué Vincent Kemer
et en fait il s'est retrouvé confronté à
Dame 6
mais c'est pas du tout ce qu'on veut et
tu remets la structure
des quatre faibles bon par contre ça
doit être égal à poser ok mais juste on
change complètement ce qu'on a dit on
pensait que les Blancs étaient en train
de dominer en fait pas du tout il y a
dame aussi en fait
égaliser avant même je préfère les Noirs
je pense qu'on va réussir on peut
peut-être faire ça et ça bon voilà on
n'aura pas trop de problèmes quand même
encore un poil de pression mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que c'est pas du tout le
bon avantage blanc comme on pensait oui
ça va sans doute faire nul cette partie
en fait
j'ai pas regardé mais juste j'ai pensé
un truc on a été assez bête je pense ça
j'ai pas vérifié on va voir alors
on retourne voir du coup Abdou
en fait ici on a dit un truc bête je
pense que c'est plus simple
et puis on prend H5 en fait pourquoi pas
tout reprendre on est complètement bête
oui ça faisait plus sens que de le
laisser on isole mais on peut plus taper
dessus rapidement
donc les noirs
d'accord
me paraissait plus logique du coup bien
sûr parce qu'il y a toujours le problème
du cavalier qu'on pouvait sortir sur les
deux cases et là il y a que cavalier F6
du coup on peut se faire Snooper la case
c'est ce qui s'est passé dans la partie
je comprends bien c'est très clair si F4
ok du coup ça va être un fight de
stratégiquement c'est double tranchant
oui c'est rigolo quand même l'idf6 elle
est pas mal aussi pour sortir le
cavalier F4 on sait pas trop on éclate
notre structure et on bloque au mieux
mais peut-être qu'il manque un temps en
fait champion
F5
mais bon ça a l'air chaud pas non plus
et qui est le prince et qu'ici tu as du
mal à sortir étape tu peux pas trop
bouger le roi à cause du pion des 6
envie de jouer cavalier 5 logique
et est-ce qu'il y a du G4
[Musique]
en fait il faut savoir c'est que même si
on double genre H2 pour prendre le pied
B4 et full prend un 4 des fois et des
fois même on peut rendre le pion parce
que le pion G5 il est pas non plus ouf
bah oui du coup mais il y a cavalier 5
qui a l'air de faire très très mal non
mais en fait G4 c'est juste pour montrer
en fait j'ai quatre c'est sans doute pas
bon mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il faut
le regarder à tous les coups la cavalier
5 c'est chaud parce que on a vraiment
KFC en plus
moi je préfère le noir
mais bon si abdos est rentré dans ça il
va avoir une idée
ou alors il veut vraiment faire la 5
bah c'est pas impossible je sais pas où
alors il y a une autre idée F4 f3g ce
qu'on a autre chose
c'est pas joué
on est toujours là et que quand tu fais
ça tu peux voir les temps tu as vu
je voulais voir que la pendule affiche
etc quand je fais ça mais pas du tout OK
est-ce que tu peux essayer de faire une
sorte de profil
qui avait le 5 d'abord tu verras
oui d'accord
en fait en plus une fois on la faiblesse
[Musique]
non mais du coup j'ai l'impression
c'est pas impossible avant de Forest on
sait qu'il a déjà gagné le tada style
donc c'est un super choix qui a un petit
hello là actuellement il y a un truc à
noter sur bonne soirée il a mal joué au
début de mois les dernières parties sont
vraiment pas mal
il doit gagner contre
[Musique]
ouais non mais tu sens qu'il est
vraiment monté en plus c'est quoi avant
de faire
[Musique]
il est sur cinq nul et une victoire de
victoire de suite je peux tricher
Mathieu et dire 11 vente foresting
avec les Noirs bon contre gamer il était
mieux puis après il a souffert et la
finale de tour OK et donc du coup ouais
ça marche pas notre DT mais c'était
quand même c'était quand même une bonne
idée mais cavaliers
4 bah il faut essayer de trouver quelque
chose mais tu as raison à un tour des
quatre jolies mais bon c'est nul
promotion nul autour des cartes
peut-être
[Musique]
je vais doubler et surtout je vais jouer
à 4 contre je
d'ailleurs sur KFC est-ce que je peux
pas essayer de continuer je vais tourner
deux
et là maintenant le chanteur
D8 et
voilà j'ai ouais j'ai évité la nulle
pendant 2 coups mais pas grand chose ok
donc du coup autour des 4 c'était bien
mignon il est pas impossible qu'on voit
ça ça
je suis d'accord après il est mis au
temps ce qui va essayer de prendre bien
après objectivement nul ça me paraît
normal
ça c'est la ok rapporte guéri c'est
toujours un peu mieux pour les blancs ou
pas
donc on était parti ici il a joué un
coup
il a répété une fois les coups
assez particulière je trouve aujourd'hui
mais bon
du coup c'est 4 ok ok
[Musique]
le fameux
là tu veux peut-être prendre des tours
C5 ouais mais bon je joue ah oui et des
cinq derrière
j'ai l'impression que je suis mieux
quand même
du coup la page de ça on va voir ce
qu'il a joué 17 tours
on a quand même le cavalier la faiblesse
ici contre la paire de fonds
pour deux résultats après c'est
peut-être 80% nul il va tourner guérie
au moins il pourra jouer
c'est un 80 95
j'ai vu il y a pas mal de coups qui ont
été joués
nous avons peut-être revenir un peu en
arrière donc il a pas joue le A4 après à
3 qui était intéressant c'est à peu près
là ils ont ouais voilà donc là il est
passé par F7 quand ça existe on a déjà
vu ça dans les historiens
on amène la tour et Regal easy prend des
mesures par rapport à ton idée de claque
en G4
il fait tout pour éviter le sacrifice en
G4 déjà il emmène son roi loin du
sacrifice éventuel tu laisses ton ranger
deux c'était suicidaire et tour B2 comme
ça il peut faire une défense de rangée
repasser de l'autre côté
il veut tenir sur cette aile là
globalement il tient ici et un jour il
pourra peut-être jouer pour ces 5 mais
bon
c'est un jour un pour l'instant c'est
lui qui va subir
il y a eu des coups de jouets
il est parti peut-être se mettre là
c'est marrant quand même ce qu'on ce
qu'on voit comme Magnus avait
gagné en fait parce que les noirs sont
sans doute très bien mais c'est eux qui
sont du côté pour jouer pour le gains
et oui c'est pas si facile et c'est très
complexe ils ont rien à changer au bout
de 2h30 de jeu
et oui
et on est dans les rock opposés
maintenant quasiment une fois que le roi
sera bien
en fait chaque joueur pousse devant son
roi
du fond de court c'est Nadal qui serait
bien et salut à tous ceux qui arrivent
ok du coup il est courte un peu plus
[Musique]
pas encore apparemment
mais bon ça va ça va
[Musique]
j'y crois pas trop
rager 6 E4
x 4
[Musique]
grand chose qu'au pire même si tu joues
une finale
de Tokyo elle est nulle
oui le petit Pione qui peut arriver
bon il y a pas grand chose
à rognan qui était bien au temps mais
elle a été très bien cette partie un
matin avec McDo à l'offensive
donc on était parti là et là il a un
fichier longtemps il me semble
F3
parce que c'est dur on peut pas prendre
en dessin tu avais prévu cavalier prend
et 40 le four de case noir ça fait mal
donc il va pas voulu mais d'un point
c'est trois fois F2
il a joué 24 minutes
bon par contre c'est le premier coup de
l'ordi c'est bien joué
et D4 bon bah on a des conventions pour
la qualité
il y a la tour
il faut faire
un coup parce que l'ordi mettez égal
avec les Blancs ne pas être moins bien
avec ses coups de merde
il y a pas de colonne pour les tours
ouais non c'est pour ça que peut-être
qu'il faut que je tourne
en mode ok je te donne ces deux mais au
moins je peux m'activer mes tours
et je rentre en B7 d'ailleurs peut-être
prendre ces deux c'est con d'ailleurs
donc c'est ça pour garder une pression
sur A5 même si c'est très bien défendu
OK et là les blancs vont essayer de pour
il pourrait il peut encore bien sûr
gagner à rognan il a trouvé les bons
coups de défense et dès que ça va
s'activer au niveau de ses tours ça va
être assez intéressant c'est une partie
très déséquilibrée où les deux joueurs
maintiennent leur chance de gagner
peut revenir sur F4 des fois oui
[Musique]
le fou si ton cavalier part de G3
peut-être que le foot peut aller en C6
pour contrôler B7 pour défendre par mon
B7 est-ce que les blancs peuvent essayer
de jouer pour ces trois c'est possible
ce serait même une bonne idée mais il
faut trouver le timing on va peut-être
maintenant
tours pour jouer ces trois mais bon il y
a toujours des 8 peut-être ah non il y a
pas
peut-être ça
intéressant
si tu te décales après je pourrais faire
Dame des 7
avec l'idée d'avoir du détroit et du
coup prend H3 tu es repartir oublier
faire attention un peu des deux côtés ça
peut encore vriller
on commence à voir ce dessiner des
résultats en fait Mathieu il y a que
celle-là qui indécise nul
rapport de guéris sans doute nulle vente
forest à boussatorov peut-être nul
parce qu'il y a pas eu déjà nuls
non
il cherche dans forest est-ce que je
peux continuer
le Gumball de dernière ronde devant de
Forest c'est après il se la fait coller
en Jean Cavalier F7 par exemple donc du
coup c'est toujours dur pour le joueur
[Musique]
du coup on va se faire dominer à l'aile
dame
parce que le GH qu'on va avoir
papillon passé pour le moment ça va être
long à activer
OK
donc ça va
jouer donc Magnus hop on revient
OK
bon c'est agréable avec les noirs
mais loin d'être gagnant
[Musique]
il a joué voilà on se dit que c'est
logique de continuer quoi autant le
mettre vraiment à l'abri
en D1 il est un peu bizarre parce que
des fois mais normalement ça marche
jamais trop pour les noirs
c'est vrai
en fait les blancs il est blond on peut
avoir un plan un jour à base de je sais
pas genre fouder deux cavalier bouge
pour prendre un A5
mais ça a pas l'air de marcher trop il y
aura
plein pour les blancs c'est le seul truc
que je vois parce que pour l'instant si
on prend à 5 il prend un atome
moyen de pouvoir menacer de prendre à 5
mais c'est pas étroit fou des deux en
fait j'assemble
nous demande pourquoi Magnus avait gros
avantage ici et ben c'est une bonne
question Hyperion ce réglage je
l'indique cela
[Musique]
des fois on trouve par hasard parce que
là je vous indique quelque chose les
sacrificions G4 déjà vous pouvez
peut-être faire AG pour poser une
question mais
[Musique]
oui il y avait AB ok c'est de l'autre
côté
et en fait
un béton C6
[Musique]
on est obligé de regarder il y a madame
en l'air
ça vaut puait c'est quand même pas si
simple de tout prévoir même celle-là
même si l'ordi ok il me dit deux pour
les Noirs mais en fait
je revenais ah non je peux pas parler
c'est le bordel
c'était quand même pas si facile parce
qu'il faut le voir de là faut ouvrir les
deux structures faut vraiment
que les processus il y a un truc drôle
c'est que le coup de leur dit enfin si
j'ai moi j'ai vu une ligne donc je dois
juste s'en fout des deux c'était des
cinq emprises trois fois
peut-être dans la ligne là
tu voulais voir
fou des deux
là il fait des 5
introuvable vous voyez il fallait ouvrir
la position mais c'est trop dur de loin
et là trois reprises possibles en plus
j'avais laissé mon pion des 6 qui était
pas si clair ok même comme là on sait
que c'est bon ben on y va facile on
s'est assis
oui oui c'est possible mais même même si
tu penses faut tout valider enfin il y a
tout à regarder dans ce cas là non mais
c'est très ordinateur quand même
il a un bon pressing en fait dans cette
position donc il se dit bon voilà c'est
enfin ça joue quoi il a pas besoin le
plus dur c'est d'y penser en fait
oui oui
mais cavaliers
vous savez que c'est dur
très très dur très très dur ok attends
on voit plus à la caméra je me suis dit
que c'était mon cadrage qui avait qui
avait bougé maintenant c'est Matt qui a
bougé et il m'a fait une blague j'ai cru
j'ai cru au problème technique alors que
pour l'instant je crois que c'est
vraiment ok ça fait plaisir d'être aussi
balaise en technique heureusement tu
étais là pour pour mettre quand même un
petit un petit partage d'écran un moment
parce que sinon c'est normalement j'ai
un peu juste voilà mais du coup
qu'est-ce que tu veux aller voir Matt
est-ce que tu as un petit
nul ou pas Kemer Google il y a un petit
pressing blanc ça continue
ok
c'est bien en fait comme tu peux pas
rentrer ça sert pas à grand chose oui
Mathieu nous rappelle à quoi sert une
colonne rentrer dans le coin
vont jouer à 5 France
on l'aura peut-être un jour on l'aura
peut-être un jour Mathieu ça te ferait
plaisir
mais bon
c'est je pense pas que les Blancs
poussent cette nuit en fait vraiment pas
du tout non
je pense
il y a vraiment pas de points d'accroche
pour les deux joueurs et une émission
mais tu sais je vois les couleurs sur
les sur les fautes etc sur dame C8 tu
sais il y avait foo.fr 6 et finalement
pendant des six qu'on n'a pas vu et en
fait
sûrement il pouvait presser de
de meilleure manière tu voulais prendre
des 6
ah ça a du sens
noir
on revient non mais ça je pense un peu
mieux pour les blancs
on pouvait peut-être trouver quelque
chose qu'on a pas trouvé tout à l'heure
parce que c'était en temps de prendre un
F6 on peut prendre de deux pièces
d'ailleurs F6
et on peut toujours jouer de cavalier G3
mais il y a fougères 6 qui tient la
boutique
comment on cherche à savoir pourquoi il
y avait gros avantage
or c'est un vas-y ouais peut-être c'est
tout simple en fait faut jouer
en améliore la pièce qui ne joue pas ça
fait sens ce coup mais apparemment c'est
pas je vois pas mon coup
dans mon fiancé
et on contrôle des cases importantes
on n'a pas mis
[Musique]
donc elle prend des 6 on a proposé c'est
pas mal mais on a vu la jauge alors des
fois la jauge elle nous piège Mathieu
aussi bien c'est qu'elle prend des 6 et
on a vu des choses comme ça donc on
vérifiera on vérifiera pour une fois on
n'a pas utilisé l'ordi de la session de
stream mais on fait aller regarder des
cinq et cahiers des quatre
c'est pas facile
ah oui il est grand
non ça marche pas du tout
ça serait bizarre que ça soit ça face à
la Tour
si ça bon dame c'était très très dur
dans ma carte peut-être dans ma carte
n'importe quoi
on va voir je peux mettre les variantes
là on verra déjà si c'est Dame B3 maths
il fallait laisser faut prendre F3 on va
mettre dans le B3 très dur
j'ai pensé à dans ma carte au moins
c'est un peu plus logique pour les cases
mais quand j'ai eu j'ai dit il
faut arrêter les bêtises je prends et
c'est quoi
ça j'ai vu mais juste j'ai pensé qu'avec
la dame à 4 mais qu'est-ce qu'on menace
maintenant on va faire créer prend sur
quel écran
ah tu vas je sens il y aura pas roi
bouge à cause d'âme c'est dur quand même
peut-être une attaque nous dit math sur
le roi adverse mais c'était
bon tu peux te prendre des carottes tu
peux te faire mater même mat avec Dame
prend H3 enfin si roi H1 c'est dur quoi
en fait si ça marche c'est quand même
fort
très très difficile à imaginer
il y a toujours un problème qu'au départ
c'est très très dur c'est pour le final
de foot couleur à poser
ah si avec Dame dessin
trop dur à
là
tout en l'air mais même ça l'ignore
introuvable
donc dans le métro on peut pas dire que
c'était facile le coup de maths c'est
normal
mais c'était tentant Matt quand même
quand on voit la partie de jouer cette
ligne là
et l'autre c'est
il a vraiment voulu jouer pour la bonne
situation et carrière 4
c'est comme ça qui s'est fait avoir dans
le 3 à la fin d'un coup ouais j'ai trop
à la fin exactement
c'est bizarre il y a un pion en prise
ouais mais même si on le bouffe
pour 8
grande classe
ok donc on peut jouer j'ai trois mais ça
va quand même tourner vers
vers une égalité cette position
c'est un long travail j'ai ma tour en
huitième qui est un peu bloqué je
tourage fuite
[Musique]
il a tout mangé
il a raté
en fait non
mais ça peut jouer longtemps quoi il y a
pas encore
j'ai toujours la petite pression là
qu'il faut bien contrôler
et il a pas pris la nul il a joué
on va voir on va aller voir ça pour
l'instant
on est sur Magnus
on va regarder si tu veux donc là statu
quo quasiment dans la partie de Magnus
mais moins de chance peut-être que tout
à l'heure quand même parce que on vient
d'enlever les ruptures ou bien jouer non
mais là les il va bizarre s'il arrive à
faire marcher C6 mais il a raté quand il
avait le cavalier bien placé donc
c'était dur il voulait protéger sans
doute c'est dur
donc nous on avait trouvé une sorte de
nul dans cette dans cette partie autour
des 8
donc l'autre a pas jouer à 4 alors ça je
ne comprends pas là tu peux pas
tu donnes toi là l'autre peut refaire
nul et non là il fait ça et ben là tu
vas te prendre à quatre cas mon copain
[Musique]
du coup c'est bizarre parce que vent de
Forest il joue ça il doit avoir une idée
il veut faire un choix il veut jouer à
fond pour lui non mais la ligne c'est ça
vas-y tu peux continuer à 4 ça va être
c'est sûr c'est sûr ça donne pas
et là je sais pas si c'est dit
5 maths mais j'ai pas le temps
où
à 5 ouais
[Musique]
je te bouffe une fois je
vais être super maintenant il est noir
quand il va arriver là il va être
content parce que
j'ai pas le temps de jouer le 5 tu
prends B4
mais c'est bizarre parce que comme le
calcul est assez facile vas-y A4 là
[Musique]
c'est hyper chiant
malheureusement vous voyez la densité de
pièces blanches et puis le cavalier est
enfermé quand même c'est une prise de
risque énorme de vente forest qui a pas
les pièces bien coordonnées pour aller
dans la baston en fait
qu'est-ce qu'on loupe
pour moi ça me paraît forcément
parce que on a donné la case nous a dit
Mathieu B3
parce que les autres
par contre j'ai un problème avec mon
pion B
si ça va
ça paraît quand même plus dur à jouer en
pratique pour les noirs
plus qu'à lg8 bizarre qui bloque la
tourage 8 ça fait beaucoup de bizarrerie
et du coup final je prends j'ai de H3
mais là ça a l'air de mal marcher et du
coup j'ai pas trouvé Mathieu mais
peut-être que je pouvais jouer KS3
ouais moi mais du coup
maintenant je peux prendre des cavaliers
[Musique]
moins bien ici parce que tu m'as laissé
j'ai BK
j'ai l'impression que c'est les blancs
qui jouent pour le gars
mais bon ok bon c'est peut-être de toute
façon c'est ça ou rien c'est ça sonne en
fait tu as trouvé son idée mais j'y
crois pas trop c'est bizarre quand même
de jouer pour le gain avec H4 enfin ça
fait hyper peur après les mecs sont fous
ils sont capables
allez du coup on va aller voir par rame
à sa joie un peu ce qu'on a dit non oui
donc on était à dams
j'ai pensé tout à l'heure mais je me
suis dit ça va pas marcher on va on va
jamais récupérer ces trois donc des
prends
pourquoi pas danser 6 comme ça je garde
ces trois donc là c'est le jeu des
blancs d'ouvrir les colonnes Mathieu
donc c'était ton idée
et en fait il a fait dans le sens
inverse pour avoir cette position
qu'a-t-il prévu sur tour C8 comment il
vient gagner ça
alors il y a d'autres options ou pas
pousser 5 échecs
B4 non
c'est vraiment le coup standard Aigle
Noir qu'est-ce qu'il a prévu avec les
Blancs ouais parce que pour ces deux il
y a faut mettre
attends
[Musique]
en fait je cherche Mathieu le plan blanc
de récupération du pion c'est
[Musique]
c'est quand même assez long on pourrait
voir alors ton foutait cinq peut-être
arriver ah non il y a mon cas et H4
aussi qu'il faut bon c'est sur échec
donc ça va mais je n'avais pas vu
en plus cavalier F1 qui avalé G6 donc
c'est pas si facile à Mathieu société
cavalier prend F6 suivi G4
bonjour de Christophe coller seul
Christophe
[Musique]
la jauge comprend pas l'idée d'un rognon
ça commence à faire beaucoup de monde
qui vont valider darognan
enfin si ouvrez la colonne c'est bien
mais il faut récupérer puis on C3
oui je me rappelle très bien de toi dans
le chat on me dit bonjour je me rappelle
très bien bien sûr à Bordeaux échec de
toute façon il se souvient les Girondins
en Ligue 2 ça donne quoi Mathieu il y a
3-0 bon match tu vas des fois au stade
quasiment plus garde quasiment tous les
matchs
il y a eu un coup dans la partie d'Abdou
il a pas joué à 4
et ils ont répété des coups ah non le
nom du coup non mais c'est vraiment
tellement bête H4 on va voir dans la
partie de c'est incroyable j'hallucine
il a joué H4 kg 4 qui est ici tour de 2
maintenant tu peux plus revenir en
il était juste moins bien
elle s'est trompé hein
ça va vouloir continuer à moins que tu
auras 5 non
tu fais quoi
effectivement
c'est compliqué à calculer
[Musique]
le 5
là je contrôle donc c'est le contrôle
ah la coordination des pièces noires et
il est vent de Forest quand même pas
dégueu ce qu'on a dit bon ça va être nul
mais les mecs ils cherchent et c'est une
belle idée quand même tu vois mais
attends par contre on a toujours faim
oui c'est une belle idée parce qu'il a
fait mais on avait quand même
l'éventualité
alors que c'est ultra thématique dans
tous les siennes de choix 4 et le mec il
le joue pas
ça peut arriver se tromper mais là on
était d'accord on a même la jauge on a
beaucoup de choses qui bon et je joue
pas OK
dans la position finale sur trois H5
qu'est-ce qui peut jouer E5
peu mais E5 je sais pas D5
parce que
[Musique]
et là il y a les deux
pas si facile quand même si ça donne
envie avec les bandes trouver un truc
des cinq stratégiquement c'est moche
mais peut-être tactiquement ça passe
parce que si je pique les pions ça va
quoi
Mathieu voulait mettre mes pions sur
blanc pour mon fou soit étouffé alors
dites cavalier le 4 ici
[Musique]
4 j'y ai pensé mais j'ai pas trouvé j'ai
pensé à pions prendre
c'était vraiment dur là
ah ouais d'accord mais c'est quand même
pas facile
il faut que je joue un coup quand même
je trouve pas de cou tu sais je suis
bien embêté faudrait que je prenne en F6
et joue à 8 et que je lâche le
peut-être
mais ça tu peux être moins bien
en fait je faisais dans mon froc là avec
les Noirs
je me suis dit ça va être tout de suite
foutu
du coup ah oui j'ai pas vu j'ai pas vu
j'ai pas vu ah oui oui
j'ai pas le choix je trouve
bravo Mathieu extraordinaire
et le vinasse
de nous corrompre un petit peu et il dit
quelqu'un vu la pépite de Sochaux hier
d'ailleurs en parlant de Ligue 2
il y a toujours des beaux rebonds non
j'ai pas vu la pépite non non je me
focus Ligue 1 je joue MP j'ai toujours
MPG aussi
[Musique]
qui ne connaissent pas c'est un jeu de
foot 1 vous êtes un peu le manager de
votre équipe et votre équipe réelle donc
kg 4 carré et C6 et je vais rebondir là
dessus c'est la partie la plus
intéressante depuis le début
guérir la porte on va faire un petit
tour
allez donc guérir rapporte
[Musique]
donc les blancs sont un peu mieux parce
que le cavalier est bien placé mais
c'est très solide parce que la faiblesse
est en 6 il y a la paire de fou donc ça
peut se retrouver avec des
fous de couleur à poser on est pas loin
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
ah oui rapporte pas son style ça va être
long long et peut-être bon pour guérir
mais
[Musique]
ok
même en cas de gain il n'est pas du tout
sûr salut happy medid salut à tous qui
arrive MPG c'est mon petit gazon une
appli de football manager c'est le jeu
où joue au Magnus mais simplement en
anglais ça existe aussi en anglais bah
c'est même beaucoup plus
différent mais il y a plein de gens
d'échecs qui font ça il y a une ligue
check basée et jouer Sophie aussi avec
Arsène il y a plein plein de gens
d'échec mais c'est beaucoup plus global
il était dans les meilleurs du monde il
s'est fait interviewer sur ça
sur la première ligue 2
c'était l'idée tu as trouvé un Matthieu
l'idée qu'il avait pas de toute façon il
y avait ça ou rien
et en fait E5 est le seul coup qui
égalise peut-être mais il a peut-être vu
le 5 je t'aime pour
en fait pas bête il est obligé
par contre il fallait avoir vu ça mais
c'est possible
ok on est vraiment
il y a eu du lourd je vais mettre la cam
il a très bien
tu risques pas vraiment de perdre dans
cette rue il a échangé toutes les tours
il a pris
très bien joué
et son idée c'est juste de partir et
pousser et en pratique ça c'est l'enfer
bien sûr avec les Blancs et c'est
vraiment plus humain que ce qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure parce que tout à l'heure
c'était vraiment calculatoire
franchement je trouvais que c'est très
difficile là c'est beau c'est du beau
jeu c'est c'est en plus ça lui ressemble
bien à Magnus très simple très simple on
comprend alors l'ordi je sais pas ce
qu'il dit mais en tout cas
[Musique]
00 franchement on va se prendre les
pions dans la gueule et vous allez voir
que manus compte bien gagner cette
position alors peut-être que
j'ai juste envie
c'est food F3
déjà pas hyper naturel parce que tu
donnes des tempos
oui parce que si je prends prends G4 tu
fais de la machin pour me faire des
guilis là par là
je voyais pas d'autres idées
et après on peut pas venir boucher les
trous des fois je peux faire un cavalier
2 et venir sacrifier j'ai trois ou F4
bien sûr
cette faible donc faut pas faire
n'importe quoi
fantasy Premier League ouais c'est ça je
cherchais le nom depuis tout à l'heure
tu nous pose la question qu'il fallait
pas habituer j'ai pas vu
bon il faut que j'aille regarder hein
tout le truc
alors je fais je vais le faire je vais
le faire j'ai promis j'ai laissé Mathieu
commenter cette position après je vais
lui laisser la patate chaude voilà bam
c'est fait et moi je suis en train de
faire des trucs de folie des 7 fois 5 je
pense mais j'en sais rien ou cavaliers
[Musique]
ça me paraissait logique
non ok je pense ça va point noir mais
c'est pour les blancs mais c'est très
dur à jouer je vais voir s'il y a des
coups
allez mon parram moi je pense pas mais
il va gagner
mais nous parrain de regarder classement
on s'en fout du département je suis pas
loin je suis pas loin de le trouver tu
veux parram alors je te mets pas rames
il faut pas
une idée c'est juste je bloque le pion
que je viens de donner quoi enfin c'est
une idée en fait
il va mettre le cavalier sur F4 bon là
il attaque B6 donc tu dois bouger le fou
ou alors tu fais x 4 ah c'est peut-être
ça son idée
j'avais pas vu
ah mais il faut accueil est protégé donc
je peux jouer dame c'est un 4 c'est 4
j'ai pas le choix
une fois tu prends des 7 je reprends du
fou ça m'arrange
à quelle heure ça se vend en général je
sais pas si vous rappeler la fois où il
y avait joué il l'avait fait à la fin de
la partie pendant les autres parties en
cours
donc c'est
peut-être que cette année il y a une
horreur donc alors
cette année ça sera la fin maintenant
c'est des partages après
ça sera en 3 + 2 Mathieu
3 + 2 donc un match en trois plus deux
sièges
ça sera donc là je parle du cas
classique à deux joueurs
je sais pas s'il y a trois joueurs et
s'il y a un il y a une mort subite avec
deux minutes 30 pour les blancs 3
minutes pour les Noirs incrément
toujours de 2 secondes bien sûr la mort
subite sera obligation de gagner pour
les blancs bien sûr mort subite
normalement il y a pas d'incrément
de deux secondes
bien sûr il est un peu c'est normalement
non il y a pas
il y aura un incrément
en cas d'égalité pour la première place
non mais les noirs sont mieux là dans la
non mais dans ils veulent
c'est bien d'ailleurs dans l'idée
à 15 + 10 serait quand même mieux
c'est quand même un peu moche pour ce
type de tournoi bon ça joue sur un coup
de dés un petit peu
donc ça me choque pas qui est
pas mal d'organisateurs font ça ça coûte
pas beaucoup de temps à l'organisation
avant la remise des prix ces
spectaculaire c'est bien pour l'image du
tournoi je pense
j'adore la blouson de Param
il a que 15 minutes de retard la pendule
il faut juste qu'il fasse gaffe il reste
12 coups à jouer pour être sympa
mais oui on préfère mais on a toujours
pas l'explication mais tu vois
il y avait pas tout à l'heure
ma décision quand même
[Musique]
il va avoir du cavalier il va essayer de
leur gagner mais les Noirs vont essayer
d'organiser du jeu sur la loi d'un truc
en 16,5 un cavalier un F4 un truc H3 là
il y a du Spiel
plus 6 degrés pas évident
c'était pour la mort subite sur la plage
en tout cas vous avez pas mal d'idées
apparemment pour le départage dans le
chat mais sur l'échiquier on préfère
[Musique]
c'est vraiment pénible à regarder même
si
ça joue toujours ses fantastiques
il y a un pion qui a été qui a été
attrapé dans la bagarre juste pour vous
dire
il m'a donné un pion pour avoir un petit
peu de jeu
ces pièces
ça va être nul prochainement quand même
ça va pas rigolote je crois à 5 ans dans
les pieds
Rennes et Carana ont déjà fini il y a
longtemps bon et digne connaissait pas
bien et a pris une nulle rapide Carlsen
c'est hyper intéressant il vient de
sacrifier une pièce pour deux pions il
est du bon côté alors dit mais également
mais il est du bon côté de l'égalité
c'est lui qui met la pression clairement
on va aller voir ça après
la Kemer gooche à l'écran juste pour
voir Mathieu comment ça c'est commencer
passé ben ok H4 pour essayer de fixer
comme tu l'as dit mais les Noirs te
saoulent et du coup
les changes d'armes ça devait pas être
perdant non plus honnêtement il a
préféré des garder ok petit pressing
blanc de rien du tout
mon avis
on peut se s'entendre là et un coup dans
la partie d'art rognon
on va aller voir après OK
et ça continue pour parram qui pourrait
faire Suarez à rognon dans cette
position
il peut y avoir du
Fuji 5 c'est quand le
de jouer
un peu en avance tu as vu ouais
tu as payé ton abonnement pas moi du
coup
déjà tu peux
[Musique]
ouais mais il est faussement en l'air
peut-être ou vraiment en l'air je peux
faire aussi le ramassage
en tout cas faut vérifier ce que nous
raconte voyez l'histoire de fou prend un
choix c'est qu'en 4G prend un H3
et fourchette royale donc en fait le
truc c'est quand j'en fous prends H3 je
peux me faire pigeonner parce que par
exemple mat il propose dame D1
et j'attaque
autrement c'est quoi maintenant
j'ai deux projets
même ça je sais pas comment juger tu vas
me bouffer H4 mais bon j'ai tout fait ah
tu as peut-être tourner
je suis parti dans le décor de rage de
Raj mate pas
[Musique]
ça se regarde quand même et franchement
c'est hyper chaud là pour ça pas ça se
passe mal pour les voilà
pour moi il est un peu insulté le jeu en
faisant
une couche en fait il est tellement
content dans un sens qui dit ouais c'est
bien fait bien fait bien fait
non
c'est peut-être une meilleure version
parce que
parrain il a tout ça à regarder par
contre c'est pas facile hein calculer
les petit nuances et tout ça alors que
c'est Google qui vient de faire un match
nul je vous ai laissé la cam
je crois que c'est lui hein
il a raté un petit avantage difficile la
dame B3 très difficile
bon restez pas
j'ai changé
le petit temps après pour que ça
devienne effectif
j'ai changé j'ai mis un petit mixcam
parce qu'on est sur aronia et Max au
loup jamais vu cette caméra je peux te
dire pourtant j'avais tous les bons
liens mats tu peux faire confiance à ma
technique légendaire et c'est bizarre
quoi c'est bizarre c'est pas très grave
pas très grave on n'a pas envie tu as
pas envie de voir un rognon de toute
façon en ce moment
des bières à 2h du mat je lui dis la
prochaine fois moi j'adore le billard
mais bon à deux heures du mat moi
j'ai cru que c'était des bières à 2h du
matin j'ai compris ça
grand tournoi comme celui-là quelle est
la motivation de se battle à fond sur
les chiquer pour les joueurs au milieu
du classement
c'est juste de jouer aux échecs quoi
c'est comme une équipe de foot qui
serait en milieu de tableau en lien elle
doit jouer ses matchs les joueurs sont
pro ils sont là pour assurer les
spectacles et il y en a qui ont envie de
revenir l'année prochaine
par rapport à ce que tu veux dire sur
les mecs de milieu de tableau ça peut
être le petit jeune qui est dans un club
intermédiaire qui a envie de se faire
recruter par une top team c'est vrai
il y en a qui se bougent qui joue
vachement bien en décembre avant les
mercato
après là
top team tout ceux qui sont là ils sont
assez tranquilles quand même
c'est dans le sens où ils sont motivés
pour se faire inviter dans d'autres
et là je m'attendais genre cavalier fin
que j'ai 6 pressing
on a toujours la plus de thème mais bon
c'est pire en pire quand même
petite pression sur la 5 peut-être ça
aussi
c'est chaud
il vient d'être papa
aussi bon finalement mat est en train de
s'adoucir voilà le moment carnet rose
dans le travail j'ai connu ça bah
surtout c'est fatiguant en fait c'est
au-delà de c'est très fatigant et toi tu
m'en parlais pas plus tard
qu'aujourd'hui il y a cet aspect là tu
dis quand tu pars en tournoi tu es en
vacances tu peux dormir évidemment sauf
que moi je joue plus tu le sais hein
donc du coup j'avais pas ce
je savais pas ce plaisir là j'aimerais
bien rejouer je t'avoue que ça me ça me
démange honnêtement parce que ça fait
longtemps que je joue plus parce que je
donne des cours ok très bien j'adore ça
mais vraiment le jeu c'est c'est
particulier c'est top aussi et comme
j'ai arrêté il y a longtemps j'aimerais
bien j'aimerais bien reprendre et c'est
pas un tournoi dans l'année le top c'est
magnifique mais ça suffit pas quoi c'est
super sympa d'être en tournoi j'ai
beaucoup moins qu'avant mais je joue
quand même est-ce que quelqu'un sera un
montant et ben oui j'y serai le rap
premier tournoi du rapide de Montendre
rapide et Blitz sur deux jours tu de
vous faire un peu de pub Mathieu
ok ok le mec se bouge il y aura une
simultanée d'Étienne bacros un rapide un
Blizz sur deux jours des activités moi
je fais un bide contre Mazet et une
master class et c'est vrai il s'est
bouché top pour faire un truc pas mal
super bravo mon tendre
ok bon on préfère les noirs on peut
venir à Magnus est-ce qu'il y a un coup
Magnus Magnus Magnus c'est bien tu sais
que je sais
le bluff F3 matte avait envie de voir ce
fouet F3 merguezi se trompe pas
je viens de trouver fois H3 et comme on
l'avait pas dit je me dis tiens sur
rigolo faut H3 je vais essayer
d'accompagner je vais essayer
d'accompagner c'est peut-être risqué
mais tant pis j'ai pas vu donc
il nous a dit on peut sacrifier ici et
maintenant sur G3 tu peux sacrifier ici
aussi
radar j'aimerais bien jouer food et 8 à
un moment il faudra peut-être que Magnus
le joue pour avoir sa dame mobile la
dame met du temps à revenir dans le jeu
F3 j'ai pas envie regardez maths va
croquer les cases à pleines dents et va
me rire au nez
pas sur ton fond à je pense au mieux
pendant cette tu vois on n'avait pas
c'était pour aider les pions dans le
futur
mais il faudrait madame manger 5 je
serai content
je peux dire je t'aime mais c'est ça
c'est pour ça que je pensais fou des 8
cavaliers G5 mes pièces noires sont pas
si bien placées donc Magnus doit se
trouver un setup il a réfléchir ce avec
mais je règle le problème si vous voulez
j'en ai marre du pion c'est ça
et tu as peut-être qu'à cette casser ici
toujours l'embrouille quoi non mais ça
c'est bien je suis content je suis
content tu vas me ramener l'autre
cavalier en B5 bon ça va il y a les
pions j'ai peur
j'aimerais bien user de ma dame pour
aider la poussée des pions on leur dit a
pas trop aimé bon je m'en fiche fouder 8
c'est dans dans l'esprit
moi j'aurais plutôt gardé le fou
j'aurais fait foudre
et ben Jean-Michel tu vas être à la
simulation
tu auras forte à faire
multiple champion de France avant avant
un Français hyper reconnu il est
toujours extrêmement respecté vous avez
vu que cette année malgré donc bah la
progression de jumeaux Sart il a quand
même énormément inquiété au chemin de
France c'était pas dit Jul était favori
avec Etienne on va dire et après il y a
il y a des jours dangereux en maths
voilà
c'était plutôt avec le format tu en
penses quoi toi du format Mathieu tu
aimes bien tu n'aimes pas pour les
spectateurs
donc ça veut tout dire non mais moi là
en allemand cette année ça m'arrangeait
parce que je revenais d'Inde j'ai joué
Olympiades et j'en ai vu on est parti
directement d'Inde et en fait j'étais là
si je suis éliminé je suis content de
rentrer chez moi avant ma famille OK et
studio reste ça veut dire que j'ai bien
joué donc je suis content aussi mais
dans l'absolu tu préfères le l'ancien
format qui était le format des puristes
d'ailleurs un peu comme le tata le
l'autre mais ça m'a pas dérangé comme
certains après il y a des années vous
ont fait des trucs bizarres Displayer
des nuls ce que je peux comprendre et il
y a une année j'ai fait 11 nuls donc je
m'y connais un peu mais par exemple ils
avaient enlevé ils avaient autorisé la
faire nul en moins de 30 coups c'est
complètement con tu veux des spectacles
et tu rajoutes cette règle il y a une
Annette t'avais pas le droit de faire
nul sauf si tu avais trop chaud
ça j'étais pas au courant maths elle a
été écrite quelque part parce qu'elle
est monstrueuse ça ou alors c'est
l'arbitre qui sympathiquement tu as dit
toi mat a le droit de faire nul si tu as
trop chaud
c'était n'importe quoi
à Nîmes
donc ils ont fait deux trois trucs assez
bêtes mais dans l'absolu moi je préfère
même si j'aime bien faire neuf je
préfère qu'il y ait
qui est pas le droit de faire nul tout
simplement ou 30 coups
c'est dans l'air du temps comme ça j'ai
même pas réfléchir si je propose je suis
obligé de jouer oui et après tu peux pas
empêcher de mec de faire de le son bah
oui c'est un peu la problématique
j'allais dire Mathieu surtout dans ces
tournois où tout le monde se connaît
[Musique]
si deux joueurs avant de faire de nuls
et jouer juste les rapides tu faisais
quoi bah c'est ce qui se passe
je sais pas on peut imaginer il y a eu
quand même des nuls qui étaient modestes
on va dire Mathieu pour voilà donc il y
a toujours ce phénomène là en 2000
c'était pas modeste pour la troisième
place je suis d'accord c'était un peu
plus solide voilà
en plus j'ai visé personne il y en a qui
sont utilisés non bon on sait que ça
existe de toute façon et c'est normal
dans la config ou ça enchaînait avec
différents tournois je crois que c'est
Maxime Lagarde aussi qui était pas enfin
qui était forcément mécontent son
tournoi mais qui était pas mécontent
au moins mais tu pouvais rentrer chez
toi ce qui était déjà pas mal
mais quand tu fais un patron c'est
cagoulé c'est non oui et quand vous
enchaînez il y a un truc intéressant
dans la partie de désolé de Aniche
c'est l'ordinateur a annoncé qu'il a
raté un bon avantage après roi G7 alors
ordinateur la jauge hein
le coup j'ai pas vu l'explication
pourquoi c'était si fort bon froid on
n'a pas envie de le faire donc c'est
Dame prend E
mais là il y a F4 il gagne un peu
tu peux montrer
de la défense de D6 je peux échanger la
dame reprendre et en plus les pièces
sont super bien placées
je peux vous dire
ça va tomber ça
davantage mais il a fait un truc assez
marrant pour jouer pour le gain il a
joué F4 G4 on balance tout
mais c'est pas bête du tout enfin c'est
vraiment hyper intéressant
c'est stable si vous voulez au centre
c'est pas fermé c'est stable il contrôle
le sens
finale
c'est pas la même finale dans l'autre tu
gagnes un pion quand même
ça
serait une bonne finale aussi je pense
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire cahier des 5
ou des 5 faut pas faire
moins bien mais
l'échange de dames a du sens que tu
faisais attaquer ton roi donc Mathieu
bon réflexe bien sûr évidemment ça tu
connais d'ailleurs Mathieu hier ou avant
hier je sais plus on me demandait
quels sont pour toi les qualités de
Mathieu et pourquoi il est pas encore
plus fort aux échecs et tout ça alors
j'ai répondu Mathieu en théorie en
calcul c'est quasiment parfait
[Musique]
quand tu étais jeune c'était quand même
parfait qu'est-ce qu'il y a ce qui s'est
passé Mathieu c'est les nuits mes nuits
donc du coup c'est en fait j'ai répondu
et je lui dis bah tiens je lui poserai
la question voilà j'ai répondu j'ai dit
en théorie il a quand même fait des des
travaux importants
il était horrible très tard genre quand
j'étais jeune tu te rappelles ce que je
veux oui et tu me disais non mais je me
rappelle mais tu étais oui oui mais
après ben en fait oui quand tu étais
jeune mais tu étais quand même en avant
sur les autres jeunes parce que si tu
veux bon déjà tu travailles plus
même si Mathieu disait souvent qu'il
travaille pas beaucoup mais c'était pas
beaucoup par rapport à l'élite de
l'élite donc c'est toujours Latif
évidemment
mais un truc j'étais j'ai eu un manque
d'ambition aussi et en fait j'aimais
bien ma vie aussi j'ai une vie sociale
je me suis pas mis à fond dans les
échecs après il m'a manqué des capacités
purement chicken j'ai une bonne mémoire
mais pas une mémoire comme le top top ça
c'est intéressant parce que toi tu sais
nous on sait pas enfin il faut être
confronté pour une bonne mémoire surtout
aux échecs mais je me rappelle quand tu
étais tout jeune à Créon d'un truc enfin
tu vois tu avais recité une de tes
parties tu étais hyper fière d'un match
je sais pas tu te rappelles de ça
non tu avais fait maintenant vraiment
très longtemps et du coup tu étais hyper
content et puis ouais je crois que c'est
un truc comme ça tu vois et du coup
c'était très impressionnant parce que là
tu montrais déjà des je me dis en
capacité de mémorisation je me
débrouiller quand même correctement je
vois le mec c'était un peu
extraterrestre histoire donc
c'est incomparable par rapport au top
j'ai toujours été plutôt mauvais en
finale parce que je les ai jamais
vraiment travaillé j'aimais pas ça et là
j'ai commencé à m'y intéresser de leur
limite pendant le confinement c'est
beaucoup bah oui et non je dirais que
c'est quand même la culture française il
y avait quand même pas une grosse école
de formation ça commence à arriver parce
que tu as les joueurs français qui sont
beaucoup plus forts bah comme toi par
exemple donc on a on a une culture qui
va être de plus en plus grande mais je
dirais que ça c'est logique quoi si tu
le fais pas par toi-même tu avais pas
une structuration d'entraînement autour
de toi comme il y a dans d'autres sports
même si tu as eu des choses Mathieu je
pense ça à toi de le dire quasiment rien
ouais c'est pas beaucoup hein tu as fait
quelques stages en équipe de France des
choses comme ça j'ai fait deux stages et
en fait mon premier entraîneur c'était
super quand j'avais 11 ans j'ai commencé
tard d'ailleurs je fais mon prêt
étonnant à 11 ans ça je me rappelle
et après j'ai joué déjà j'étais
complètement inconnu je rappelle pas
franchement je suis arrivé complètement
inconnu tu sais il y avait des Libye
maso hyper connu planter des mecs comme
ça HR euh de Cannes et moi je suis
arrivé hyper tard mais je suis monté
très vite j'ai dépassé tout le monde
mais j'avais beaucoup beaucoup de
lacunes
j'étais très bon dans certains trucs et
beaucoup de lacunes et j'ai pris pour la
première fois des cours quand j'avais 19
ans avec Darkman
j'avais déjà une énorme mais
j'avais 22 je crois on sait de 20 à 22
j'ai dû bosser avec lui il m'a dit enfin
c'était marrant parce qu'il m'a dit tu
sais genre regarder les parties après on
a dit on peut faire un petit bilan
il m'a dit ok les ouvertures j'ai pas
compris ce que tu joues sur 4
n'importe quoi j' alternais j'avais rien
et depuis maintenant c'est je suis connu
pour avoir un point fort je suis bien
préparé ce qui est vrai et après il m'a
dit en tactique il me dit j'ai jamais vu
quelqu'un de ton niveau pouvoir donner
des pièces en un coup moi j'ai fait
énormément de GAFFE j'ai déjà perdu
beaucoup de pièces en fait je pouvais
calculer très loin les lignes même
prendre une fourchette au premier mais
toi tu es un peu pareil non oui oui mais
bon c'est beaucoup plus fort donc c'est
normalement on dit plus on est fort plus
on est consent donc pour toi qui
calculent quand même très très bien
c'est vrai que c'est plutôt étonnant et
je pouvais craquer un truc assez
hallucinant après il m'a dit
stratégiquement c'est quand même mon
vrai point faible à l'époque maintenant
je pense c'est un peu de mon point fort
mais le problème c'est que c'est trop
tard bien sûr
il m'a dit final tu connais rien
il sera je me rappelle une partie quand
j'avais à cette époque donc j'avais 25
50 j'avais comme maintenant quasiment et
un moment j'avais refusé de jouer fous
cavalier contre endroit j'avais laissé
un pion à mon adversaire juste parce que
j'étais pas sûr si j'arrive à mater
après depuis je l'ai vu deux fois j'ai
gagné deux fois mais bon
je savais pas ça je connaissais pas
anecdote celle-là elle est pas mal
celle-là elle est pas mal et donc du
coup voilà non il me manquait plein de
trucs et aussi
ouais quand tu comprends vite que tu
peux pas aller très loin je préférais un
autre mode de vie mais je regarde pas du
tout toi je comprends je comprends oui
donc toute façon hyper bizarre dans la
partie d'Aniche on va regarder merci
d'avoir répondu en tout cas mal et
lentement c'est terrible
et genre là il pouvait reprendre aussi
c'est faire H4 en fait il voulait pas
elle prend donc il a fait faux D5 sauf
que maintenant c'est pas si clair prise
sur C4
et la jauge de Rodier égale dame 6 au
prochain
maintenant pour finir
j'étais nul partout
mais il m'a dit par contre tu as de la
chance il exigeant donc les grands
très bien avec lui
soit tu arrêtes soit tu passes
grand-mère tu passais grand-mère en 3
mois il m'a dit mais tu as de la chance
parce que ton gros point fort aux échecs
c'est que je suis très imaginatif
et je l'ai toujours aimé et toujours été
pendant je pense le et la l'autre chose
c'est que j'aime ça
et c'est pour ça que je fais toujours
des vidéos je parle
d'échecs j'aime parler d'échecs et voilà
la passion du genre il y en a plein qui
la perdent moi j'ai aucun problème avec
ça je comprends la curiosité naturelle
aussi de regarder les choses je pense
que c'était très curieux et ça c'est un
peu perdu d'ailleurs dans dans les
nouvelles générations quoi que les
meilleurs leçons
travaillé évidemment mais maintenant ils
ont tous les cours ils ont tous quatre
entraîneurs ils ont aucune culture oui
c'est un peu trop maintenant la
structuration qui est mis en place enfin
il faut pas oublier qu'il faut aussi
bosser en autonomie alors pas quand on a
8 ans c'est bien d'avoir de l'aide etc
le coach va servir de facilitateur mais
il est vrai qu'on doit faire beaucoup de
choses par nous-mêmes
il se prend une prépa il a dit ok son
n'a jamais joué ça de sa vie
c'est-à-dire qu'il avait vérifié quand
même le matin et là il a dit une phrase
magique il dit ok est-ce qu'il a joué je
ne connaissais pas à part la partie
casperroffakis
bon j'ai pas la raie je check casse pas
ça qui même ligne partie dans une très
très vieille partie
et là on parle de la mémoire c'est fou
les mecs
mais tu demandes à Prague de citer une
partie de kaspora il va te sortir contre
Topalov j'imagine mais une partie
obscure comme ça d'ailleurs elle est
jolie la partie je l'ai regardé il y a
aucune chance que par an un mec comme
dans les jeunes il y en a certains je
pense qu'il bosse encore bien
mais il y en a toi qui font que de la
théorie que de l'ordi il défendent c'est
qui ça qui c'est un joueur israélien
super fort
moi il a arrêté quand j'ai commencé donc
dans quoi c'était je crois que je l'ai
vu une fois dans un tournoi en Espagne
en 98
donc
tu as de la chance et imagine natif et
tu aimes le jeu et ils me disent c'est
le plus important et imaginatif et Mehdi
le truc c'est que ça se travaille pas
l'imagination quand t'as pas elle quand
tu es pas imaginatif tu vas pas
t'inventer
des pièces je faisais des sacrifices je
faisais des trucs jolis toi
mais c'est comme Marie beaucoup moins
qui a commencé à 13 ans et c'est pas les
mêmes échecs mais ouais c'est un talent
fantastique
finalement tous les joueurs qu'on voit
là sur le plateau du tada style
objectivement ils ont commencé très tôt
bon surtout qu'on allait tous les les
plus les plus grandes pépites au monde
dans ce tournoi à part Ali resa il en
manque quelques-uns mais globalement
c'est logique de commencer tôt pour
palper les pièces tout petit et évoluer
avec avec le jeu quoi et en grandissant
ben on va avoir des réflexes de dingue
après j'ai
travaillé enfin j'ai entraîné pendant
quatre ans mon Rudy et quand on me
posait des questions sur lui j'ai été
championneur moins de 10 ans je dis moi
j'ai mon premier tournant à 11 ans donc
j'en sais rien toi
ma guerre en fait
sur une partie je peux encore le battre
largement toi mais
déjà on blesse je pense que j'ai déjà
plus ma chance la dernière fois il m'a
battu
mais en partie longue je pense j'ai bien
sûr encore mon mot à dire mais ouais on
a pas les mêmes
j'ai l'occasion voilà tu vois j'ai joué
je sais pas la semaine dernière en blitz
et bosser un 3-0 c'est sur internet
c'est pas pareil qu'un vrai Blitz mais
je pense qu'il est vraiment plus fort en
langue en blitz il y a d'autres jeunes
qui m'impressionnent plus
qui sont moins fort que lui en vrai
partie et qui est le Blitz j'ai juste
sur lui un blice sur l'échiquier entre 3
+ 2 je me suis fait dominer
c'est encore marginal je sais pas il
faudra un échantillon de partie un peu
plus représentatif je pense je pense que
tu as encore la côte tu as encore la
côte sur TF1 il joue sur le téléphone
c'est déjà un problème parce qu'on est
moins performant il y en a qui arrivent
mais nous pas trop
[Musique]
ok donc là je pense que les il suit il
suit un mauvais fil Guiri il va se faire
retourner on peut peut-être aller voir
tout le monde abdos Saint-Orens c'était
hyper chaud
et ils ont trouvé la ligne
4 4
mais
ça a du sens non bien sûr
alors vas-y joue le coup on va essayer
de comprendre pourquoi il prend pas j'ai
le cavalier
du coup on s'est mis une structure
bizarre parti bizarre ah mais il y a le
5 en prison
qui contrôle beaucoup de cases mais qui
tape sur rien
pas évident
26 minutes qu'on neuf il reste 12 ça va
être très chaudes à une autre
partie des équilibrer les belles cette
partie quand même avec un vent de Forest
dans le même style
ce plan avec
toujours pas il aimerait bien le
retourner oui c'est vrai que ça avait
l'air en plus d'être petit plus sans
risque agréable à jouer bon
pour cette constater qu'il l'a pas joué
après il a joué tous les coups et vente
forest aussi c'est une grosse baston
grosse grosse baston on nous dit dans le
chat appeler de ses parties oui il a une
mémoire fantastique mais je crois que
Carlson c'est juste complètement dingue
guéri aussi karwana super mémoire mais
par contre
Carlson il y a plusieurs vidéos tu vois
les mecs essaient de le piéger c'est
quoi cette partie il ressort
H3 c'est assez logique activer la tour
intéressante mais il y a des trucs
drôles dans des vidéos de milliards une
position et j'ai retrouvé ce que c'était
toi les deux fois
ouais je suis pas étonné
il y a une mémoire de citation de partie
bon qui sert plus ou moins bah si tu te
rappelles du film évidemment mais il y a
aussi les nuances dans les ouvertures
Mathieu et du coup je remarque plutôt
mon point fort plus je commande plus les
mecs de très haut niveau comme 45 et
compagnie ici ils sont très forts en
théorie enfin ils arrivent à se rappeler
quand même c'est assez dingue
mvl il me semble avoir une excellente
mémoire et il avait une variété moins
importante dans son répertoire
il était un peu moqué ou en tout cas on
rapportait dans les interviews etc on
lui posait souvent cette question qui
m'énerver un petit peu comment toi tu
expliques ça qu'est-ce que tu en penses
si tu as envie de t'exprimer là-dessus
c'est pas une question piège je suis en
train de réfléchir la position fou des
trois
non non j'ai pas compris en fait comment
tu expliques que le répertoire de mvl
soit aussi réducteur pour un joueur de
son niveau alors qu'il semble avoir une
super mémoire alors que les autres
joueurs de haut niveau car scène et les
autres ils ont beaucoup de variétés en
règle générale un choix de lui et de sa
team non
j'ai pas trop la réponse à ta question
moi
par exemple si j'avais été dans sa team
j'aurais fait le forcing pour qu'il
change pour la première partie qu'on
était en or match retour des candidats
est-ce que tu as six mois pour bosser
une nouvelle ouverture
alors que tout le monde change c'est
quand même un peu bizarre quoi
jusqu'à il y a deux ans tu disais que ça
marchait très bien juste là il a une
mauvaise période ah oui d'accord oui tu
vois
il est passé numéro 2 mondial avec ce
postulat oui d'accord il était numéro de
mondial en jean super bien en faisant ça
après moi c'est pas du tout le mien je
pense que je vois dans la base
dans le sens en plus le défaut c'est que
du coup tu manques de culture dans
d'autres positions et maintenant changer
à son âge c'est plus dur là on va voir
on a vu qu'il commence à jouer des
commentaires
en plus mais de toute façon
les choix des autres joueurs de la
majorité des joueurs de très haut niveau
montrent quand même qu'il faut pouvoir
changer un minimum quoi un minimum il a
été mal conseillé parce que ça aussi un
choix à lui enfin c'est pas c'est facile
de enfin c'est pas la faute de ces
entrepreneurs et
très bon boulot enfin il a amené numéro
de mondial c'est quand même
oui bien sûr
mais
c'est vrai
et lui
non je pense au Triboulet de chasse que
Maxime il travaille les échecs sinon il
pourrait pas aussi bien connaître ses
lignes sur les sujets dont on a parlé
voilà non mais c'est un peu démotivé
aussi quand il a perdu les candidats ah
oui ça c'est autre chose
là il faut lui laisser une dernière
tournoi ça a été moyen mais il faut lui
laisser le
mais en plus qui s'est quitté c'est un
truc affectif tu quittes ton entraîneur
après longtemps ça paraît bizarre que tu
as des résultats directs
et les autres on aime bien on a une
bonne mémoire aussi mais on sait pas
c'est l'énigme
très bizarre d'ailleurs
bien sûr
qui ne joue pas mais en règle générale
tu parles indien
alors fout des trois est-ce qu'il veut
pas juste trois F7
donc maintenant on a stabilisé quand
même on ne perd pas de pion en Mathieu
on a l'air quand même d'avoir une
position de domination
ok
[Musique]
il
y a pas de risque
le temps enfermé durablement il y a le
problème sur E5
ok donne-moi un argument pourquoi les
blancs peuvent être mieux
les pièces le jeu de pièces lourdes
c'est moins vrai
j'imagine des rentrées même tout rêve de
mais je peux pas jouer Tour Eiffel quoi
je suis embêté avec ce qui est quand
même un des problèmes de la pause
c'est nul donc du coup parce que l'idée
des Noirs
tout à fait
il faudra regarder mais pour H4 ça a
l'air très intelligent pour laisser là
que mon j'ai pas de
j'aime pas trop échanger le cavalier qui
attaque 5 oui et en plus il y aura un
pion du coin F6 sera un peu pénible
après j'ai besoin d'un plan avec des
blancs effectivement
ça fait longtemps visuellement mieux
mais rien quoi c'est ça que tu dis alors
trois fois exactement
et sur
toi tu veux jouer F3
[Musique]
à échanger sur les cases blanches
même ça je pourrais peut-être avec
mesdames
bon il leur reste que deux coups à jouer
avant la fin designer je vais vous les
mettre d'ailleurs à l'écran ça sera
encore mieux
et voilà
du coup donc dame D1 je pense à fouger2
match je préfère je vais fouger d'eux et
garder garder mon fou pour aider les
pions toi tu voulais échanger
non je sais pas du tout ce que je
détesterais je sais plus avec les deux
couleurs
dame D1 mais tu as raison Damien ça a du
sens non
non je vais juste m'occuper de
je sais pas trop m'occuper du chat mais
je vais être obligé je crois
pourquoi on va pas la game là mais si on
voit une partie
on regarde la partie
je déteste et je veux cette position
avec les deux couleurs comment on fait
avec les Blancs est-ce qu'il peut il
peut pas vraiment sacrifier un F4 pour
l'instant ce que tu es Chloé
c'est peut-être pas complètement con
ah non il y a F3 non c'est con
[Musique]
pas déjà
c'est quoi son idée
ah faut prendre deux fous prends F7 d'en
prendre
c'est pardon pour les deux joueurs
c'est beau
next
alors la punition je pense que oui alors
on l'avait cité
qui est trop attaque la dame bouge
jusque là cohérent
donc c'est quoi les enjeux les non en
sacrifié la qualité pour un pion et qui
est en sacroît qui est bien protégé il y
a 5 qui a quand même très faible
à tout moment tu l'as cité le cavalier
justice peut revenir à F4 donc il faut
prendre pas le choix sinon tu paieras à
donc dame prend il veut pas laisser la
case des 5 c'est bien joué
c'est dur à jouer
la paire de fou très active
20 minutes pour vous prendre des 7
grosse partie de parent quand même
on peut surtout le cavalier 8 ah oui
c'est vrai que j'avais oublié celle-là
Mathieu à toi ça t'a plu théoriquement
parlant ça t'a plu tu le gardes pour tes
prépas
pour bien donc il attaque une pièce en
main
ça se fait un niveau là
alors qu'est-ce que tu fais
il est pas bien les vans
de quoi
bien sûr
[Musique]
jeux
3 fous des quatre sûrement et puis tu
mets dans ton foulard
et tu vas voir un peu plus
et il faisait 5 ouais
[Musique]
sinon tu repars loin et ton fou mais il
va revenir en serbe peut-être un truc
comme ça genre
F4 vous voyez les cases clignote il y a
du thème de partout il y a les thèmes là
et peut-être là aussi
tu nous dis Mathieu non non
on n'a pas l'évaluation mais pour moi ça
me paraît on l'avait tout à l'heure et
c'est la même position quasiment
toujours
il a refusé nul il a mis la pression
dans une partie c'est un battant quand
même c'est bien c'est une belle image
c'est jeune qui doit fond rien que c'est
bien joué par contre Wesley il va pas
lui laisser le gain ils vont sans doute
perdu là ça fait partie des des gens je
pense qu'il déjà c'est même pas sûr
qu'il va l'avoir et si là je pense pas
qu'il veut la gagner parce que Wesley
c'est du solide un peu trop au goût de
Mathieu voilà
mais il se fait moins tacler que
que notre ami est bonne
on y va directement et avec la bonne cam
sera encore mieux mais lui c'est on
était assez position il y a le tout
poussé
non Prague Prague c'est un joueur solide
un peu la caméra mais je joue longtemps
enfin c'était plus ça que tu décris il y
a eu j'ai problème cinq cavaliers H5
voilà il s'est passé des choses Mathieu
Roger 6 tours D6 Roger 5
de rapport tout ça alors en fait il a
raté je pense
fait F5 ok prise cavalier F4 malin pour
la case H5 dans le 5 et chaque et la
tour prend des 6 avec
on pouvait pas prendre en G4 attends
attends
on va se faire
c'est vraiment abondant à toi Mathieu
juste pour
en G4
on fait juste d'un prime 6 on reprend
yamat avec donc il échange et on prend
du cavalier comme ça on a une pièce de
plus ok donc tout reprend des 6 là roi
G5 mais ça doit être complètement foutu
cette position parce que le roi ça
n'existe pas aux échecs de faire ça
remplit de ça
et si c'est pas trompé de Casa avec le
roi
je peux prendre
une bonne blague
mais on n'y croit pas trop non ça marche
pas
ça
oui c'était sans doute mieux que roi
alors il y en a quelqu'un nous dit roi
j'ai 8 ouais mais c'est un peu la même
idée je suis juste tu vas pas
ouais c'est une grosse gaffe ah oui il a
oublié
de reprendre des six
ah il prend même pas F6
c'est lunaire là la partie
peut-être que ça va encore pas non non
mais juste pour prendre un fils on va
essayer de comprendre pas mourir compte
alors est-ce que c'est un coup sans
doute
il y a pas un petit
un petit h
avec des machins
parce que si roi prend un choc
[Musique]
je jouais d'un F2 ici
déjà vous voyez comme c'était chaud
H4 donc on a dit on reprend HK
machin qui gagne mais juste du coup tu
reprends ça m'a perturbé
[Musique]
tout rêve 5 et sur dame 1
c'était tendu en plus c'est même pas la
suite dans la partie ouais dis-moi
Mathieu tu voulais dire montrer quelque
chose c'est ça
a gagné peut-être
c'est toujours gagnant ou pas
il veut mettre son rond en H4 c'est ça
Mathieu bah il y a pas le choix de toute
façon
la blessure du roi
et
quasiment maths
que tu veux faire ouais
de toute façon
merde c'était bien tenté pour toi d'où
le direct
j'ai pas la ref
roidage
je me suis dit on va refaire kayak mais
c'est peut-être pas grave
on part
F5 il y en a un qui dit m'attendent
alors ça veut dire que c'est d'un
problème synchro H4 qui avait les bouge
donc d'un point F5 Rohff 4 ok c'est qui
bouge il y a dame G3 on va réfléchir
et là juste
cavalier cavalier cavalier qui a lui je
sais pas et j'ai 7 kg
je fais dames les deux comme tout à
l'heure mais cette fois j'ai pas donné
madame en un coup
j'ai trois pour jouer
c'est normal mais il y a fougé 5
alors
des deux
et là maintenant
5 donne des deux cavaliers
29,5 et de machin
c'est possible c'est possible et du coup
c'était quoi la gaffe c'était vraiment
ce roi H1 il y a marqué
grosse gaffe de Richard rapporte qui
relance tout le tournoi ou roi H8 les
deux élus nous on a dit roi achète donc
[Musique]
parce qu'il est pas bien dans la finale
ah ça on n'a pas vu alors oui ça
pourrait être ça pourrait être la fin
horrible pour abusa torov si venait à
toi j'allais te le dire il peut activer
le fou en a donc pour moi il y a que les
Noirs qui pouvaient être mieux
mais peut-être que c'est pas mieux mais
tourrage de fou des trois faudra le
vérifier
il y a plus de choses à surveiller 4-30
4 coups enfin 3 ça va aller mais il est
sous pression la tour fait pas bouger
elle est horrible là je trouve le
cavalier FC c'est Fati il est beau mais
il fait rien tu as raison Triboulet de
chasse
c'est pression ouais je suis d'accord
bon Guy il a maintenant 8 il faut qu'il
trouve
ça je suis pas trop inquiet pour lui
Magnus on n'a pas vu
et qu'est-ce que je veux dire
[Musique]
mais ça marche non c'est hyper chiant
ouais
en fait
de garder le fou fou G6 OK
il pouvait pas rendre le la pièce là ah
non tu as attaqué le cadre pardon
F5 bien sûr faut prendre un carte
ok c'est 3 et probable
celui-là peut-être Mathieu mais soit je
lâche c'est 7
j'en ai besoin quand même
je pense plutôt celui-là
pour garder le cavalier aux deux mais
ta dame peut venir maintenant aussi ce
serait vraiment pénible
il a quoi 3 il a passé 40e ok donc ça
peut durer
on nous le confirme voilà
c'est quoi la position finale du coup
voilà vous allez le voir à l'écran
on dirait ça gagne position finale hop
je vous la mets donc on s'est arrêté là
à peu près tout D5 on avait vu dame 1
roager de fou E7 c'est la constitue F5
Road H4 et Mathieu très rigolo on en
avait pas parlé dans
tu peux montrer triste
[Musique]
donc on peut juste décaler la tour pour
faire mat ici Mathieu par exemple
était possible
ultra c'est que la finale est
complètement perdante
je peux me faire un blocus de la case
j'ai 5
pas bête parce que ça va être cavalier 5
imparable donc vous voyez on fait une
sorte de de faux mate mais de vrais
gains voilà parce que il peut donner sa
tour mais c'est foutu quoi
donc il nous reste quoi bah je peux
attends je pense que le mieux c'est
d'aller voir de cette Europe parce
qu'ils sont encore en zinote exactement
un petit tour vers parram
vous avez vu à l'écran la déception
et maintenant le
pour empêcher le cavalier F4
c'est deux
en G3 donc il donne un je crois ils sont
fous
il a des idées à base de F4 prise d'un
point H3 ou d'un
très très dur la position blanche
faudrait pouvoir croquer le pion C2
sinon on va mourir et en plus il y a pas
trop à trois ne sert à rien tout
renfermé et sur quel prend C2 c'est
dames C8
on est en train de sombrer à petit feu
on va voir une victoire parrain Mathieu
qui est complètement gagnant ici il m'a
l'air gagnant après peut-être c'est le
moment de ramener ce fou
il va venir en solidifie le pion ces
deux on ramène le fou par là et on va
gagner tout de suite à toi tu voudrais
faire dames
que ça va être un peu
envie de jouer simple et de contrôler il
y a peut-être encore mieux
mais bon
on peut peut-être aller voir
au fou bouge car il y a une fuite qui a
eu 6
n'est pas encore tout à fait fini il
reste trois couches chacun à jouer et
prendre position qui avait l'air de
faire mal
très pénible et il n'est pas impossible
car d'où ça te rend perte cette partie
et que Jordan van forest arbitre
cette femme pour moi ils ne sont pas et
serait content aussi pour lui de gagner
ça lui ferait du bien il mérite un
Jordan parce qu'il est complètement
revenu il est 13e actuellement avec une
grosse partie hier il a failli failli la
coller à guéri
arnaqueur du circuit c'est incroyable
comme c'est vrai
Abdou je pense pas qu'il va gagner quand
même puisque tout à l'heure on pouvait
partir au candidat enfin
une arnaque incroyable
de gagner les gens directs
tu perds un pion mais on va essayer de
rester en vie après mais Jordan est en
train de de faire mal ou alors c'est
trois pour essayer
on va voir on va voir si
je pense qu'il trouve qu'elle ait eu ça
je peux aller voir l'évaluation si tu
veux ouais avec plaisir je peux
peut-être même la mettre KD-8 1,70 sur
Chacom j'ai 99
c'est des profondeurs pourris mais
voilà 2020 nous confirme
130 il faut encore jouer un 30 en finale
c'est-à-dire plus d'un pion pas mal
quand même
forest la forêt traduction littérale à
la française
je connaissais pas
bon après il y a du sens c'est écrit
dans mais c'est pour ça que je me suis
dit c'est plutôt pas mal
plutôt pas mal et donc là ça joue pas 10
minutes ça va s'accélérer est-ce que
Magnus il y a un coup non et le contrôle
a été passé ouais donc du coup la partie
nous intéresse c'est vraiment celle-là
[Musique]
et parâmes par an c'est plus de 50
+ 5 ça disait ce qu'on disait d'ailleurs
ok
je serais content qu'il y ait j'ai tenté
de trouver une cam
à demain
je vais tenté de trouver la cam que j'ai
jamais trouvé depuis le début
elles sont là c'est incroyable quoi
toujours
mais du bois c'est déjà pris en France
c'est pas mal aussi ça rivalise d'un
jeuneosité dans le chat
de la forêt plutôt
et ça dégage notre tronche OK
c'est énorme
ok on va voir si je vais être bon
aussi Abdou gagne il est tout seul si il
perd ses guéri s'il y a nul il y a des
partages
mais la sœur je l'ai vu je crois qu'elle
s'en fout complètement le petit frère
est bien taré j'ai perdu contre le jour
dans un rapide d'ailleurs
le plus fort quand même
j'ai leur cam mais je la camoufat ça y
est je l'ai trouvé mat et tu vas
comprendre pourquoi
moi
incroyable
c'est pour ça que je trouvais pas depuis
tout à l'heure regarde franchement
franchement je vais vendre forest donc
j'étais content tu vois et là je pense
que c'est abusa torov je comprends pas
que ça fasse ça sérieux quoi il est
souvent classe en plus
sa chemise est bien repassée Mathieu
mais
alors voilà on met pas au niveau
technique
il y a un bruit de fond ah ouais ça
c'est ça c'était moi pour le coup voilà
et je voulais enlever le bruit de fond
parce que j'ai changé la cam et du coup
il peut y avoir un petit bruit de fond
voilà
vous êtes vous êtes bien là vous êtes
bien on a Abdou sa torov à l'écran il
faut juste imaginer son visage vous avez
les mains les mains de ce grand champion
la fille elle joue bien mais juste moi
je l'ai vu en tournoi elle s'en fout des
échecs oui c'est ça ce que dit Mathieu
c'est que sur le long terme
elle est très douée mais
après je pense il joue de 3 H2 il sera
bien quand même 3
cahier des quatre oui mais franchement
c'est bizarre qu'il est pris en fait
c'est bizarre en fait il a envie
d'enfoncer
elle est d'ailleurs c'est Jordan sur la
caméra tu as raison en chemise blanche
c'est Jordan en fait je pensais que
c'était ça
quand je vous ai mis la cam je voyais je
voyais Jordan mais je voyais le son
visage et donc je me suis dit que
l'autre caméra qui était planté sur
l'échiquier
je vais aller voir ça
je repars dans mes dans mes idées je
vais essayer de voir un truc
ok c'est super bizarre je sais pas
pourquoi ça fait ça ok il tremble pas
toi moi j'aurais ma main qui tremble à
ce moment-là c'est un peu le problème
d'ailleurs
ok
comment il bouge ses mains il a l'air
focus
est-ce qu'on va le voir jouer à la cam
ah oui on a vu un cavalière partir tu as
vu
je suis en train de te faire un truc
Matthieu aux petits oignons
c'était bizarre cette cam je sais la
seule que j'avais pas
pour qui non je suis pour personne je
suis pour le beau jeu moi j'ai moi
j'engueule ce qu'ils font rien qui sont
chiants à voir donc à rognan s'il a
perdu le joueur ben je serai content
parce que pour moi il ajoute trop vite
il a pas respecté le jeu il a été
content de faire ses nul tout le tournoi
j'ai pas du tout aimé son comportement
autant d'inka wanna ils ont fini le
rapide mais c'est la première nul de
rapide du tournoi et je peux le
comprendre ça peut arriver
tu as vu Mathieu ce que je t'ai fait
honnêtement je pense que c'était bien de
ma faute l'histoire de pas voir les
caméras 5 6 7 8 machin parce que si je
les avais toutes copiés
j'avais un petit retardage à faire sans
doute et sauf que je le voyais pas voilà
comme ça vous savez tout vous savez tout
on le dira pas à souffre surtout hein ne
me balancez pas auprès de souffle pour
cette performance au niveau de la cam
j'ai quasiment tout réussi mais il y
avait ce petit ce petit bémol ce petit
bémol mais comme ça vous avez pu voir
les mains de vinforest voilà
abdos est toujours assez stressé quand
tu joues merde pas de bol quoi juste
quand je dis ça
quand tu dis son nom
[Rires]
tu peux ne pas le voir mais quand tu le
vois il saute tellement aux yeux
c'est le FC il fait la même chose quand
c'est 6 sauf qu'il attaque j'ai 5 ans en
plus c'est juste
un fruit et puis dur à jouer maintenant
pour là il faut il faut que ça t'aura il
est de la chance parce que cette
position qui est il y a un peu de
travail encore pour la gagner il faut
qu'il ait réussite dans ce qui va jouer
il va tenter le tout pour le tout et
c'est pas encore c'est pas encore foutu
foutu
et en plus c'est pas nous chercher c'est
ça qui est bien oui parce que là il va
essayer de jouer le meilleur coup il a
plusieurs choix pour jouer dynamique
j'ai pas je sais pas quoi en fait
une tour en C8 après ça va te retourner
contre toi
donc du coup je voulais faire un tour
trois pour faire ces trois il y a
toujours tout rage de si on veut guéri a
gagné pour répondre à la question du
chat de guéri et pour l'instant ça dans
ta tête
c'est plus sympa mais je peux peut-être
vous mettre ça en attendant
on voit pas les scores à jour comment ça
se fait ah si vous voyez je vous ai mis
un petit un petit plaisir vous allez
voir ça à l'écran directement
les petits scores du jour et ça arrive
dans quelques secondes
attendez la fin tu en as franchement ça
a été un bon deux semaines moi je suis
tombé sur la pierre rouge je crois
l'autre jour
c'est une intéressante une fois à fouet
de jouer
OK
assez logique
mais
prise prise
cavalier F7 bon comme ça je vous ai mis
les scores ça met un petit peu de temps
arrivé c'est la magie du peuple
en fait je me suis un peu emmêlés
crayons max voilà on voit que la
technique fatigue la technique fatigue
mais après les notes on partira en pause
du coup et mauvais coup de fou ou deux
apparemment j'ai remis la cam là des
joueurs on va mentir une petite pause ça
me dérangerait pas s'il y a ma mère qui
vient d'arriver chez moi je comprends je
comprends maths
on attend la fin ou alors tu pouvais y
aller puis je finissais puis de toute
façon je m'étais en pause c'était
vraiment pas de souci ce dimanche matin
c'est dimanche tu as le droit
cavalier F7 ça a l'air hyper hyper
pénible mais c'était le seul moyen pour
lui peut-être de jouer C3 alors Mathieu
est-ce que je te ferais pas non je te
ferai pas je voulais faire tout rage 3
pour fixer mais il y aura cahier G8 tu
vas m'embêter je te vois arriver donc
cavalier 7 j'assume
et cavaliers 7 qu'est-ce que je menace
en fait qu'à étranger 5
x 2 ça laisse 5 et les cinq faibles à
vie alors en quoi ne pas jouer folie ça
changeait ça bah ouais c'est dur hein
parce qu'on a bah oui je pense qu'il a
vu à la jauge que c'était pas apprécié
mais mais c'est dur de jouer la position
chat sur les joueurs comme Abdou Sa
Torah il trouve tous les coups mais
quand j'ai une position désespérée ben
il joue pas les bons coups pas les coups
de l'ordi après
je vais revenir en F7 et quand tu feras
ton projet 6 et qui est français qui
viennent tu pourras même pas me bouffer
G6 donc c'est vrai que ça a pas l'air de
marcher hyper bien concrètement
je vais aller voir s'il y a eu des trucs
importants à côté
leur dit Dick et C6 encore plus fort
ah pour juste faire tout rachats le
mépris ok
max glou
il y a eu des coups
on peut aller voir vite fait en
attendant le coup de vent de Forest plus
en finale là tu as rendu la pièce en C2
on l'avait mentionné l'idée
en sauce ça joue toujours
Magnus a pas bougé ok ok
de rendre le matériel donc là c'est
juste pion de plus
ok oui
un peu faible le pion A5 un peu faible
le foot peut aller en C3 dans le C7 bon
ça va être pénible quoi 6 encore mais
c'est très très
probable que les von a rognan va
s'incliner dans dans un moment dans un
moment mais la partie peut durer par
contre il a l'autre appel la technique
il a plus légendaire là il y a pas eu de
coups depuis que j'ai 5 le contrôle de
temps est pas toujours chaud
tu sais qu'il y a un truc intéressant
ici c'est qui est prêt F4 mais on va
devoir faire ça à Mathieu parce que
sinon ça risque d'être alors qu'est-ce
que tu as vu après
c'est bien vu mais c'est dur à trouver
franchement et c'est sûr ça c'est
super
contenter la case D4 mais j'ai vu la
jauge et bah c'est moins bien
non OK
ouais c'est pas facile quand même faut
être en forme ce jour-là ok il y a eu un
coup alors on retourne
donc ces trois prises et la 48e
tu vas faire échec là
bah ouais parce que tu pourras des
quatre je prends des quatre
voilà et tout
du coup et bah on a une position où les
pions vont tomber et il faut juste
éviter tout cavaler contre tour faut pas
se faire avoir
bon ah ça vient d'être gagnant
techniquement mais ok tout le monde a
passé le contrôle il a déconné Abdou et
Abdou il a dominé tout le tournoi et
Jordan ne fait une sacrée partie quand
même parce que Mathieu un moment à la
place de Jordan on aurait pris nul lui
il joue aux échecs tout à fait normal
et avec de la ouais c'était quand même
une grande créativité parce qu'il
pouvait avoir peur
donc à étranger 5 et on garde tout H3 en
plus à n'importe quel moment
G5 on menace ça et ça pour taper le
Pione 5 donc ça peut être il a joué quoi
contrôle le temps est passé on fait une
mini pause on fait une mini pause on se
retrouve à 16h20 Mathieu est-ce que
c'est bien pour tout le monde ça te va
ça marche à tout de suite à tout de
suite
et à tout de suite à tous je vous laisse
avec une magnifique coupure je vous ai
mis la vidéo tout à l'heure je vous
laisse avec le mixcam allez à tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes repartis tout de suite après
cette petite pause et on voit que ça te
rend
à jouer étant grande réflexion et je
pense qu'il est un petit peu un petit
peu débité
c'est quoi son idée de t'auras
niveau Rebais deux prises pour ces deux
je veux créer un pion passé et mais bon
ça a l'air
il essaie d'embrouiller la position tu
peux montrer genre 3 allez courage 3 on
dégage le roi pour prendre l'option B4
le problème pour faire roisser 5 c'est
que tu me mettras encore échec Mathieu
et tu prendras en B4 et j'aurais plus de
contre jeu c'est mon idée donc roi B2 je
pensais AB et du coup en plus il y a des
tours à trois qui peuvent arriver pour
aller chercher le pion donc là tour ces
deux là je pensais F3 moi
il veut rentrer en septième vous voyez
pour essayer d'arnaquer
un KF3 me paraît bien
pour des 7 3D 8
pour 17
[Musique]
h
et finita la comédien ok
on va d'abord par rame parce qu'après il
ne restera qu'une partie ça sera
irrigaty Carsen parce que il y a eu du
manger tu me disais ça là en arrivant
Mathieu pour la grosse grosse
il a les jeux fou c'est ça donc là il
ajoute toujours bien il a donné le
deuxième pion
il a été pris d'ailleurs le deuxième
pion donc tour des 6 très bien joué
trois tours
la partie n'a plus aucun intérêt
tiens Praxo
Praxo ça fait nul voilà position on va
vous montrer la position finale
côté
Wesley Sow on a pris le pion et ils ont
fait ils ont beau copain
ok maintenant on va chez magalius
donc là on avait dit que nous on aura
jockey ces trois puis je t'avais dit
j'ai vu l'aide le coût de l'ordi j'ai
halluciné c'était qui épreuve 4 ou 2
c'est trop dur à trouver
ça m'a paru hyper long bon en même temps
là ça vaut le coup de réfléchir ils ont
récupéré leur temps les joueurs
c'est pas écrit on peut les comprendre
c'est pas écrit moi j'ai pas le temps de
combien de coups
[Musique]
donc il est revenu
donc Mathieu on pensait avoir des matchs
de départage à la faveur de la victoire
d'anis Jerry en se disait tout à l'heure
petit nul ça t'aura et on est en match
de départage ce qui était pas improbable
et il est possible que guéri gagne son
premier tata style seul en tête sans
match de départage on va le voir des
partages pour la deuxième place
normalement non à ma connaissance non
parce que il peut y avoir Abdou
carrassen avec
dans mon esprit il y en a pas dans mon
esprit il y en a pas je peux vérifier je
peux vérifier toujours pareil terrible
Mathieu ce que tu viens de me faire je
crois que j'ai l'article ouvert yes
je suis obligé de lire un petit peu
quand même
à la première place
donc il a joué F3 ici pour clouer
et d'un médecin visiblement était pas
précis d'après ce qu'on a vu
dans mes fins non précis sur foie F3
c'est ce qu'on voulait depuis un moment
on en avait parlé et Magnus a enfin
réussi son pari amener la dame pour
finir le joueur
ici il avait un coup qui gagnait d'après
l'ordi à plus trois damage 4
et ramener la dame faisait sens Mathieu
après on voit pas la menace
si peut-être
non mais en fait il a chaque fois assez
vite l'anatomique c'est une grosse faute
mais
quand il fait des fois de Magnus qui est
bien c'est qu'il reste mieux là il peut
pas s'aborder son avantage
c'est matériel égal sauf que le plongé
est beaucoup plus fort que le pion
mesdam H4 ça permettait de ramener la
dame en jeu en fait salut Joa salut à
tous ceux qui nous rejoignent pour se
dénouement du tata style avec un
craquage de Richard rapporte contre
Aniche Guiri qui lui a offert à Aniche
la victoire il est donc seul en tête il
était sous pression mais oui
Mathieu et du coup attention
grande difficulté contre Jordan van
forest on peut déjà vous dire qu'il ne
gagnera pas on va on peut déjà vous dire
qu'il est sans doute enfin il est
perdant il va sans doute perdre et à
niche en volerait
ça serait beau pour un niche
ouais triste pour ado parce qu'il fait
un super pour moi
s
il aurait pu perdre et aujourd'hui
là tu as fait après il avait mis la
pression toute la partie aujourd'hui
ce que je peux jouer un peu je serais
tenté pour que je foue 5
j'y ai pas pensé ce qui est bizarre
parce que c'était opposé au coup d'avant
bah oui tu vois je recycle les bonnes
idées
en plus ça a l'air hyper logique quoi de
ramener la dame ce qu'on voulait faire
depuis le départ je sais pas ce que je
ne vois pas
parce que ça m'a indiqué que ça allait
gagner quand même
non mais tu me laisses peut-être rien de
spécial donc je voulais jouer le très
original G3
non mais peut-être qu'il y a un contre
jeu via la casser 7 genre C5
ce que je me disais Mathieu si tu veux
c'est que je me disais j'ai trois G2
dans ma chambre ça vient très très vite
quoi
en plus même ça c'est pas sûr
c'est horrible pour pour les pour les
blancs je comprends maintenant pourquoi
Magnus n'a pas trouvé et à jouer FF6 ça
a l'air quand même très pénible
il a préféré mettre le fou pour éviter
je sais pas 5 quelque chose comme ça bon
non mais d'accord ok il aurait dû le
jouer avant c'est sûr
oui c'était le scénario le plus
improbable effectivement avec les pièces
en danger aujourd'hui oui enfin il parle
de la combo des deux victoires noires
franchement en terme de pronos même si
ergy on savait qu'il pouvait perdre
contre manus parce qu'il envoie tout et
les battants et tout ça et Magnus est
tellement fort que dans une partie qui
joue il peut gagner maintenant
c'est le meilleur coup on voyait quand
même pas la victoire de Forest
oui bah c'est logique que dame c'est un
DA mask on voulait ramener la dame
depuis le début il a quand même tourné
Magnus il a ramené sa dame donc il va le
jouer je pense est-ce que ça bouche aux
va gagner le tournoi B oui donc on peut
ouais on savait qu'il avait qualifié
l'autre vient de faire une gaffe donc
c'est bien de voir ce joueur
[Musique]
financeur très travailleur dans les
ouvertures
ça m'avait énervé de pas gagner
une vraie partie quand même parce qu'à
mon il peut faire nul avec les noirs et
on pensait avec Mathieu que ça allait
plutôt tourner là dessus et il a été
très ambitieux dans le jeu pour aller
chercher à Boussa torov qui a pas fait
n'importe quoi apparemment il a trouvé
les seuls coups mais il a fait quand
même craquer il a fait craquer
non plus à la fin de la partie je sais
pas mais comme il perd il y avait comme
un coup qui paraissait lui procurer un
avantage on a peut-être raté quelque
chose mais ça avait l'air quand même
assez séduisant
où on va il nous reste trois parties
donc mag zoolo on ira moins voir sa
partie là deux pions de plus contre à
rognan c'est le maintenant une question
de technique de jouer vite non
ils ont joué un coup chacun
à regarder et puis c'est pas qu'on s'en
fiche mais déjà Matthieu bah il nous a
dit qu'il était en colère après les vols
et en plus bah il joue plus plus rien
quoi tu es content qu'il perdent voilà
donc allez voir Abdou il y a bien eu B4
tour H3 comme tu le voulais
à une sortie
voilà c'est une sortie de piste
non t'inquiète pas on a bien compris
quelle chère se vendent forest pas de
souci ça passe ça passe très bien
de quoi c'est une blague j'ai pas
compris
le fait qu'il battable d'où quoi dans
c'est dans ce sens-là parce que Abdou
avait fait un thé un tel tournoi et
est-ce que ça va faire mal au moral au
tan oui ça va l'embêter un petit peu
mais il montre des prédispositions pour
s'inscrire durablement
dans la super élite donc c'est dommage
qu'il ne gagne pas le tournoi alors on
va voir faut qu'il soit confirmé il a il
a un des meilleurs entraîneurs du monde
et lui c'est pas le moins bon non plus
ça va faire il va encore faire parler de
lui
oui donc là après
salut les cannes
on a trouvé donc
je pense qu'il va le voir
de carwana quand même
numéro 2 mondial on a parlé avec Laurent
Laurent qui est secondant de Magnus et
dans le milieu il nous disait que
quasiment était très très respecté en
tant qu'aux joueurs évidemment
tu dis pardon avec Nielsen exactement
Nielsen le bourreau de de Laurent au
basket voilà Poulidor va gagner
Néandertal tout à fait Poulidor et bien
effectivement il va finir 3e je pense il
avait gagné là pas trop regardé mais
en tout cas au classement
bah on a guéri à 8h30 à d'où ça te rave
qui pourrait rester à huit
et Magnus cette nuit
plus suite tendance suite tendance suite
bravo à Magnus quand même d'être revenu
d'aussi loin avec ces deux défaites
alors que tout le monde disait problème
de démotivation etc etc en fait il a
juste remis les pendules à l'heure c'est
vrai qu'il part de hyper deux parties
d'années donc là en perte 2 sur un même
tournoi mais c'est les échecs
[Musique]
alors Magnus on va aller voir du coup
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
dans en plus dans le monde moderne c'est
presque encore plus dur d'être constante
vu la concurrence qu'il y a peut-être
Mathieu qui est peut-être plus forte
qu'avant il y a une densité en tout cas
d'un joueur à plus de 2700 un peu plus
importantes alors est-ce que les 2700
d'aujourd'hui valent les 2700 d'hier ça
c'est encore un gros débat maintenant
mais est-ce qu'ils comprennent mieux les
échecs donc c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça
ce qui est quand même important
est-ce que c'était le meilleur coup tes
rois
C25 on joue quoi parce qu'on a amené
notre fond FC c'est pas pour faire
des 8 là il y a un super tu veux
chercher un super coup ouais je
cherchais je cherchais mais je vais
peut-être pas le trouver Matt je vais
essayer de le chercher vite fait
la finale
moi je ferais ça après tu as peut-être
des c'est cette faible si le roi revient
c'est 7 à protéger on dit qu'il y a un
super coup en plus j'espère que tu vas
pas enfumé avec un petit peu
non non les joueurs maintenant
comprennent beaucoup moins bien les
échecs qu'avant parce qu'en fait ils en
ont pas besoin parce qu'ils font que
calculer ça calcule beaucoup mieux et ça
défend beaucoup mieux en fait c'est
comme j'adore c'est comme dans tout
sport ben non mais en fait on apprend de
on apprend les gens d'avant eux ils ont
pas nos références
donc c'est normal que ça progresse aux
échecs dans d'autres sports est-ce qu'il
y a des différences oui par exemple le
foot si vous regardez les vieux matchs
il y avait des mecs c'était les génies
les ces génies là seraient toujours dans
les meilleurs du monde maintenant parce
qu'ils auraient utiliser les modes
d'entraînement de maintenant mais parce
que maintenant tu es beaucoup plus
on fait beaucoup plus de fonciers enfin
ils courent beaucoup plus les joueurs
sur un terrain
et donc du coup ça c'est juste on a
profité de la technologie de l'avancée
des trucs
tu vois ce que je veux dire moi j'ai
enfin une idée maths
je me suis dit sur damso2 3 tu sais
il peut pas prendre un 4 bah en fait je
voulais faire x 2 mais ça doit gagner
aussi fou de je te le dis à maths pas du
tout sûr pas du tout sûr
oui donc du coup elle a compréhension
des échecs pour moi il y a pas photo
après ils sont beaucoup plus pratique en
plus se sont réduites c'est pas
exactement le même jeu
non mais c'est un truc je sais pas si
toi tu as remarqué qu'on avait pas
forcément un autre époque c'est comme
l'information arrive plus vite c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup de parties sur
internet des mecs genre honnêtement je
sais pas un profil 2000 2002 on
n'annonce pas très bon ont battu déjà
pas mal de grands mètres sur Internet du
coup ils ont beaucoup moins peur nous
quand on était également
et on avait ce côté respect c'est vrai
c'est vrai maintenant ça n'existe pas
non on peut vraiment on peut vraiment
progresser beaucoup plus sur internet
avec les nouvelles technologies ont
gagné énormément de temps nous on a
commencé mais tard qu'on avait
je sais pas 10 16 à 18 ans en maths on a
commencé à voir les ordis les machins
enfin vraiment plus performants les
bases de données mais pas beaucoup pas
beaucoup avant
l'ordi a tué la magie non c'est
différent genre l'analyse maintenant tu
rentres dans ta chambre d'hôtel quand tu
es en tournoi avant tu passais déjà mais
moi maintenant j'essaye de d'analyser
avec mon adversaire si je peux tu le
fais plus qu'avant on a vu Magnus le
faire pas mal dans le tournoi et être
vraiment plus zen
à l'ancienne
du coup on va retourner voir abdos
il va trouver
le contre jeu
donc là moi j'avais dit cavalier F3 je
désolé mais je garde mon cou ah bah
c'est très bien c'est très bien qu'elle
froide en fait tu montres quelque chose
d'intéressant à Mathieu ici il faut pas
défendre passivement il faut continuer
on doit de méfiant mais pas peureux aux
échecs et Mathieu il a vu tout ses sept
il a regardé les implications du truc
c'est pas grave c'est une tour en 7e le
revendait 8 et à des cases par contre
faut bien calculer évidemment parce que
on peut perdre une position complètement
gagnante en jouant sur le fil il fait
genre kg 4 jusqu'à iD4 oui oui là
justement c'est la contre-attaque
Mathieu et vise B3 il vit ça et ça etc
etc
pas le seul coup bien sûr
donc il va gagner la 39 minutes en plus
il a du temps pour bien calculer
un rognon un rognon sans fiches un peu
on vous laisse pour l'instant la caméra
très passive donc je m'organise un petit
peu et je pousse mes pions
voilà
c'est l'arnaquer et se prendre un café
ok dames C5 ça attaque le cheval donc
c'est quand même une bonne idée
tu dis
B5 j'aime bien ton homme C5 ça regarde
un œil sur le cavalier menace dame C7 et
après on irait faire ton
ton petit dessin
ok on va pas regarder ça il y a deux
pions de plus on va aller vers qu'est-ce
que tu veux voir peut-être à égaliser
Carlson
bah là les trois ça on peut attendre
longtemps les trois en 50 minutes 30
minutes et 30 minutes ouais mais je
pense qu'ils vont jouer relativement
vite relativement c'est à dire que ils
vont pas user de tout leur temps et du
coup trois victoires en noir et une
victoire blanche
Parame il est beaucoup trop bien ouais
ça c'est une référence à vos vidéos
je pense que demain on va analyser
l'iris si gain de tournoi
qui a quand même la côte c'est logique
quoi
j'ai la petite qui pleure si tu as
besoin de t'absenter un instant à main
tu fais comme à la maison tu es chez toi
tu es chez toi tu es chez toi Mathieu
tu vois tu laisses et ouais en route
salut à toi bah oui
guéri va gagner vraisemblablement sauf
catastrophe
devant de Forest dans cette finale où il
est complètement gagnant on voit
d'ailleurs que Abdou il a la mine des
mauvais jours ça se ça se sent c'est pas
poker face
avec les Blancs il est en feu
il brise la malédiction ouais on pourra
plus l'appeler Poulidor un Poulidor
c'était l'éternel second au vélo pour
ceux qui n'ont pas la ref
et du coup dans ce tournoi cinq fois
deuxième guéri et là ça va lui faire du
bien
3e ouais c'est ça drive il va finir
il a joué F3
et oui trouve les cours bien sûr
a refusé nul il a pas chose sur la 4 à
mon avis il va tellement faire des
cauchemars sur la carte on remonte
peut-être d'ailleurs ce moment-là il a
joué il a fini par jouer à 4 mais pas
dans le mont timing hein
quand il fait 4 on revient avant alors
c'était bien avant 19e
[Rires]
attaques la tour par tour
bien ça fait nul parce qu'en fait
il va jouer tour D8 tour D1 et là il va
jouer H4 qui est vraiment alors là déjà
il peut jouer A4 avec les mains on
comprend pas il va inclure tout HD1
c'était l'idée de tour des cartes de
défendre mais peut-être Mathieu qui a eu
un petit truc psycho il s'est dit je
vais faire nul cette partie peut-être
c'est ça mais bon Atlant
c'est tellement logique pour faire nul
même pour faire nul je fais un 4 et
d'ailleurs j'ai pas faire du jeu pour
gagner
surtout à ce niveau là
il a calculé un truc joli on peut le
montrer c'est la partie et G4 qui est
ici
mais il est noir ils sont mieux et là il
a trouvé E5 des 5 cavaliers 4 il avait
prévu ça mais pas de chance pour lui
c'est pas si fort
on leur dit trouve peut-être une défense
mais ouais ça fait pas plaisir ça fait
très peur
en bref il y a eu très malin visiblement
il a joué une erreur qui est peut-être
les rats décisive en fait
je sais pas s'il y a une occasion tu
sais
malus a pas trouvé dommage
il est pas pressé en cette fin attends
il aurait quand même pu revenir
peut-être c'est ce fou j'ai quatre tu
sais Mathieu qu'il a perdu en fait si je
reprends
les événements tu sais tu parlais
d'ailleurs de fou des trois dans cette
position qui était sans doute plus
indiquée d'ailleurs
ouais pour moi c'était plus logique pour
taper la faiblesse qui est pas protégée
là il a tapé la faiblesse
il a perdu le fil de la position
et ça c'est un peu gâté cette position
il a très bien joué
très bien joué faut deux c'est pas
terrible mais bon c'est hyper logique
dans le jeu maintenant il a été très
fort aujourd'hui vente forest même s'il
y a eu un gros A4 de rater et là on en
est là KF3 kg 4 on en est parlé Mathieu
Kai D4 tour G3 et peut-être la fin
on va aller voir Magnus
il a pas joué il a fait ABAB dans ma vie
alors qui était notre idée dans ma 3 et
jouer la finale
je vais vous mettre ma news
voilà
il s'est dit la finale en fait les deux
se sont partis du postulat que la finale
était gagnante facile
parce que nous on pensait à damma 3 e 5
jouets directement Mathieu
j'ai vérifié ça marche pas
[Musique]
je sais juste si ça marche pas je sais
pas pourquoi toi
donc son idée c'est puis on prend un 5
et prend à douche d'accord avec toi
Binky et oui
du coup ici je pense
[Musique]
un peu de fatigue chez les joueurs alors
attention
ça c'est un match pour du beurre même si
le champion du monde il a envie de finir
sur une très bonne note et il a quand
même
il passerait devant saut et même les
points
il doit il doit quand même donc on gagne
il fait 8
il fallait qu'il fasse quoi 9 et demi 9
c'est ça il est à moins donc là il
reprendrait il est combien sur
l'adversaire 27 22 il prend 3,1
il en a besoin
de ces trois
il a dit qu'il avait plus vraiment 2009
comme objectif tu vois il a plus trop
d'objectif
[Musique]
28 50
qui vient d'arrêter enfin qu'il a laissé
le titre vacant le titre mondial vacant
en l'an donc c'est dans une période un
peu plus difficile en terme de
motivation mais on a vu quand même qu'il
adorait les échecs dans ce tournoi en
analysant accès ses adversaires il a
pris pas mal de plaisir je pense tu dis
un niche il prend ça ce point
c'est plus standard de Aniche là il
était pas gras on va dire par rapport à
ces standard 27 80 je pense c'est normal
enfin bon prêt ou plus 26 il tape 20
mondial ça c'est beau et ça fait plaisir
pour lui
[Musique]
ah il a pas pris du fond non il a pris
du pion mais c'est vraiment un temps il
garde il garde bien la presse sur la
position fous des deux et deux pions qui
filent il est quand même
vraiment très très bien
d'accord et deux pions passés E4 il veut
que je fous ces trois ça serait
peut-être une erreur et alors
j'ai je vais vous remettre à bout ventes
forest quand même on va suivre et ça se
joue assez vite quand même on est à
cavalier G4 il a pas encore joué cahier
des quatre si à l'instant
voilà
plus simple on voit que c'est jouer un
les coups annoncé ce produit et on y est
il y a juste vraiment pas d'idée
complètement
c'est énorme nous on l'a gagné je viens
d'arriver mais si Abdouf est nul il se
passe quoi de gagnants pas de gagnants
ce serait match de partage belle Maja
malheureusement
Abdou en fait il est en grande grande
difficulté il est quasiment foutu
mais il a deux pions de moins
deux pions isolés
[Musique]
ça commence à être très chaud les pièces
devant une forêt sont actives on annonce
perdant on annonce perdant
complètement complètement
oui
ok en fait il y a trois parties pas très
intéressantes la plus importante c'est
Magnus en fait celle-là
l'exécution par âme j'ai pas regardé on
va surveiller quand même
tour C8 jouer à un tour C8 c'est marrant
tiens
tours
pour B3 déjà
pour faire tourner
du coup tu vas me donner le pion à
peut-être mais bon comment ça va faire
beaucoup quoi
le mode anti-jeux et enclenché
on veut gagner sans effort surtout ici
ça change qui sera pas premier salut
Gaïa
petit cours de prononciation de Persan
le GH de Max doudou c'est juste un R
ok en français et il est où c'est des
ouf donc c'est makrout
ah non mars
ok ça se prononce donc mars
qui dit McDo slow à la Norvégienne
jusque là tu vois et merci hier KS c'est
cool
j'ai entraîné pendant cinq ans la
meilleure chose iranienne mais vous en
avez peut-être entendu parler c'est elle
qui est parti vivre en Espagne
dis-nous comment ça s'appelle Mathieu
merci
[Rires]
un point sur les parties finies allez je
vais mettre le score board
tu le fais comme demain ou tu le fais
maintenant
j'essaie de faire maximum PAM regarde
comme je suis allé vite là maths à tout
à l'heure j'étais en mode studio donc je
l'ai mis mais ça s'est pas vu
histoire de fou lire des nouvelles je
l'ai entraîné encore pour le cheveu mais
là on en a on a dit qu'on faisait une
pause mais rien à voir un gamin elle dit
bah j'ai envie de partir juste assez dit
elle a pas compris que je jouais sans
voile ça allait faire un peu de bruit ah
oui
je te jure une fois elle m'a dit tu
arrives à prononcer mon nom je m'étais
entraîné et tout elle m'a aidé
un cours dessus
du coup donc il y a bien eu tout B3
maths
on peut croquer le pion
ça fera trois pions plus il va essayer
un KFC c'est trouver un
tu veux monter il y a un réseau de
perpète qui existe c'est un cavalier FC
et qui avait déjà elle est belle
d'ailleurs avec le matin rap si on veut
plus de la perpète
si je vais de l'autre côté rué chaque
j'ai intérêt de revenir là sur la
position initiale d'accepter la perpète
avec les Noirs dans ce cas là parce que
sur wash 8 il y a le célèbre Matara avec
le tandem tour cavalier voilà donc dans
le tournoi B c'est assez drôle il va y
avoir peut-être une hulule et que des
victoires OK ou dépend donc ça a joué un
vous voyez ceux qui sont invités au tata
si il joue donc tour à trois jouets de
la part de ventes forest Matthieu
de plus et à 12 ça commence à faire cher
parce qu'après ce sera B3 tour à deux
aussi etc
ça va se voir au bout la trois pions
[Musique]
c'est vraiment fini facile
on va voir ça
revient de quoi avant
petit jeu
comme ça
c'est important le roi à venir sur la
première
et là son roi est tranquille et le Pione
est pas passé avant que ça soit le cas
BIM BIM BIM BIM bim bam boum voilà
quelque chose comme ça si on peut
trouver du contre jaune mais on n'y
croit pas trop à 4 non il a joué H4
H5 à 3 à 3 dames C5 vas-y c'est ça qu'il
faut regarder
donc
c'est 5 de Mathieu pour faire une
embrouille avec dames C8 et dame F5
alors là il y a un truc qui est assez
professionnel qui marche des fois c'est
F6
pour mettre dame ici c'est ça
va pas être le seul coup mais
t'as pas l'air convaincu alors ça c'est
assez professionnel mais j'ai pas envie
de la voir dans le baba à la fin de
cette
j'ai essayé de garder un arbre tout de
suite
[Musique]
j'étais hyper content tu as vu j'étais
bien nu hein
et en fait ça marche pas parce que vous
voulez aller dans la suite et tu peux
le faire au coup d'avant du coup
j'ai regardé je me suis appliqué en plus
mat en fait F6 c'est malin il veut
ramener sa dame ici et mettre son rond
en H8
c'est pas perpète
au prochain
donc ok victoire on regarde plus cette
partie quasiment juste d'un coin de
l'oeil au cas où mais ça va gagner tu
peux faire d'un bien dans ces deux je
pense c'est encore plus simple
[Musique]
échec non non fait chèque d'abord je
voulais jouer ça pour dame 8 dans F7
mais il y aura de OK
dame D8
à 2
d'un F5
et si tu fais
donc oui bon les vannes de toute façon
ça fait un moment qu'on en parle alors
ça a avancé un petit peu après tout
reprend un 4 kf6 B3 on en avait parlé en
place
il est pas loin mais le problème c'est
qu'on peut jamais autour des 7 nuls mais
on peut jamais en plus enterrer le roi
c'est-à-dire qu'il est pas obligé du
tout d'aller parler c'est tellement
gagnant facile tu vas en C8
ça va être on va voir que ça en fait à
la fin tu as raison Mathieu il a raté le
gain qui aurait pu
clôturer le tournoi mais il doit pas
être loin regarde il y a je Kai D6 c'est
très sérieux de la part de Magnus il
veut quoi sans qu'il prend ses 7
très sérieux très sérieux
alors quel est français 7 dans ma 4 ou
dans ma tête
dans ma carte ça a l'air plus naturel
parce que dans ma tête je laisse
cavalier aussi ouais mais c'est
peut-être pas plus mal comme ça c'est
fait
parce que là il peut garder le cavalier
en fait il y a encore du taf j'avais
omis je me suis dit qu'il était si c'est
il fait le bloqueur voilà c'est pas un
vrai bloqueur mat
non mais peut-être genre damasut qui
avait lieu six
on a un dénouement du tournoi la caméra
la caméra bien vu Matt
hop et là vous allez voir le dénouement
du tournoi avec
c'est déjà levé non non tu vas voir tu
vas voir Mathieu j'étais tellement
réactif grâce à toi quand même
je me suis pris la pub encore
je l'ai fait une fois
incroyable quoi justement il faut pas
non ça mais je te jure tu vas voir ça y
est c'est incroyable c'est incroyable tu
vas voir tu vas voir ça va être bon mais
ça c'est pas de ma faute et vous allez
voir juste au moment après ça va être
terrible pour toi tu vas tu vas
apprécier
c'était quand même un très beau
un très beau move voilà
c'est terrible alors j'ai réactualisé
hyper vite mais il a pas voulu prendre
sa feuille de parti tu as noté
comme vous propose l'abonnement en fait
je pense que si je le demande je peux la
vendre
oui si si si ouais je pense que
je puisse l'avoir je pense que mais
quand même diamant sur sur chetcom
en voilà bah alors terrible quand même
vous l'avez vu quand tu es à niche oui
bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr terrible pour
abusa torov et à la caméra
qu'il a gagné oh je suis content pour
lui parce que je trouve qu'il a comme
d'hab il prend les échecs sérieusement
et j'ai envie de dire cette semaine ça
montre ce qu'il est jeune et ceux qui
prennent les échecs sérieusement mais je
joue bien
je m'a juste je mettrai juste Ding à
part parce que on en parlait ce matin
avec Kevin pas toi bordel
c'est il m'a fait l'analogie c'est comme
Ding c'est comme un joueur de tennis qui
joue sans servir
il est aussi tu as la pression tu as
bossé comme un dingue là pendant 2-3
mois il a dû faire que ça comme un
dingue Roger aux échecs ça lui a fait du
bien bon le problème c'est qu'il perdent
un point
ça fait mal
bon après il s'est remis dans le bain
mais ça règle le résultat vraiment
comment je le répète je suis pas hyper
fan et je trouve qu'il mérite cette
semaine
mais après voilà j'ai envie de dire
est-ce que c'est pas mieux comme de pas
gagner ton premier tournoi
je sais pas quoi
on se croirait sur sur TF1 m'attaque tu
sais les analyses tu sais avec les
plateaux télé
ou sur RMC maths tu vas bientôt être
consultant sur une grande radio une
grande TV
tu vas raser tu diras beaucoup plus de
conneries mais tu seras hyper bien payé
quoi Matt marrant marrant mais oui oui
et là normalement je dois rebondir sur
ce que tu as dit dire ah tu as raison
mat c'est vrai que c'est une bonne chose
pour lui pour la chaud il va être un peu
déçu
du tout c'était de la merde
[Rires]
tout ça en fait ça serait pas mal ça tu
vas pouvoir aller prendre le goûter
bientôt
au moins tu pourras me laisser sans
aucun problème ça monte a envie de
rejoindre ta famille un match c'est que
tu as du monde chez toi donc bah tu
hésites pas si un moment il y a vraiment
zéro problème vu les particules restent
les von Levon bah tu t'en fous depuis le
départ et en plus tu vas le voir perdre
en fait j'ai l'impression que tu as
envie de rester pour les voir les bonnes
perdre et après
la caméra ou pas ah il faut il faut que
je la cherche tu me donnes beaucoup de
travail mat mais maintenant que j'ai
compris que je pouvais faire des des
recadrage je peux te faire un petit
plaisir je vais te faire un petit
plaisir
je vais essayer de te mettre ça et je te
laisse avec ce cavalier français 7
potentiel il a pas encore été joué car
il est français 7 en fait il est à Rio
en train de réfléchir alors hop
le petit changement
en quasi direct
parce que bien sûr la forme faire bosser
un petit peu il faut que je le trouve
tac donc ça il y a ceux qui connaissent
espagnol mais pas à l'aise dans le sang
ou la les blancs enfin il en a joué avec
les Noirs
j'ai pas vraiment beaucoup de souvenirs
de Ding je vois ça Ding je vais plutôt
les mars
les commentateurs ne sont pas payés à
l'heure
je crois pas cette année pour ça très
bien
parce qu'il y a qu'une partie et quand
ils font nul en une heure
ça pourrait être aussi un forfait pour
la quinzaine quoi bon après ou les trois
semaines enfin c'est long quoi
pour l'ensemble
pourtant j'adore à rognon pour moi
c'était un de mes joueurs préférés
pendant longtemps mais là tu reviens
avec cette mentalité ben moi je t'ai
pour parrain mais trouve finir par trois
avec toi ça montre une force de
caractère incroyable
donc très content pour lui en plus c'est
un mec marron
et qui gagne le pari à ses Paris entre
toi et
Stéphane c'est ça
gagne
carcène sur le podium la remontée de
Carsen on avait fait un pari comme ça
mais il y avait pas que celui-là pour
l'instant il a plus gagné parce que il
pariait sur les victoires d'Abdou et moi
sur les victoires de Kemer si tu
regardes bien Mathieu kamer il m'a pas
rapporté une fortune
des émotions des émotions il m'a
rapporté est-ce que Kemer a gagné
je la trouve pas c'est vraiment la
poisse à chaque fois
allez là
franchement ouais bah hier par exemple
vous pouvez voir ma vidéo
c'est un fou furieux toi
il va falloir qu'il se calme qui se
fasse un répertoire un peu plus dans son
style j'ai l'impression qu'il
s'éparpille un peu trop
mais la Colona je me fais un peu peur
à moins qu'il est fou je sens
[Musique]
ans
la nickel il y a rien là maintenant je
sais bien je sais pas il y a un bug sur
cette cam c'est pas possible
tu vas voir des belles choses la
technique dans tout ça splendeur
ça c'est peut-être mieux d'ailleurs
c'est con ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
donc là il y a plein de plus pour qu'un
scène et un par un bien de finir j'ai
enfin trouvé sa caméra je suis vert
j'arrive pas à la mettre mais je te jure
que c'est vrai elle est mal
terrible terrible je sais même pas si je
vais réussir à la mettre avant
incroyable voilà
et pourquoi il est en transparence
voilà il y a un coup
voilà j'ai réussi à faire un truc
incroyable
discute voilà et voilà là vous êtes
contents regardez profitez-en c'était
beaucoup de travail pour pour cette
image de parram bien contents de gagner
sa petite partie de la je pense pas que
la commenter demain quand même
malheureusement je peux pas mais un
livre c'est la veste il est ouverture il
fait non puis c'est pas où mettre les
pièces l'autre complique boom ça griffe
de qualité le défense
il faut faire comme par Ham
ouais c'est vrai que il a des chemises
assez particulières Evan
et non on va couper le chauffage c'est
la veste officielle chascom pour les
finales voilà une veste je vous la
conseille
qui est bien 3 jours de suite il est pas
bien il est très bien il va finir 5 x
classement mis à jour
alors le classement peut-être la
victoire encore
la victoire
donc il termine à 7
il va terminer 5e dans 6e il va finir il
va passer devant un rognan incroyable
je vous mets la seule partie voilà ça a
l'air complètement gagnant pour les
Noirs parce qu'ils ont l'attaque et un
plan de plus
par contre faut calculer un peu le
défense un peu nul
donc je vais vous mettre hop on peut pas
jouer d'un macaque
ouais bon ça c'est vrai faut calculer un
peu tu as pas
demain je pense que je vais analyser la
partie de
guéri parce qu'il gagne le tournoi avec
une victoire
merci be je vais les recherches c'est
vrai que là c'est la totale aujourd'hui
c'est la totale
et c'est qui visuelle on sait qui c'est
derrière
[Musique]
parce que quand on avait Laurent Laurent
avec Billère maintenant
il n'a pas dit voilà
en tout cas merci pour les mots sympas
oui surtout que c'est ma première au
niveau de la technique d'habitude je
gère pas mais ça le fait il y a des
petites choses à savoir et après tout
roule
c'est bien ce que je pensais Étienne
mais j'étais pas sûr que c'était toi
d'accord ok
salut à toi j'aurais dit
ah oui oui oui
[Rires]
[Musique]
qui s'occupe de la régie pendant le
chemin de France jeune mais je ne savais
pas qui était budget quand même ça
aurait pu mais je savais pas
Étienne macro c'est ça
c'est pas mal
bon du coup ben ça va le faire
maintenant pour
pour Magnus va finir si en gagnant ça
deuxième ex aequo avec Abdou
quand même
on commence à gagner
un coup comme fois je suis qui a quand
même du sens
est-ce qu'il y a une vraie menace en
menace faut aussi faut aussi ça
marcherait il y aurait roi G6 quand même
ouais donc non je peux faire dans ma
carte alors du coup
un dama 4 vous prenez un membre
ou après
donc tu dois je fous bouge
c'est pareil pour la deuxième place on
s'en fout ouais
est-ce que je peux pas vous faire un
petit
un petit kiff là vous voulez une caméra
en plus avec les deux joueurs qu'on voit
encore mieux
ouais
je vais quand même essayer je vais quand
même essayer j'ai compris des trucs là
hop
j'ai passé un mois
je vais faire des trucs de dingue là
fort c'est plus de l'ordi on nous dit
ouais en fait t'empêche juste le contre
jeu à base de la dame qui rentre sur la
colonache tu peux jouer au 4 ah c'est
complètement
si l'ordi le dit en plus
si l'ordi le dites
il y a pas mal de chaînes où ils ont
quelqu'un pour la régie
là c'est keV à la Régie je peux vous
dire qui est si les gens me voyaient
j'envoie du rêve par moment au niveau au
niveau régi OK
c'est bien mon petit papier j'ai fini
par comprendre à l'histoire des camions
a fallu quelques petits temps adaptation
c'est pas trop dur je le sais bien
alors je l'ai trouvé je pense
superbe
maintenant c'est complètement gagnant en
plus en jeu
ou trois joueurs tempo
est-ce qu'on fait j'ai trois ou quatre
j'aime bien pour faire Damas 8
est-ce que tu as vu ce petit changement
de Cam discret
l'échiquier la totale je sens que tu
veux la totale je peux tenter un truc
dans quel temps
je peux faire un truc de dingue une
dinguerie
un peu risqué mais c'est pas grave c'est
pas grave là on est on est en roue libre
pour cette fin de stream donc du coup je
peux tenter des trucs au niveau des
câbles
tu sais ce que je vais tenter mat
le grand écran le copier-coller le
copier coller toujours risque toujours
risqué pour moi mais je vais tenter
oser un copier-coller
ça pas fait tout ça fait ce que je
pensais
ouais c'est pas ça que j'aurais dû faire
c'est pas grave
je tente un truc je chante le Move c'est
un peu dégueu
j'ai vraiment envie de regarder la
finale j'ai regardé balayette deux
derniers matchs déjà en poule j'avais
pas pu suivre parce que bah c'était
difficile de suivre quoi tout simplement
et
[Musique]
OK
je peux faire ça aussi vous proposer ça
alors vous allez me dire
ce que vous aimez bien cette vue le
ramasse regarde je peux te régaler
mais ça en grand c'est un grand c'est le
grand écran c'est un peu comme le stade
de foot là vous imaginez les pièces un
peu au loin voilà
tout le monde trouve ça super voilà
du coup vous imaginez un peu plus un peu
plus les commentaires de maths un peu
plus lointain
on se plaise on peut on peut faire des
belles choses en tout cas les images
sont belles voilà
mais c'est pas mal
on verra on mettra l'échiquier à chaque
fois que Magnus joue
à chaque fois il y a un coup je mets les
il faut animer un ce genre de fin de
stream c'est pas évident donc on fait
notre possible faudrait que je regarde
ce que ça a donné sur l'autre
fait des bêtises je pense même
et le Danemark est largement
vous voyez ce que je veux dire
il y a ici il a 18 ans
à 40 quand tu lui parles avec son petit
cheveux sur la langue il fait plutôt 18
ans
avec Niall Sarine
autant aux échecs alors là c'est nos
vedettes autant en foot c'est des
vedettes aussi mais dans l'autre sens je
peux te dire que c'est bien modeste
[Musique]
ces deux styles non il est un peu au
dessus génial
mais les plus fragiles et plus fragiles
on joue dans le chat
bon il se passe pas grand chose c'est le
défaut de cette cadence
un peu c'est un peu la fin ça retombe un
petit peu je pense à 17h30 je te laisse
alors 10h20 peut encore tenir 10 minutes
et ben on a marre et moche j'ai jamais
dit à Stéphane j'en ai marre à 19h30
j'arrête mais comme on a commencé deux
heures avant c'est 17h30
non je m'amuse un peu avec les caméras
voilà j'ai fait réapparaître les pièces
pour Matt salut manquer les pièces un
petit peu
franchement les gens je conseille si
vous avez un peu de temps à perdre il y
a la chaîne Youtube de ta ta steel qui
faisait des interviews tous les jours
des vainqueurs et de trois parties
importantes et c'était
[Musique]
pas mal et salut à tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent pour cette fin de stream
que Mathieu te pose une question est-ce
qu'il reste des places pour le stage de
chaque à Paris avec Mazet
je m'appelle pas Mazet
lequel parce que là il y en a il est en
stage en ce moment là il y a plus de
place
le stage il est fini dans une heure
pour le prochain je sais pas ça il faut
lui écrire un livre il a un site de
coaching mais moi on fait un stage avec
lui en mai le 13 14 mai à Bordeaux
on n'a pas encore fait la pub mais dans
le Bordelais il y en a qui vont prendre
notre
et dans la bonne humeur et c'est assez
cool ouais 13 14 mai c'est ça
c'est noté vous notez un ce qui habite
dans le coin
on aime il y en a qui prennent le train
on a une fois il y a un Belge qui est
venu
bien sûr c'est dans une cave non mais
non mais par contre ceux qui viennent
peuvent voir la cave parce que c'est là
où j'ai appris à jouer aux échecs les
locaux avant on faisait dans le club de
tennis de Seb mais je sais pas le même
sport
mais maintenant on le fait au club
d'échec un des clubs d'échelle de
Bordeaux et du coup c'est au club où
j'ai appris à jouer depuis j'ai 10 ans
et tu vois pareil
c'est au club je suis venu pour la
première fois en 96 ans
et le club est très beau très bien placé
en plein centre-ville mais du coup il y
a déjà les échiquiers c'est comme
l'avantage
et le concept c'est des échecs toute la
journée le soir apéro pizza
et le deuxième jour on refait ça et
quand on habite pour finir en gros
tu as raté quelque chose 13 ronde à la
cadence
1h40 plus 30
50 minutes plus 30 pour les 20 prochains
coups après le 40e
et ensuite 15 minutes pour 60e pour
finir pour clore le spectacle mais
toujours avec 30 secondes de plus donc
c'est très très très très long
à Eva il se passerait à Paris mais si en
ce moment il y a un stage après moi j'en
ai jamais fait à Paris c'est ça que tu
veux dire j'ai jamais fait ça à Paris
mais à Paris il y en a plein oui il y a
beaucoup de choses sur Paris c'est là où
ça ou ça se passe entre guillemets mais
il y a dans d'autres endroits il y en a
Lyon la partie mais il faudrait que j'en
fasse un appareil bien sûr ça marche
bien oui c'est plus facile c'est plus
facile
après
Montpellier bientôt je crois que c'est
possible mais allez regarder il y a un
site Internet est-ce qu'il a mis à jour
son site c'est pas sûr
tout ça se fait là je sais quelque chose
tous les prochains stages
maintenant effectivement il a pas mis à
jour les annonces c'est quand même sur
les réseaux peut-être
matsur sur Twitter je l'ai vu la
quand tu cliques sur stage et ça te met
[Rires]
mais on sait que ça existe on sait que
ça existe
non attends je peux vous retrouver
ouais voilà c'est ça Twitter insta
et il restait une place au dernier stage
millions c'est rempli
celle-là les dates
je peux le copier dans le chat
tu m'envoies le lien et je le mettrai
non
je suis 29 janvier avec la vie mais là
c'est en ce moment Paris 4-5 mars stage
100% final complet bon après on
négociant c'est peut-être pas vraiment
complet Montpellier 6 7 mai avec Libye
et sa baie moi donc 13 14 mai à Bordeaux
telle responsable bordelais
non c'est celle qui gère mais après moi
je suis de Bordeaux dans cette plus
facile
c'est quoi le niveau minimum maximum
pour les stages alors Mathieu je sais
pas il y a pas de vraiment de niveau bah
c'est on fait en fait on fait de groupe
de niveau
j'ai eu des personnes qui avaient appris
à jouer genre 6 mois avant ah oui
d'accord un peu dur mais ils apprennent
des choses après le plus haut on a eu
autour de 2000 moi je limite mon stage
pour que ce soit pas c'est plus tôt par
le haut que je limite le bas aussi mais
il faut savoir jouer minimum on sent
j'aime bien dire 111800 c'est pas mal
ouais on sent du sens c'est le top on a
après maintenant on a eu le profil je
sais pas si tu en as eu un mec je me
rappelle toujours un jean 2002 en Bullet
sur litchi c'est la première fois qu'il
touche un échiquier
[Musique]
E4 jouet bah c'est le meilleur
en même temps ça ouvre la diago
[Musique]
c'est G3 bientôt c'est beaucoup de
choses toutes les menaces
ça va bientôt bientôt
est-ce que quelqu'un a lu le bouquin de
Bauer sur la lotine non ben type perso
je vous ai dit soit on joue les Quatre
Fantastiques soit merci lilio mais oui
je sais qui tu es je t'ai reconnu
derrière ton prénom dans le cul non non
non
mais
tu vas sortir un peu les paquets des
fois exactement
et fou prends B6 n'arrange pas la
position
par contre pourquoi son idée c'est quoi
cette dame à 8 fois 5
comment ça gagne là
il joue beaucoup de choses en fait il
joue énormément de choses il joue
quasiment tout il peut jouer la une
française qui va laisser 6 variante
Guimard
connaît le nom de ça ouais ouais parce
que j'ai des élèves qui jouent ça enfin
j'ai montré cette française et c'était
moyen c'était OK
l'huile de Bauer ouais ouais mais le
problème c'est que l'ouverture et ben
moi j'ai joué la liquide hein très
longtemps ma femme joue tout le temps
sur internet
mais c'est pas terrible honnêtement
c'est pas bon enfin moi je dis
quand j'ai battu Bowers
mais soit on joue la française la
carrocane la sienne 4 5 pour le long
terme c'est mieux de commencer par ses
ouvertures et je trouve que si c'est C6
sont plus abordables que 5 et C5 parce
que sur E5 et c'est 5 il y a beaucoup
plus de choix pour les adversaires donc
dans un premier temps si vous débutant
ou amateur premier niveau
carrocane et français c'est très bien et
ça peut être joué après sur le long
terme
je casse tu conseilles toi matos
après E6 moi j'ai joué la française
c'est une mes premières ouvertures aussi
je trouve que c'est vraiment bien
je trouve qu'il y a quand même non c'est
compliqué et des Coréens qui peuvent mal
se passer mais après stratégiquement
c'est très simple en fait sur l'avant tu
sais je fais le C5 le plus rapide parce
que faut F5 c'est trop compliqué enfin
tu vois bah c'est j'essaie de trouver
des billets dans dans les ouvertures
pour pour simplifier le travail quoi
voilà bon après c'est des temps en
projet de faire un répertoire car au
calme pour les noirs avec biscuit mais
on l'a commencé on l'a pas fait je crois
j'avais commencé à le préparer on l'a
jamais tourné si j'imagine que vous êtes
bien pris
ouais
par contre mais j'ai pas vu en tout cas
[Musique]
ce qu'il a ce qui s'est pris
je vais vous amener dans le challenger
tu vas essayer voilà ça chie hyper bien
il part d'un
dernier coup
le guili ça sent le matarab vous vous
rappelez tout à l'heure on a parlé du
matarab si la tour était en C7 tu aurais
perpétude ah non il n'y aurait pas
perpétuel c'est un dérivé 26 10
un petit truc à discuter
il va y avoir que des parties décisives
dans le tournoi plein la gueule et donne
avec 10 sur 13 quand même là c'est bon
c'est impressionnant OK
bonus mais vous voyez un matin pas rare
il y a quelques échecs mais pas grand
chose donc du coup on retourne
faire à Ton faux-2 peut revenir ah non
ça marche pas
même ça ça marcherait peut-être pour eux
deux faut prendre un 4 faut prendre ces
quatre
je peux pas prendre il y a maths ici il
faudra regarder mais il veut passer le
fou ici et faire du mal
il y aurait
pas terrible quand même mais bon ok de
toute façon on va le faire dame 5
d'abord et on peut après faire tous les
idées qu'on veut
voler ton idée
parce que parce que c'est toujours dur
d'abandonner et puis on a vu des
retournements bon là il y a toujours un
petit délai on comprend qu'on est foutu
et on digère le fait d'être foutu on
abandonne
trois probablement
ou c'est 5
en plus maintenant il a plus de contrôle
parce que faut aussi se faire Roger 7
étapes pas un échec non c'est la crise
ça va être bien tout abandon mais ouais
c'est toujours et puis les jours indiens
ils continuent longtemps
il continue un peu plus
il se battent mais bon là c'est
ça pas duré longtemps
ah oui
fait notre possible avec avec ce qu'on a
et on n'a pas on a plus grand chose fin
du stata style dans quelques minutes
oui à tort clairement en politique colle
plus ouais plus
vous êtes amateur débutant plus vous
devez continuer pour comprendre un peu
comment finir une partie en fait
si plus vous adversaires ont des chances
de merde c'est bien pour ça qu'il faut
continuer on apprend on carotte
rester en vie dans les positions foutues
bah c'est hyper important en fait il
faut aussi gagner quand vous jouez mal
en fait je voulais pas publier mais en
général c'est un tournoi il est pas
terrible mais par contre ils ont des des
cachets pour venir qui sont plutôt bons
j'avais vu je crois que c'était 60000 ou
quelque chose comme ça
bien
sûr c'est toute proportion gardée vous
l'avez compris ce que dit ce que dit
maths évidemment il y en a qui se
mettrait bien les 60 000 mais bon il y a
des centres il y a des millions à gagner
parce que
ça a l'air fort
[Musique]
enfin je pense pas que tu es un mauvais
coup ici non c'est dur de trouver un
mauvais coup et d'un mec ça fait chaque
donc il y aurait aussi contre échec
vous aussi
oui tu as tout à fait raison je peux
quand même maintenant du coup
ça va tu me donnes rien
même j'ai trois ce que je veux mais bon
c'est sûr que c'est un peu dommage je te
lâche
autant autant garder la pression
[Musique]
bah du coup tu sais quoi je vais faire
dame 2 on en a parlé
[Musique]
je voulais plutôt faire d'un mec au
début mais c'est vrai que Matt a trouvé
un petit truc pour embêter il faut aussi
si je me cache en E7 il fait dans ma 3
il contrôle il y a peut-être pardon
croisé 6 in extremis pour être peinard
et ça gagnerait vraiment facile aussi
depuis le début tu vois il empêche de
recontre jaune dame de jouer par Magnus
il fixe la dame ici et si tu fais dames
C2
garde une bonne réserve de temps je vous
rappelle qu'à un quart d'heure
supplémentaire au 60e mais je pense
qu'il n'y arrivera pas et rien ici au
60e
donc si Dame C2 il y a des mains dans
les quatre
ah tu veux une blague un super gaillard
ça fait plaisir c'est utiliser
l'ouverture de dernier pack cool est-ce
que tu veux une blague allez maintenant
c'est nul
tu es quasiment maths avec les Blancs et
en plus les pions noirs sont plus
avancés donc tu choisis ta mort mais là
ça va pas le faire gel
donc tu fais référence à la cause du
carter je pense j'ai fait un pack sur la
colle du carter
tu sais du coup c'est les buts
moi je manque à tous mes devoirs
non c'est intéressant après je pense
qu'il y a un ordre de il y a des trucs
qui vont bien pour la non mais moi on me
la jouer une fois ça m'emmerdait un peu
mais d'ailleurs j'avais joué ça contre
toi à Capelle mais après tu m'avais un
petit peu
oui c'est ça voilà c'est ça
t'avais pas voulu d'accord
il faut être deux
tours et on s'attire mon la totale c'est
cool Dame des trois Damas 3 c'est quoi
le plan là il sent que c'est la fin il
sent que c'est la fin donc
en fait l'ordinateur du matin 9
on est pas une température
[Musique]
forest ça se préparait qu'on leur
diabète c'est pas tant que ça c'est pas
ton ça et c'est tellement bien préparé
que
comme dit Mathieu pas de besoin et voilà
c'est signé
vous avez vu Mathieu a réussi à rester
jusqu'à la fin parce que ils sentaient
ils sentaient le coup Mathieu que ça
allait abandonner très très vite merci à
toi à cette Escom d'avoir couvert ce
tournoi bah ouais merci à toi Mathieu
c'était en tout cas plaisir on a pas
l'occasion de se voir souvent mais très
content d'avoir fait ça avec toi c'était
cool on a pu bénéficier de tous tes
conseils tu as bien senti les choses
dans beaucoup de situations et c'était
très agréable de commenter cela avec ce
gros retournement de situation et la
victoire d'anis guéri dans ce tournoi et
devant Abdou sa torov et Magnus qui est
revenu de très très loin donc merci à
tous aussi d'avoir animé le chat tous
ceux qui ont participé tous ceux qui ont
regardé cela vous pouvez retrouver
Mathieu sur la chaîne Youtube de
blitstream il en a parlé il fait des
analyses régulières Mathieu tu as
peut-être quelque chose à rajouter sur
ça
non ça va sortir demain matin sac tu
nous as dit
la dernière du tournoi bon bah super
donc si vous voulez nous retrouver vous
n'hésitez pas pour évolution échec aussi
il y a une plateforme en ligne il y a
des stages il y a beaucoup de choses
aussi on vous laisse regarder chaîne
Youtube vous avez tout ce qu'il faut si
vous voulez continuer à nous retrouver
en tout cas il y aura d'autres
événements sur chatcom à venir en tout
cas on va s'arrêter là vous souhaitez un
très très bon week-end et on fait un
gros bisou merci Mathieu merci à tous et
bonne fin d'après-midi bye bye bye bon
dimanche et n'oubliez pas le hand ce
soir
salut à tous